TAKING TIME AND YOUR WEDNESDAY
DO YOU JOIN THIS INFORMATIONAL
HEARING BETWEEN THE CENTER
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE IN THE SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER COMMITTEE.
WE WANT TAKE A MOMENT TO START
OUT AND THANK THE GENTLEMAN TO
MY RIGHT.
CHAIRMAN STERN IN HIS ENTIRE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PARTNERSHIP ON
BRINGING THESE.
ALL STARS WHO OUR PANELISTS
TOGETHER TODAY AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND EASTERN AND IT'S GREAT
TO PARTNER WITH YOU SIR.
WOULD LIKE TO BE TO LAY OUT THE
AGENDA AND BOTH HAVE SOME
OPENING REMARKS.
THE LAST DECADE IN CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING.
DUE TO WILD AND FIRES.
NEVER IN OUR HISTORY HAVE WE
SEEN SUCH DEVASTATION.
PAIN AND DEATH.
CAUSED BY SOME OF THE LARGEST
WILDLAND FIRES IN AMERICAN
HISTORY. FOURTEEN OF THE TWENTY
LARGEST WILDLAND FIRES IN TEN OF
THE TWENTY MOST DESTRUCTIVE.
HAVE ALL TAKEN PLACE.
IN THE LAST DECADE.
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME QUICK STATISTICS THE UNITED
STATES WILDFIRE SEASON IN THE
WEST.
IN THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WAS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY EIGHT DAYS.
IN. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWO DAYS.
TWICE AS MANY ACRES HAVE BURNED
ON AVERAGE EACH YEAR AFTER THE
YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND COMPARED TO THE
AVERAGE IN THE NINETEEN SIXTIES.
AND IN THE LAST DECADE WE SEEN A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION DEAD
AND OR DYING TREES MOSTLY.
IN THE COASTAL ANCIER RANGES.
WHATEVER YOU WANNA CALL IT.
CALIFORNIA'S NEW REALITY OR OUR
NEW NORMAL.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS.
WE MUST CHANGE THE WAY THE STATE
ADVANCES FIRE PROTECTION A
RESPONSE.
FIRE PREVENTION AND THE WAY WE
BUILD OR CANDIDLY NOT BUILD IN
FIRE PRONE AREAS.
THE DAY OF RECKONING IS HERE.
HEY WHY OWL THIS STATE IS
ADVANCING ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IN ENHANCE RESOURCES FOR FIRE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO THE
RESIDENTS OF THE STATE TO HAVE
HARD CONVERSATIONS ABOUT WHAT
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
DOING RIGHT.
AND WRONG WHEN THEY PLAN FOR AND
POTENTIALLY APPROVED DEVELOPMENT.
IN FIRE PRONE AREAS.
AND CANDIDLY THAT IS THE
DISCUSSION THAT HAS MOSTLY BEEN
ABSENT.
IN THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT FIRE
PREVENTION RESPONSE.
WE'VE NOT BEEN AS CANDID AND OR
DIRECT ON BUILDING IN FIRE PRONE
AREAS.
WE HAVE BROUGHT EXPERTS TOGETHER
FROM ACROSS THE GOLDEN STATE
TODAY TO INFORM OUR
DELIBERATIONS IN.
ANSWER VITAL QUESTIONS.
ON HOW WE CAN BUILD MORE
RESILIENT.
FIND LANEY'S PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT APPROVALS.
AND ENHANCE SAFETY REGULATIONS
IN FIRE PRONE REGIONS ACROSS THE
STATE.
AGAIN YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE AN
ALL STAR GROUP OF PANELISTS
TODAY FROM THE FEDERAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS AND NON PROFITS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND I'M GRATEFUL AGAIN TO BE
ABLE TO FROM OUT OF IT FROM
THERE AND GONNA BE TURN IT OVER
TO SENATOR STERN FOR INTERNET
REMARKS IN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALL OF YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
YOUR COMMITTEES BEEN TREMENDOUS
IN BUILDING THIS HEARING AND FOR
YOUR COURAGE AND AND ASSISTANCE
THROUGH THESE FIRES AYE AYE AYE
AYE AYE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU --
YOU GROW UP QUICKLY ED DOING
DOING THIS WORK AND WATCHING
YOUR WHOLE HOME TOWN BURNED DOWN.
IS A LOT SO YOUR LEADERSHIP NOT
JUST AT THE POLICY LEVEL BUT AT
THE VERY HUMAN LEVEL IS MUCH
APPRECIATED --
THESE ARE VERY HUMAN
CATASTROPHES.
AND THIS PEOPLE IT'S HARD.
TO FEEL CONSTRAINED IN YOUR
CHOICES WHEN EVERYTHING DOES
SEEM NORMAL IN YOUR LIVING YOUR
LIFE AND YOU WANT.
TO MOVE INTO A NEW HOUSE AND YOU
WANT.
TO GO ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS BEGIN.
HEY RELEVANT TO WHAT THE CLIMB
IT'S DOING OR WHERE WILD VIRUS
ARE WHERE YOU ARE ON A SOME
HAZARD MAP.
IT'S MUCH MORE CONVENIENT TO
JUST -- LIB
LIVER BOLIVIA SLEEP BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT LUXURY ANYMORE AND I
THINK TODAY IS PART OF THAT SORT
OF SOBERING UP THAT WE ALL HAVE
TO DO IS CALIFORNIANS AND MANY
CALIFORNIANS WHO.
EITHER WE'LL BE WATCHING THIS OR
OR NOT WATCHING THIS MAY LIVE AT
RISK AND THEY DON'T EVEN REALIZE
IT -- AND
CITY AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS THAT
HAVE PRIMARY JURISDICTION OVER
LAND USE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
YOU KNOW.
THEY MAY NOT BE AS A WHERE I'D
SO I'M I'M REALLY HOPING THAT
WITH THE EXPERTISE PRESENT IN
THE ROOM TODAY AND ALL THESE
PANELISTS --
THAT WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA BRING
SOME SOBRE TRUTH TO THIS
CONVERSATION --
TO ASK SOME HARD QUESTIONS --
BUT ALSO STILL PRESERVE.
THIS LIFESTYLE THAT HAS SO MANY
FOLKS SEMI RURAL SUBURBAN
COMMUNITIES HAVE COME TO EXPECT --
SO WITH THAT I'D I'D TURN IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE CAN WORK THROUGH THE
FIRST PANEL.
OKAY MUCH MISTRUST YEAR.
MISTER CHAIR WAS A NOVEMBER
SATURDAY I WAS WORKING AT THE AT
MY OFFICE I WAS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR.
AND I COULD SEE THE SANTA ANA
MOUNTAINS FROM MY OFFICE I WAS
ON THE FIFTH FLOOR.
AND I STARTED SEEING SMOKE.
WHICH WE WERE WARNED IT WAS
EERIE AMENITY AND WE ALREADY HAD
A SHERIFF'S HELICOPTER UP IN THE
AIR ALL MORNING LONG.
MY BROTHER LIVED WHERE THE SMOKE
WAS COMING FROM MY YOUNGEST
CAN'T.
I CALLED HIM UP AND SAID WOULD
YOU DOING TODAY.
THIS IS WHAT I TAKE MY OLDEST TO
SOCCER PRACTICE AND I SAID I
DON'T THINK YOU ARE COULD YOU GO
OUTSIDE.
AND JUST LOOK AROUND AND TELL ME
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD BECAUSE I CAN SEE
IT FROM HERE.
THAT WAS CALLED THE FREEWAY
COMPLEX FIRE.
WAS TRAGICALLY LOST SO MANY
HOMES.
I TOURED THE NEXT DAY SUNDAY
WITH CHRIS CONCEPTION WHO IS NOW
HE'S UP HERE NOW.
THERE WAS THE ROUGHEST TOUR I
HAVE EVER.
EVER BEEN ON SO YOU TRY AND
THINK WHAT CAN WE DO WHEN I WAS
A PRACTICING.
THE FIRE TO PROVIDE MIGHT MY
ALARM COMPANY CALLED AND SAID.
YOUR BUILDINGS ON FIRE.
I BEAT THE FIRE DEPARTMENT TO MY
OFFICE.
AND WE COULD NOT FIND.
ANYTHING NO SMOKE NO NOTHING.
WAS PUZZLING THE NEXT MORNING
THE ALARM WENT OFF AGAIN BUT WE
WERE ALL ON THE BUILDING SITE.
I WENT OUTSIDE TO LOOK AT THE
CONNECTION FROM THE ELECTRIC
LINE TO THE BUILDING AND IT WAS
SO HOT THAT THE COPPER WAS
DRIPPING.
MORE OPEN ON MIGHT SHAKE ROOF.
AND I SAID YOU OKAY NOW WE GOTTA
GET WATER GET OUT YOU KNOW WHAT.
SO.
I WORKED ON LEGISLATION HOW DO
WE PREVENT ELECTRICAL FIGHTERS
HOW DO WE HOW DO WE PREVENT WENT
OUT WHEN A TELEPHONE POLE WITH
ELECTRIC APPLIANCES.
HIT AND IT SNAPS HOW DO WE
PREVENT THE SPARKS.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES BECAUSE EVERYONE
VOTED FOR THAT BILL. FOURTEEN
SIXTY THREE THREE YEARS AGO BUT
BUT THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT.
AND NOW WE'VE HAD MAJOR FIRES
CAUSED BY ELECTRIC LINES AND
THAT'S BEEN EMOTIONALLY
DISTURBING TO ME BECAUSE WE
TRIED. TO DO SOMETHING TO START
HARDENING THESE ASSETS.
SO YOU DO A LOT OF RESEARCH AND
YOU SAY WELL WHAT WHAT CAN WE DO.
OBVIOUSLY A FEW.
DECADES AGO WE DECIDED IT WOULD
BE A GOOD IDEA NOT TO YOU SHAKE
ROOFS.
YOU KNOW THAT'S ALL STOPPED --
BUT WHAT'S NEXT AND SO I HAD-SOMEONE IN MY OFFICE.
WITH AN IDEA AND HE SAID YOU
KNOW IF YOU COULD PUT A WATER
TANK UNDER THE PROPERTY WHEN YOU
BUILD YOUR MOUNTAIN CABIN OR
WHATEVER IT IS.
I MEAN YOU HAVE SPRINKLERS ON
ALL FOUR CORNERS AND MAY BE IF
IT'S A RECTANGULAR YOU HAVE TO
MORE IN THE MIDDLE.
AND THEN YOU CAN USE YOUR IPHONE
AND IF OF FIRES COMING.
THE AT THE SPRINKLERS COME UP
AND THEY SHOOT OUT.
AND YOU COULD EVEN HAVE THE
CHEMICAL POWDER THAT YOU COULD
COMBINE WHICH WOULD BE A FIRE
RETARDANT.
SO PEOPLE ARE THINKING OF IDEAS
OTHER THAN NO SHAKE AND MOVE THE
VEGETATION AWAY FROM THE HOMES.
SO I'M I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO
SOME INNOVATIVE IDEAS OR
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO.
BECAUSE THIS IS THIS IS A MOTION
WAS TOUGH AND NOW WE'VE LOST
LIVES.
AND SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MISTER CHAIR.
AT THIS IS IMPORTANT IN YOUR
LIKE YOU SAID IT IS WE'RE
REACTING BUT WE SHOULD BE
PROACTIVE GOING.
FOR THANK YOU MISTER MISTER VICE
CHAIR.
MISTER JONES WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HAVE A IN THE OPENING REMARKS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU JUST NOT REAL BRIEFLY
AMARI AL SCANNING THROUGH --
THE PAPERWORK HERE ON OUR DESK
YOU'RE ONE OF THE PAGES IS A
ALMOST COMPLETELY.
DEDICATED TO MY DISTRICT --
BELIEVE IT OR NOT IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY.
ARE YOU KNOW RANGING FROM RANCHO
SANTA FE IN THE WESTERN PART OF
MY DISTRICT ALL THE WAY OUT --
TO ALPINE RAMONA.
AND HOME ALL IN THE EASTERN PART.
OF MY DISTRICT AND IS SIMILAR.
IN A SITUATION WITH ME IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO I GOT ELECTED TO
THE SANTEE CITY COUNCIL. TWO
THOUSAND THREE WE HAD THE CEDAR
FIRES IN SAN DIEGO IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN WE HAD THE WHICH
CREEK FIRES.
AND I THINK ABOUT THE DATES AND
NAMES RIGHT BY KNOWS POSTED --
THREE IN.
OH SEVEN AND YOU KNOW.
TWO THOUSAND CALLING MY FIRE
CHIEF ENDS YEAH I I'VE NEVER
BEEN IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS
BEFORE.
AND HE YOU KNOW HE DROVE ME OUT
TO THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES --
WHERE THE FIRE HAD COME THROUGH
MUSEUM ALLEY --
SO RAPIDLY THAT EAT.
EVEN THE EMERGENCY SERVICES
DIDN'T KNOW THAT IT WAS MOVING
THAT QUICKLY AND I THINK WE LOST --
SO A HUNDRED HOMES THAT
PARTICULAR AREA BUT ELEVEN LIVES
AND I I STILL REMEMBER DRIVING
THROUGH THAT.
AREA WITH --
MY FIRE CHIEF AND CARS BEING
BURNED OUT ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD -- WITH
THEIR HEADLIGHTS ON BUT THEIR
TIRES MELTED.
AND AND AND AND AND SO YOU KNOW
IT WAS LIKE A WAR ZONE.
AND SO -- I
JUST.
THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE I BRING
TO THIS AND SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT WERE YOU KNOW PAY
ATTENTION STAFF AND HOPEFULLY
TAKEN SOME PROACTIVE MEASURES.
TO STIR STARTED DRESSING SINGS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR DID
ANY OTHER MEMBERS SIR NIELSEN.
I THANK THE CHAIRS FOR THE
ATTENTION IN THIS HEARING.
AND WHERE WE'RE AT AT THIS SO
CALLED NEW NORMAL OR NEW
ABNORMAL.
IS THE PRODUCT OF DECADES IN
THIS STATE [inaudible]
OF NEGLECT.
NEGLECT OF MANAGING OUR FORCE
AND WILD PLANTS IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAZARD.
IS A GREATER OFFENDER THAN THE
STATE.
AND THEY NEED TO TEND TO THEIR
SHOP.
AS WELL AS US.
WHAT HAS CHANGED IS THE
MAGNITUDE OF DAMAGE [inaudible]
THESE FIRES.
AND THAT THEY HAVE ENCROACHED
NOW ON HIGHER POPULATED AREAS
[inaudible]
CITIES.
I WOULD CAUTION THAT AS WE
PROCEED.
THERE WILL BE MANY THINGS DONE
IN THIS NEW ERA.
IT OUGHT NOT BE PREDICATED ON
THE ASSUMPTION THAT WE DE
POPULATE.
THE FOREST AND THE WILD LANDS
BUT THE LADY REVITALIZED.
AND PART OF THAT REVITALIZATION
HAS GOT TO BE PREDICATED ON SOME
REMOVAL UP TIMBER [inaudible]
COMMERCIAL.
REMOVAL OF TIMBER AND MANAGING
FORESTS THROUGH THOSE.
SOUND FORCED PRACTICES
[inaudible]
AND ALSO [inaudible]
GREATER ATTENTION. TO CO
GENERATION. TO REMOVE SOME OF
THE EXISTING FEELS [inaudible]
DIRECTION.
NOT ONLY THERE BUT THE
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY HAS A
PROBLEM.
HE SHE WAS THE TIMBER INDUSTRY
DEMISE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE POLICIES THAT HAVE
DISCOURAGED COGENERATION.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
IS NOT THERE NOW. TO MANAGE
THOSE FORCED AND WILDLIFE'S.
INDEED WE NEED TO DO MORE.
WITHIN OUR DEPARTMENTS.
BUT CAL FIRE TO ASSIST THEM LAST
YEAR.
WE MADE SOME ADVANCES --
WITH THEIR AERIAL CAPABILITY.
IT'S GONNA BE A LONG WAY BACK.
WHAT WE ARE IN THE THROES OF
ARTICULATING HERE?
IN THIS LEGISLATURE.
IN PARTICULAR THE COMMITTEE LIKE
THIS.
IS NEW LONG TERM SUSTAINED
POLICY. FOR MANAGING THE FORCE.
AND THE WILD PLANTS. ONE ONE
LAST OBSERVATION [inaudible]
PROBLEM [inaudible]
THE CAMPFIRE.
ON THE RIDGE.
AND IN PARADISE.
THAT THERE WAS SO MUCH FUEL.
AND THAT FIRE.
BURNED SO HOT.
AND MOVE SO RAPIDLY HAS MANY
FIRES ARE DOING.
NOW.
IT WAS INTERESTING AS I WAS UP
THERE.
WELCOME TO EVERY WEEK MENTALLY
BUT LOOKING AT THE SCORCHED
LARGER ESTABLISHED TREES
[inaudible]
BLACK. TEN FIFTEEN FEET UP.
AND SOME OF THOSE TREES ARE
GONNA BE WEAKENED.
IT WILL HAVE TO BE REMOVED SOME
WILL REMAIN.
BUT THE CANOPIES OF MOST OF
THOSE TREES.
WERE ATTACKED BECAUSE OF FIRE
WENT SO FAST.
IT DIDN'T RATE JUMPED IN THE
CANOPY.
SO THE HOPE FOR AREAS LIKE
PARADISE IS THAT BEAUTIFUL
AESTHETICS.
OF LIVING IN THE MOUNTAINS.
IN FIFTEEN OR SO YEARS AS THINGS
GO BACK.
THEY'LL HAVE THE CANOPY THERE.
TO COME BACK.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN A
THANKS TO ALL OF YOU HERE WHO
HAVE YOUR INTEREST IN YOUR
RESOLVE TO HELP CHANGE. TO A NEW
DYNAMIC.
NOT A NEW NORMAL.
BUT A NEW HEALTHIER HAPPIER.
RURAL.
AND EVEN IRVINE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN.
YOUR RIGHT OVER THERE SENATE
CAREER OKAY VERY GOOD LET'S GET
STARTED THEN.
LET'S LET'S GET START WE GOT
SOME -- BUSY
FOLKS WAITING TO TESTIFY SO
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO WE'RE GONNA
START OUR SECOND PANEL I DID
WANT -- TO
TO NOTE FOR FOR THOSE IN
ATTENDANCE THE MEMBERS MAY BE
COMING IN AND NOW WE'VE GOT A G.
LACK MEETING THIS MORNING SO IF
YOU SEE SOME MEMBERS CYCLE AND
NOW THERE'S ALSO A PRESS
CONFERENCE GOING ON WITH THE
GOVERNOR RIGHT NOW AS YOU MAY
SEE SOME.
FLUCTUATION DON'T TAKE OFFENSE
THAT PLEASE --
SO FOR OUR FIRST PANEL WE'RE
GONNA INVITE UP BY CHIEF MICHAEL
RICH WINE IS THE ACTING STATE
FIRE MARSHAL --
WITH CAL FIRE --
SO WELCOME SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ATTENDING TODAY I KNOW
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE US AN OVERVIEW
OF SOME OF THE RECENT TRENDS --
AND HOW THE IMPACT BOTH THE WILL
WE WHICH I THINK WE'LL ALL GET
TO KNOW THAT ACRONYM QUITE WELL
AFTER YOUR REMARKS THIS MORNING --
AS WELL AS AN UPDATE ON YOUR
FIRE MAPPING --
AND HOW WE CAN MEET.
POTENTIALLY INTEGRATE THAT
BETTER INTO OUR LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS SEES I ALSO WANT TO
APPLAUD YOU ALL FOR YOUR TIMELY
WORK IN RELEASING YOUR FORTY
FIVE DAY --
HIT YOUR DEADLINE AND COMING
FORTH WITH THE FUEL MANAGEMENT
PLANNED SO --
I KNOW YOU ALL BEEN BUSY SO
THANKS FOR TAKING THE TIME THIS
MORNING CHIEF.
THANK YOU FOR THAT INTRODUCTION.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR STERN AND TEAR MCGUIRE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. TO
PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU THIS
MORNING -- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO UPDATE YOU ON CAL
FIRES WHILE IN FIRE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS.
WE ALL SHARE THE SAME GOAL OF
PREVENTING OR REDUCING THE
EFFECTS OF DEVASTATING WILDFIRES
IN OUR STATE.
OF THE UP WHAT I THOUGHT I WOULD
DO IS JUST --
GIVE YOU A QUICK SNAPSHOT OF
SOME OF THE ACTIVITIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN OUR PROGRAMS
IN OUR WHILE IN WILDLAND
ENGINEERING PROGRAM.
AND THEN TAKE A LITTLE DEEPER
DIVE IF IF I MAY INTO --
SOME SPECIFIC PROGRAM ELEMENTS
NO THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
OVERGROWN FORCED AND PROLONGED
DROUGHT HAVE RESULTED IN
UNPRECEDENTED TREE MORTALITY IN
THE STATE'S FORCED AS WELL AS AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER.
SIZE AND SEVERITY OF WILDFIRES.
LOSS OF LIFE AND STRUCTURES AS A
DIRECTOR PROXIMATE RESULT OF
WILDFIRES.
IS AN ALL TIME HIGH HI.
IN TURN CAL FIRE HAS SET ITS
FOCUS ON INCREASING THE PACE AND
SCALE THE FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES.
AS A KEY ELEMENT IN OUR BATTLE
AGAINST THE DESTRUCTIVE AND
DEADLY WILDFIRES.
WE USE THE STATE'S STRTEGIC
FIRE PLAN AS A ROAD MAP.
THIS PLAN WAS RECENTLY UPDATED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
SPECIFICALLYCALLS OUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FIRE PREVENTION
AND LAND USE PLANNING.
OUR WORK IS TO REDUCE THE IMPACT
IN THE THREAT OF WILDFIRES.
HAS BEEN LONG PART OF OUR
MISSION BUT OVER THE PAST YEARS
WE HAVE DOUBLED DOWN ON THOSE
EFFORTS.
IN FACT SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN WE HAVE NEARLY DOUBLED THE
NUMBER OF ACRES THAT HAVE BEEN
TREATED BY FUEL REDUCTION.
WE HAVE TRIPLED THE NUMBER OF
ACRES TREATED BY PRESCRIBED FIRE.
AND WE'VE INSPECTED OVER ONE
POINT TWO MILLION HOMES FOR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE CLARENCE.
FACILITATED OVER ONE HUNDRED
MILLION GRANT ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANTS FOR
LOCAL FIRE PREVENTION PROJECTS.
AND WE HAVE ASSISTED IN THE
REVIEW AND SUBMITTAL OF THIRTY
FOUR LOCAL SAFETY ELEMENTS TO
THE BOARD OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION.
CALIFORNIA'S DRY MEDITERRANEAN
CLIMATE HAS LENT ITSELF TO
WILDFIRES. FOR CENTURIES.
AND WHILE WE MUST TAKE EVERY
STEP TO PREVENT AND SUPPRESS
HUMAN BECAUSE WILDFIRES WE MUST
ALSO ADAPT TO WILDFIRES.
ADAPTING TO WILDFIRES IS A
SYSTEMATIC APPROACH.
AND AS COMMITTEE MEMBERS KNOW
THERE IS NO ONE SILVER BULLET
THAT WILL FIX THIS PROBLEM.
IT'S GONNA REQUIRE HOLISTIC
EFFORTS.
AND IT MEANS PLANNING
COMMUNITIES ARE HARDENED AGAINST
WILDFIRES.
WITH FEW BREAKS IN AND AROUND
THE COMMUNITIES.
IT MEANS PROPERTY EVACUATION
ROUTES WATER SUPPLIES AND FIRE
PROTECTION RESOURCES.
IT INCLUDES BUILDING HOMES OUT
OF MEMBER RESISTANT MATERIALS
WHILE MAINTAINING A ONE HUNDRED
FOOT DEFENSIBLE SPACE CLEARANCE
BY REMOVING DEAD.
AND OVERGROWN VEGETATION.
CALIFORNIA HAS SOME OF THE MOST
STRINGENT WELL IN BUILDING AND
FIRE CODES IN THE WORLD.
AND SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NEW
CONSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLANDS WE REQUIRES BUILDING
MATERIALS.
THAT ARE IGNITION RESISTANT.
THE WELL IN URBAN INTERFACE OR
WE WE BUILDING CODES ARE
REVIEWED EVALUATED AND AND
AMENDMENTS ARE RECOMMENDED AT
REGULAR INTERVALS.
ARE WE WE COMMITTEE
REPRESENTATIVE BUILDING AND AND
FOREST PRODUCTS MANUFACTURERS.
BUILDING AND FIRE OFFICIALS AND
IN THE ACADEMIA WORLD SERVED TO
ADVISE THE DEPARTMENT OF NEW
AMBER RESISTANT PRODUCTS
TECHNOLOGY.
AND EVEN BUILDING TECHNIQUES.
DURING A RECENT CO DEVELOPMENT
CYCLE WE WE HAD FIVE PROPOSALS
THAT WERE APPROVED.
FROM THE WE WE COMMITTEE IN
THOSE INCLUDED UL LISTED GARAGE
DOOR --
WEATHER STRIPPING TO PREVENT
KIMBER IGNITION IN THE GARAGE.
ANY NUMBER RESISTANCE SCREENS
OVER SKYLIGHTS.
THESE WERE RECENTLY ADOPTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION IN IN IS
ADDED TO OUR CURRENT CHAPTER
SEVEN A BUILDING CODES.
OF COURSE THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR
QUESTION IS WHAT ABOUT THE HOMES
BUILT BEFORE TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WE ARE DEVELOPING A LOW
COST BUILDING RETROFIT LIST.
WE THINK THIS WILL BE AN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL GUIDE TO
HOMEOWNERS ON EASY HOME
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL HARDEN
THEIR HOME AGAINST WELFARE
EMBERS.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO EDUCATE
AND INCENTIVIZE HOMEOWNERS TO
UPGRADE THEIR HOMES THAT WERE
BUILT BEFORE THE CURRENT
BUILDING CODES.
THE SERVER MUST BE COMMUNITY
BASED TO AVOID INCONSISTENT
APPLICATION.
BECAUSE ONE HOME THAT IS
COMPLIANT WITH RETROFIT
CONSTRUCTION AND THE NEXT DOOR
NEIGHBOR IS NOT.
IN CLOSE PROXIMITY.
WELL THEM BOTH HOMES ARE STILL
AT RISK SO REALLY NEEDS TO BE A
COMMUNITY INVOLVEMENT.
HOME HER NAME IS A CRITICAL STEP
IN MAKING COMMUNITY FIRE
RESISTANT.
IN FACT --
DAMAGE INSPECTION ANALYSIS OF
SHOWN THAT 93% OF ALL STRUCTURES
TO CATCH FIRE DURING A WILDFIRE
WILL BE DESTROYED.
TIED CLOSELY TO THE WELL IN
BUILDING CODES IS A FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITIES OWNS.
THESE AREAS OR ZONES ARE BASED
ON THE PHYSICAL CONDITIONS SUCH
AS FUEL SLOPE --
FIRE HISTORY AND EVEN WHETHER.
OUR FIRE RESOURCE ASSESSMENT
PROGRAM OR FRAPH USES THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND TECH AND
DATA AT THE TIME. TO DEVELOP AND
FIELD TESTING MODEL THAT IS USED
TO IDENTIFY THREE INCREASING
FIRE HAZARD AREAS OR ZONES.
MEDIUM HIGH AND VERY HIGH.
CALIFORNIA HAS BEGUN THE PROCESS
OF UPDATING THE THE FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITIES OWNS USING THE LATEST
TECHNOLOGIES AND MAPPING.
NEW MAPPING WILL INCLUDE NEW
FACTORS INCLUDE INCLUDING LAND
LEASE LAND USE CHANGES NEW
SIGNIFICANT WHEN DATA.
AS WELL AS A MODEL THAT IS MORE
SPATIALLY DETAILED.
MAPS ARE IMPORTANT.
AND ESPECIALLY IN THE LOCAL
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS WHERE THE
VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITIES
OWN TRIGGERS THE WELL IN
BUILDING CODES FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
OF COURSE THESE CODES APPLY TO
ALL THREE ZONES IN THE STATE
RESPONSIBILITY AREA.
IT'S BEEN ASKED OF THESE MAPS
SHOULD BE UPDATED MORE
FREQUENTLY AND THE REALITY IS
MOST OF THE FACTORS ARE CONSTANT
OVER THE YEARS.
WE UPDATE THE MODEL IS NEW
TECHNOLOGY OR SCIENCE BECOMES
AVAILABLE. FOR EXAMPLE WE'RE
JUST COMPLETING NEW DATA ON
AVAILABLE TO US ON SIGNIFICANT
WIND EVENTS.
THESE ISOLATED AND EXTREME WHEN
THE BANDS HAVE BEEN AT THE ROOT
OF THE SEVERITY CAUSED BY THE
NORTH BE FIRES IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IN THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CAMPFIRE
AND YOU COUNTY.
SO THIS NEW DATA ON MICRO
CLIMATES IS AN IMPORTANT CHANGE
REQUIRING REMAPPING.
CRITICAL COME A CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF OUR FIRE PREVENTION
ACTIVITIES IS ALSO OUR LAND USE
PLANNING PROGRAM.
THIS WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE BY SENATOR KILOS
BILL WAS IMPLEMENTED IN IN THE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN AND WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH LOCAL PLANNING
AND BUILDING AND FIRE OFFICIALS
TO ASSIST THEM IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR SAFETY
ELEMENTS OF THEIR GENERAL PLANS.
PROVIDE THEM WITH INFORMATION TO
ENSURE THEY MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS BASED ON THE FIRE
THREAT AND RISK IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE IN CONTACT WITH FIFTY SIX
COUNTIES AND ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE CITIES.
WHO HAVE VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES?
THIS YEAR WE WILL WE WILL BE
ADDING THIRTY ONE COMMUNITIES
WITH THEIR SCHEDULED SAFETY
ELEMENT UPDATES.
THEY PROVIDE YOU ARE OUR STAFF
PROVIDES GUIDANCE ON STATE FIRE
REGULATIONS TO THE LOCALS
INCLUDING ROAD STANDARDS FOR
FIRE EQUIPMENT ACCESS STANDARDS
FOR STREET SIGNS AND BUILDING
IDENTIFICATION.
MINIMUM PRIVATE.
AND PUBLIC WATER RESERVES FOR
EMERGENCY THEN FIELD BREAKS AND
GREEN BELTS.
WE ALSO ASSIST LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WITH INCORPORATING WELL FIRE
MITIGATION MEASURES.
THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN OUR CAL
FIRE UNIT PLANS LOCAL HAZARD
MITIGATION PLANS IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHILE FIRE PROTECTION
PLANS.
OR LAND USE PLANNERS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE SINKING
THOSE PLANNING EFFORTS.
WE'RE IN THE NATIONAL STAGES OF
OUR WORK WITH THE BOARD OF
FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
REVIEWING SUBDIVISIONS AND WHILE
IN AREAS BUILT WITHOUT SECONDARY.
EMERGENCY EGRESS TO IMPROVE BOTH
PUBLIC EVACUATIONS AND EMERGENCY
ACCESS.
OR WELL IN FIRE ENGINEERING
PROGRAM COORDINATES ARE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
ACTIVITIES STATEWIDE AND ALSO
MANAGES OUR DAMAGE INSPECTION
RESPONSE.
THE DATA COLLECTED FROM THESE
INSPECTIONS HELP US ANALYZE HOW
HOME IGNITIONS OCCUR.
AND RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOME
HARDENING IS DISCUSSED THROUGH
OUR WE WE COMMITTEES.
ANOTHER KEY ROLE THAT --
ANOTHER KEY PLAYER I SHOULD SAY
IN THIS EFFORT.
IS THE ROLE OF THE HOMEOWNER.
IT IS KEY TO THE FIRE PREVENTION
AS 95% OF ALL WHILE AND FIRES
ARE CAUSED BY THE ACTIVITY THE
PEOPLE.
THIS MEANS WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
RESIDENTS AND VISITORS TO BE
EXTRA CAUTIOUS OUTDOORS TO
PREVENT SPARKING A NEW WILDFIRE.
WE KNOW DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS THE
LAW.
IN OUR EFFORTS HAVE MADE GAINS
IN COMPLIANCE BUT WE NEED TO
EDUCATE HOMEOWNERS ON THE
BENEFITS OF HOME HARDENING.
IS PROVEN TO DRAMATICALLY
INCREASE THE CHANCE OF SURVIVING
A WILDFIRE.
CALIFORNIA IS READY FOR WILDFIRE
APP.
IT WILL HELP HOMEOWNERS PREPARE
FOR A WHILE FIRE IT'S AVAILABLE
TO TO DOWNLOAD.
AND IT HAS INFORMATION ON
DEFENSIBLE SPACE CLEARANCE
REQUIREMENTS IN TIPS INFORMATION
ON HOME HARDENING AND AND SOME
TIPS THERE AS WELL.
AND YOU CAN EVEN SIGN UP FOR
ALERTS TO NOTIFY YOU IN THE
EVENT OF AN ENCROACHING WILDFIRE
IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
SO IN CONCLUSION OUR VISION IS
TO MAKE OUR NATURAL ENVIRONMENT
MORE FIRE RESILIENT.
MAKER HOMES IN INFRASTRUCTURE
MORE FIRE RESISTANT.
AND SHAPE SOCIETIES AWARENESS OF
THREATS OF AND MEDICATIONS TO
WILDLAND FIRE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE WITH YOU TODAY AND I'M NOW
AVAILABLE FOR YOUR QUESTIONS.
FAMOUS RICH.
ONE YOU START OFF I'M SURE
THERE'S A LOT OF QUESTIONS BUT
WHEN IT COMES.
TO SERVICE SPEED OF
IMPLEMENTATION.
SOME OF THE WORK YOU AS YOU'RE
DOING ON THE ON SAY THE BUILDING
STANDARDS SIDE --
BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION CORRECT CORRECT.
AND SO.
WHEN IT COMES TO REBUILDING MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IT ALSO DOESN'T
APPLY NECESSARILY TO DIDN'T TO
REBUILDS OF HOMES THAT CORRECT?
AS WELL AS RETROFIT OBVIOUSLY
THAT'S GOING TO BE AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE HOME OR
BUILDING OWNER CORRECT
[inaudible]
AND SO --
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO ACTUALLY?
THE PUSH FOR THE STANDARDS ON
THE REBUILD EFFORTS SO WE DON'T.
REPEAT THE MISTAKES THE PAST
WE'RE GOING THROUGH A REBUILDING
EFFORTS I KNOW THAT SOME OF OUR
CITIES --
THAT ARE DEALING WITH THE WILL
THE FIRE RIGHT NOW WRESTLING
WITH THIS VERY QUESTION --
NOT JUST AROUND YOU KNOW DRIVE
WAYS AND THINGS LIKE THAT UNDER
FIRE CODE BUT SPECIFICALLY THE
BUILDINGS THEMSELVES IS THAT AT
THE DISCRETION OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO ADOPT THOSE
STANDARDS OR HOW DOES THAT WORK.
WELL WE'RE WORKING THAT OUT
THROUGH OUR WE WE COMMITTEE --
WE WE HAVE --
AT OUR LAST MEETING WE WORK IF I
MAY USE THE TERM --
SPIT BALLING.
I THAT COULD BE RELATIVELY LOW
COST FOR HOMEOWNERS TO IMPLEMENT
ONE OF THOSE IS IS SCREENING THE
BENSON NEEDS --
THAT'S A FAIRLY LOW COST AS A
MENTION THE GASKET IN IN IN
GARAGES --
THAT'S AN AREA THAT HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED WHERE AMBER IGNITIONS
OCCUR -- SO
THERE ARE THERE ARE THINGS YOU
CAN DO --
OBVIOUSLY CHAPTER SEVEN A HAS.
LISTED STANDARDS FOR FOR GLAZING
FOR WINDOWS FOR EXTERIOR CITING
FOR DECKING --
SO THAT'S A THAT'S AVAILABLE AS
WELL -- I A
I THINK THROUGH THE BUT NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS THE I'M TOUCH ME
BACK UP.
CHAPTER SEVEN A IS APPLICABLE TO
NEW CONSTRUCTION A LOCAL
ORDINANCE GOOD COULD TRIGGER IT
THROUGH A REMODEL OF A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE FOR EXAMPLE LIKE WE
DO FOR ROOFING IN SOME AREAS 50%
OR MORE.
YOU HAVE TO COMPLY --
OR OR YOU CAN BE EVEN MORE
RESTRICTIVE.
BUT WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT ISSUE [inaudible]
HOW CAN HOMEOWNERS TO RETROFIT
THEIR HOMES AND IT'S NOT JUST A
MATTER OF HOW BUT IT'S ALSO HOW
TO HOW TO FIND IT?
YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE TO IT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW IT WOULD TAKE
A LOCAL ORDINANCE EITHER THROUGH
COUNTY OR CITY TO APPLY CHAPTER
SEVEN A TO REBUILDING.
IS THAT CORRECT OR SEVEN DAYS
ADOPTED BY THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL SO IT'S AUTOMATICALLY --
ENFORCE IT AUTOMATICALLY IT IS
ENFORCEABLE FOR NEW BUILDINGS
BUT WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE LEGAL
PACKED IMPLEMENTATION FOR NOT
FOR RETROFIT BUT FOR FOR REBUILD.
OR IS THERE.
ONE THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION OKAY.
TIME ELEVEN TO GET BACK WITH YOU
IN OKAY GOOD AND WE CAN WE CAN
TEASE THAT OUT MAYBE IN
SUBSEQUENT PANELS MY ONE OF THE
QUESTION.
WAS ABOUT.
YOUR YOUR AT SEVERITY MAPPING --
HI IS THIS SIZE IT GOES RIGHT DO
WE NEED TO GO HIGHER BUT WHAT IS
EXTREME I THINK THIS LOOK LIKE
THAT INCLUDES EXTREME.
AND ESPECIALLY WITH THE WITH THE
WIND DATA THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
COLLECTING WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE
TO DO MICRO CLIMATES A TWO
HUNDRED ACRES.
OR OR TWENTY OR TWO ACRES OR
LESS -- SO
IT'S GONNA BE IT'S GONNA BE THAT
SPATIAL ELEMENT ALONG WITH THE
WINDS -- IN
A TWO KILOMETERS TWO KILOMETER
GRID IS REALLY GOING TO GIVE A
LOT MORE INFORMATION INTO THOSE
MAPS.
SO THE QUESTION YOU HAVE SIR IS
IS WHETHER OR NOT WE NEED TO GO
AN EXTREME LEVEL --
I THINK WITH A VERY HIGH FIRE
HAZARD SEVERITIES OWNSIN THAT
BEING TIED TO THE BUILDING CODES --
I THINK THAT'S A GOOD START SO
WE I FORGET THE NUMBER PROJECTS
THAT WERE IN YOUR EXPEDITED HAVE
VEGETARIAN FUEL MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY. FORTY THIRTY FIVE THAT
ARE THIRTY FIVE OKAY SO.
YET THIRTY FIVE PARTY PROJECTS
THERE BUT THE MAP OBVIOUSLY IS
MUCH BIGGER SO HOW MUCH WITHIN
THE VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES DIDN'T WE COVER.
WITH THOSE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS
THOSE THIRTY FIVE PROJECTS WERE
IDENTIFIED BY OUR CAL FIRE UNITS
AS BEING CRITICAL TO PROTECTING
THE COMMUNITIES IN THEIR UNITS.
AND SO THOSE ARE ONES THAT THAT
PRIMARILY HAVE ALREADY BEEN
PLANNED AND AND FOR THE MOST
PART PERMITTED AND ARE READY TO
GO WE'RE READY SHOVEL READY ON
THOSE.
OKAY SO WE FELT THAT WAS THE
BEST USE.
AN IMMEDIATE RESPONSE AND SO
WE'RE WE'RE GETTING READY TO TO
MOBILIZE ON I DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PLACES I'VE SOME FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS BUT I'LL DEFER TO MY
FELLOW CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FUTURE
FARMERS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING THE TIME TO COULD YOU SEE
SIR GOOD TO SEE YOU --
I THINK THAT AGAIN THERE'S BEEN
SO MUCH FOCUS OF THE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT MOVE LAST YEAR IN
REGARDS TO VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ENDANGERING BEFORE.
MAKING KALIFORNIA AROUND
FIREFIGHTING FORCE OR FORTY
MILLION RIGHT THING TO DO.
RECALLING THEIR TAX BASE RIGHT
THING TO DO.
BLACK HAWK HELICOPTERS ALL THE
APPARATUS THINK WE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO GET.
BACK TO NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
STANDARD --
WHEN IT COMES TO ENGINES BUT
THAT'S JUST ANOTHER PLUS --
BUT THE WE'RE STILL TALKING IN
COMMITTEE ON THE ISSUES OF HOME
HEARTENING.
AND I THINK I THINK WE'RE HERE.
AND I'M NOT GONNA BUT WORDS IN
YOUR MOUTH AND DISCUSS ANYTHING
PROBABLY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
WERE NOW THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL --
STEP IN THIS PROCESS CAN BY THE
HOMEOWNER.
AND WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IN
REGARDS TO HOME HARDENING.
AT NEW DEVELOPMENT AND WHAT NEW
STANDARDS ARE WE GONNA REQUIRE --
WHEN YOU SEE LANDUSE CHANGES IN
THE MAPPING --
THE EIGHT WITHIN MAPPING THAT
YOU'RE TAKING A LOOK AT RIGHT
NOW THAT'S WITHIN THE COMMITTEE
WHAT IS THAT ME.
ARE THERE COULD BE A CHANGE FROM
AGRICULTURAL --
TO TO RESIDENTIAL COULD BE YOU
KNOW ANY OF THOSE OWNING CHANGES
COULD BE FROM.
FROM.
FROM THEIR FROM WHILE IN TWO TO
DEVELOPMENT IN AWHILE AND IS
RESIDENTIAL COULD BE INDUSTRIAL
COMMERCIAL --
SO THOSE TYPE OF CHANGES --
THAT WEREN'T INCLUDED BEFORETHE
BECAUSE MAYBE THE MAPPING --
THAT WAS USING THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN VEGETATION --
MAPPING.
DIDN'T SHOW THOSE DEVELOPMENTS
IN THOSE AREAS AND SO THOSE ARE
DIFFERENT CHANGES SO YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE AN ENCROACHMENT OUT
OF THE WELL AND INTO AN URBAN
ENVIRONMENT AND SO THAT WILL
BECOME A VERY HIGH.
THE MOST LIKELY.
WHAT TYPE OF RECOMMENDATIONS CAN
WE EXPECT FOR PRE EXISTING HOMES
AND STRUCTURES WITHIN THE WHAT
WE?
IT'S A TOUGH ONE SENATOR --
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
DIFFERENT THEORIES VARIATIONS OF
WHAT IS A RESIDENTS.
IN IN THE WE WE BUT FOR A SINGLE
FAMILY HOME --
YOU KNOW THE I THINK WE NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE --
LET ME BE SPECIFIC ABOUT THAT
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE A LOT A LOT
A LOT OF HOMES AND RESIDENCES
THAT THAT TO OUR OUR MOBILE HOME
PARKS.
AND SO RETROFITTING THEM IS IT
IS IT.
THE CHALLENGE IN A SINGLE FAMILY
HOME -- AND
AND AND DEVELOPMENT.
SO.
YOU KNOW WE WE ARE DISCUSSING
THIS IN IN OUR WE WE COMMITTEE
WE NEED TO FIND A WAY PERHAPS TO
INCENTIVIZE.
THE THE RETROFITS WE'VE DONE
THAT AT POST DISASTERS WITH
EARTHQUAKES.
WITH THAT DONE THAT IN SOME
AREAS ONE IS WITH OTHER FLOOD TO
HAVE WITH OTHER OTHER DISASTERS
AND ANOTHER RISK --
AND HEN THERE SB FUNDING
AVAILABLE I THINK SOMEHOW TO TO
HELP OFFSET THE COST.
THERE WAS A GREAT STUDY THAT'S
COMING OUT IN AND SOME OF THE
PANEL MEMBERS BEHIND ME MAY BE
SPEAKING ABOUT THIS THE COST OF
RETROFITTING.
OF FROM HAD ONE HEADWATERS
ECONOMICS --
YOU KNOW THE THAT IT SHOWS THAT
THE NEW CONSTRUCTION IT'S FAIRLY
COMPARABLE IF NOT EVEN CHEAPER.
TO TO TO BUILD THIS BUT IN THE
RETRO AREA BECAUSE YOU HAVE
DEMOLITION COST AND YOU HAVE THE
BUILDING BECAUSE IT DRIVES IT UP
SLIGHTLY --
BUT SO IF WE COULD FIND A WAY TO
IN AND INCENTIVIZE PERHAPS
THROUGH INSURANCE OR OR SOME
OTHER FUN AND WORKING THROUGH
THE THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS WE
HAVE A LOT OF MONEY IN GRANTS IF
THERE'S A WAY THAT WE CAN.
PROVIDE THAT MONEY THROUGH
THROUGH NONPROFITS TO WORK WITH
THE LOCALS AND WHO CAN IN TURN
COULD HELP PRIVATE PRIVATE
HOMEOWNERS AND LANDOWNERS.
YEAH LOOK I THINK WE WHATEVER IS
GOING TO BE ESTABLISH IT NEEDS
TO HAVE THE SAME BIGGER --
THAT WE'VE HAD ON PUTTING MORE
APPARATUS ON THE ROAD --
NEEDS AT THE SAME BIGGER OF
REMOVING DEAD AND DYING TREES
ARE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
BECAUSE GOING THROUGH THE THE
NORTH A FIRE STORM --
WITH THE CENTER TO MY RIGHT
GOING THROUGH --
THE TERRIBLE FIRES DOWN SOUTH
AND AT THE SENATOR WITH THE
CAMPFIRE --
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE IN THERE
HAS TO BE SOME TYPE FUND THAT WE
SEEN IN FLORIDA --
THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO HARDEN YOUR
HOME WHEN IT COMES PRE EXISTING
STRUCTURES WHEN IT COMES --
TO HURRICANES I SENT I KNOW THAT
BUT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO USE
PACE LOANS --
THROUGH SPECIAL DISTRICTS I GET
IT -- TO BE
ABLE DO HOME HARDENING WHEN IT
COMES TO HURRICANES AND THAT
ALSO HELPS WITH THE INSURANCE
RATING AS WELL.
AND THE QUESTION I HAVE FOR THE
TEAM ADMINISTRATOR TODAY --
IS.
WHAT TYPE OF POTENTIAL STATE?
FEDERAL PARTNERSHIP CAN THERE BE
WHEN IT COMES TO FINDING JUST
LIKE WE SEEN WITH --
RAISING HOMES WITH SLIDES YES
AND OTHERWISE SAY YOU WILL NO
LONGER BE INSURED BUT YOU HAVE
TO BE IN IT BY THE WAY THIS
IMPACTS FOLKS.
BUT I WORK FOR EVERY DAY RIGHT
ON THE NORTH COAST BUT WE'RE AT
THE POINT NOW WHERE WE HAVE TO
PUT PUBLIC MONEY BEHIND IT IN
INCENTIVIZE.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO LOOK AT
FOR EXAMPLE.
IF I'M GONNA REMODEL HALF OF MY
HOME THAT DAY IN TRIGGERS HOME
HARDENING THERE HAS TO BE SOME
TYPE OF TRIGGER TO BE A TO DO
THAT WHAT WHAT IS YOUR REACTION
TO THAT --
THAT WOULD BE CONSISTENT WITH A
LOT OF OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE
CODE AS IT RELATES TO REMODELING --
YOU HAVE TO BRING IT UP TO CODE
FOR OF SPECIFIC STANDARDS I
COULD BE ENERGY COULD BE --
YOU KNOW BUILDING A FIRE EASY
FOR EXAMPLE --
I AGREE WITH YOU WE NEED A SENSE
OF URGENCY.
I I THINK --
YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING IN THE FAR
MORE CELS UPS IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU KNOW WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
BRAINSTORM THESE IDEAS.
AND WE WE HAVE SOME SOME PRETTY
SOME PRETTY --
IN WHO WORK WITH THESE PRODUCTS
EVERY DAY AND THEY'RE WORKING
THEY UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY OF
THE ISSUE AND AND THEY CAN SEE
THE DEVASTATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT.
THE THE BUILDERS --
THE FORCE MANUFACTURERS THE
BUILDING MATERIALS --
INDUSTRY IS IS PARTICIPATING IN
THIS COMMITTEE.
AND SO THEY HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO THIS AS WELL
ARE WE TALKING GUIDELINES OUR
MANDATES.
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION --
MANDATE SEEM TO WORK BETTER.
BUT NO CAN BE VERY CONTROVERSIAL
BUT LET IT BUT IT COMES AT A
COST IN AND THEN.
YOU KNOW HOW MANDATE TO FUND IT.
YEAH AND THAT'S WHY --
WHAT I WOULD HOPE IS IF?
WE ARE GOING DOWN THAT ROAD THAT
THERE IS JUST AS MUCH FOCUS.
ON PROVIDING FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE FOR HOMEOWNERS.
AS THERE HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON
REMOVING DEAD AND DYING TREES
BECAUSE IT ALL GOES TOGETHER.
AND ULTIMATELY IT'S GOING TO
KEEP RESIDENTS SAFE FOR AND IT'S
GOING TO KEEP.
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY PERSONNEL
SAFER AT TIMES I HAVE --
OF EVACUATION.
WHEN IT COMES --
TO EVACUATION ROUTES MANY THESE
SUBDIVISIONS I KNOW AND I I
DON'T SPEAK FOR THE REST OF
STATE BUT I'M SURE AND CENTER
NIELSEN'S.
NECK OF THE WOODS AS WELL ONE
WAY IN ONE WAY OUT.
SO AT A MINIMUM A NEEDING TO BE
ABLE TO MANDATE IF YOU'RE GONNA
BE DOING SOME TYPE OF RULE
SUBDIVISION.
YEAH YOU HAVE TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT.
HOW TO GET TO GET FOLKS IN A NOW
AND NOT JUST ON ONE ROAD --
BUT IT WOULD BE A LOOP HAVE YOU
BEEN DISCUSSING THAT YES THAT'S
OUR LAND USE PLANNING IN FACT WE
HAVE -- IT'S
A BUDGETED ITEM FOR THIS YEAR
FOR THE PERSONNEL TO GO OUT AND
DO A SURVEY OF THOSE EXISTING
COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN OUR LAND USE PLANNING
FOLKS WORK VERY CLOSELY WITH THE
LOCALS AS THEY'RE NOT ONLY
OPENING THEIR SAFETY ELEMENTS
BUT AS ARE CONSIDERING
DEVELOPMENT INTO THE INTO THE WE
WE AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE ACCESS.
AS IS A RESPONDING AGENCY OR THE
FIRE DISTRICTS ARE COUNTIES IN
THAT THEY HAVE SUFFICIENT WATER
SUPPLY IN THAT THY'RE
SUFFICIENT FIRE PROTECTION
RESOURCES.
BUT WE YOU KNOW WE ALSO THE
PROBLEM WITH THAT --
THE CAMPFIRE.
AND SO WE WANT --
TO WE WE IN FACT ARE CAL FIRE
UNITS ALREADY HAVE A LIST OF
THOSE THOSE CRITICAL
SUBDIVISIONS AND SO WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP WITH THAT AND
WORKING WITH THE LOCALS AS WELL.
MY LAST QUESTION IS GOING TO BE
ON PREVIOUS DECISIONS ON LOCAL
PLANNING UNDERSTAND THAT WERE
LIVING WITH THEM.
WHAT ARE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
TOP THREE ISSUES?
THAT CAL FIREOR MUNICIPAL FIRE
AGENCIES FACE WHEN IT COMES A
PRIOR DECISIONS AND BUILDING
WHEN THE WILL BE WHEN IT COMES A
RESPONSE.
WHEN IT COMES TO RESPONSE YEAH --
CENTER WILL DO RESPECT I'M GONNA
HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE IN OUR
OPERATION SECTION --
OBVIOUSLY OBVIOUSLY IT'S ACCESS
AND INTENSITY HOUSING PROP
PERHAPS IS.
ONE BUT I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
CONFER WITH OUR OPERATIONS FOLKS
IT'S GREEN I KNOW CHAIR AND I
WILL ASK A RETIRED --
CAP ARCHIE TO MY ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
JAMES FROM RUSSIA.
LET'S GO DOWN THE LINE CENTER
MORE LUCK THAN THE SENATOR
NIELSEN.
WELCOME SENATOR BILL.
THANK YOU CHIEF FRED RICH WINE I
APPRECIATE YOUR BEING HERE --
I KNOW THAT TYNESIDE OF TWENTY
TWENTY SO THIS QUESTION WILL BE
KIND OF LONG BUT A JUST KIND OF
GIVE SOME BACKGROUND ON ON THE
FIRE MAPS HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS FIRE MAPS. FOR FOUR YEARS --
BECAUSE I HAVE A COMMUNITY THAT
TO HAD A FIRE BACK IN NINETY
THREE THAT.
WIPED OUT FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE HOMES IN THESE ARE ALL OCEAN
VIEW.
AND WE'VE SEEN IT IN SANTA
BARBARA AND OTHER PLACES --
SO.
IN IN DOING OUR RESEARCH WE
FOUND THAT YOU.
AS CAL FIRE HAVE TO WORK WITH
THE CPUC [inaudible] TORANK
THESE AREAS AS LOW MEDIUM HIGH I
THINK THAT WERE USING TEARS LIKE
TIER THREE WOULD BE THE HIGHEST.
AND THEY WEREN'T COMPLETED THREE
YEARS AGO AND AND I WAS INFORMED
THAT YOU YOU YOU I USE A PRONOUN
USE I APOLOGIZE THAT CAL FIRE
AND THE CPC HAVE BEEN WORKING ON
THESE MAPS FOR EIGHT YEARS AND
THEY WERE NOT.
COMPLETED [inaudible]
SO.
I'M WORKING WITH UTILITIES
TRYING TO GET THEM TO
UNDERGROUND OR DO WHATEVER THEY
CAN.
I HAVE A A CITY AND IN MY
DISTRICT ANAHEIM WHICH HAS ITS
OWN UTILITY SYSTEM IT'S ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE AND AND THEY KNEW
IT WAS EXPENSIVE TO UNDERGROUND
AND AND TRY.
TO MITIGATE IN WILDFIRES OWNS.
BUT OVER TWENTY YEARS THEIR
METHODICALLY BEEN [inaudible]
ADDRESSING.
THERE WILD FIRES ON SCENE SO
THEY'VE GOT 98% OF THAT
COMPLETED NOW THEY'RE WORKING
INSIDE.
THE CITY.
TO UNDERGROUND ELECTRICITY ET
CETERA [inaudible]
ANSEL.
WE'RE FINDING FROM UTILITIES ARE
SAYING WHAT WE GET HARDEN OUR
ASSETS BUT THAT'S ONLY GONNA
TAKES CARE 60% OF THE ISSUE.
I'M BEING TOLD BY THE CPUC YEAH
YOU COULD UNDERGROUND IT'S
EXPENSIVE BUT WE NEED THESE.
POLLS FOR FIVE G. IN THE FUTURE
AND ALL THE REST AND THEREFORE
YOU GOTTA KEEP THESE BACK I HAVE
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS. FIFTY NINE
POLLS THAT HAVE BEEN HIT AND TEN
YEARS AND AND KNOCKED OUT.
AND THEY'RE CARRYING HIGH
VOLTAGE ELECTRICITY.
SO THAT'S THAT'S THE BIG FEAR
FOR THE HOMEOWNER IS NOT
NECESSARILY HELP WELL THEY HAVE
MAINTAINED THEIR WHOLE BUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO SOMEONE THAT IS.
FALLING ASLEEP AT THE WHEEL IN
THE MIDDLE AND I IT'S A POLL
[inaudible]
IT'S ALL.
MIKE MY QUESTION IS.
I'M EVE SAID TODAY THAT THE MAPS
ARE DONE.
AND THAT NOW THEY CAN BE REVISED
BUT I JUST WANNA KNOW WHY IT'S
TAKING SO LONG AND WHAT CAN I DO
AS A SENATOR. TO GET THE UTILITY
COMPANIES.
THE GILMORE PROACTIVE I MEAN
THEY'RE ALL COMING IN NOW
BECAUSE I'M --
VICE CHAIR OF ENERGY.
THE ROCK AND AND AND AND IT.
ANYWAY THEY'RE ALL COMING IN AND
SAYING THIS IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN
DOING.
BUT OBVIOUSLY P. JEANNIE FAILED.
MISERABLY ANOTHER IN CHAPTER
ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY SO WHAT CAN WE
DO THAT ENCOURAGES UTILITIES TO
HELP THEMSELVES BEFORE THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN CHAPTER ELEVEN AS
WELL.
THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION I WANT
TO CLARIFY THOUGH YOU SAID THE
MAPS ARE DONE AND I THINK YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT THE THREAT
DISTRICT MAPS THAT CPUC USES IN
THE UTILITY ISSUES WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE FIRE HAZARDS
VERITIES ON MAPPING.
STAR FIRE HAZARD SEVERITIES ON
MAPPING --%
IS IS UNDER WAY --
AND WOULD BE BEGUN THAT PROCESS
TO UPDATE THAT MAP IN IN THAT
MAP REFLECTS.
THE CONDITIONS OF THE WHILE AND
AND AND AND INTO COMMUNITIES IT
WARY WORDING CROUCHES.
THE CPUC AND AND THE UTILITY
MAPPING --
WE HAVE AN AMMO YOU WITH WITH
THE CPUC CAL FIRE DOES --
WE HAVE A DEDICATED PERSON WHO
WORKS ALMOST DAILY WITH THEIR
STAFFING AND THEIR SAFETY
DIVISION AT CPUC.
AND WE'VE WE'RE NEARING THE
COMPLETION OF THE REVIEW OF
THEIR THEIR WELFARE MITIGATION
PLANS THAT THEY'RE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT -- I
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE THOSE
BACK TO CPUC.
AND THEN I'M NOT SURE THE
PROCESS AFTER THAT.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING TO TO
REVIEW THOSE MAPS AND WE'RE
MAKING GREAT PROGRESS AND I
BELIEVE THE DEADLINE IS --
IS THE NINETEENTH HAVE THOSE
BACK TO CPUC.
SO IT'S KIND OF TAKEN SOME
ELEVEN YEARS TO GET THOSE MATT.
WHAT WHAT MIGHT BE THE REASON?
FOR IT TAKING SO LONG I'VE THE
LA TIMES PT OUT MAPS AND JUST A
COUPLE MONTHS GO ON ABOUT MY
TAKEN A WEEK I DON'T KNOW.
I I CAN'T RESPOND TO THAT I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
TOO LONG.
A DROPPED IF IF YOU HAVE ANY
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW.
TO MOVE THIS ALONG AND AND TO
WORK WITH UTILITIES TO START.
YOU KNOW START THE PROCESS TO TO
BE TWENTY YEAR PROCESS BUT WE'VE
GOT TO START IDENTIFYING WHERE
THE WILD FIRE.
HIGH RISK ZONES ARE IN.
IN ANSWER PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITY SO SO THANK YOU CHIEF
I I WILL ADD THAT IS PART OF THE
THREAT.
THE THREAT PROTECTION THE THREAT
PLANNING THAT'S INVOLVED IN THE
WILD AND MITIGATION PLANS THAT
THE ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS HAVE
SUBMITTED.
THAT WE ARE REVIEWING AND NEAR
IN AND NEARLY COMPLETED THAT
REVIEW.
THE PROCESS AFTER THAT I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT TO THE ELEVEN
YEARS PRIOR TO THAT.
THANK YOU CHIEF.
FOR THANK YOU CENTER MORE LIKE
CENTER NIELSEN.
AND WELCOME CENTER JACKSON
[inaudible] TWENTY YES FIFTY
BRED WIND --
A KEY PART OF YOUR RESPONSE
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN THE MUTUAL.
EIGHT ALWAYS SHOULD SHOW
IMPRESSIVE TO ME TO WATCH TWENTY
FOUR HOURS A DAY THE CONVOYS OF
VEHICLES COMING FROM ALL OVER
EVERYWHERE.
OUT OF STATE EVEN OUT OF COUNTRY --
BUT PARTICULARLY THE RESPONSE IN
STATE OF DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS.
AND WE'RE FOCUSING ON CAL FIRE --
YES AS WE SHOULD.
BUT IT IS ALSO IMPORTANT.
FOR LEGISLATORS KEEP IN MIND THE
IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS.
LOCAL FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
[inaudible]
AND VOLUNTEER.
FIRE DEPARTMENTS ARE THOSE ALSO
A PART OF OUR WHOLE RESPONSE
MECHANISMS YES SIR.
ANOTHER THING.
THAT I HAVE ADVOCATED AND I HOPE
WE WOULD CONTINUE TO EMBRACE.
IT WILL REQUIRE.
MORE SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE OUR MAIN STAY RESOURCE THE
FUTURE.
WHERE BY FOR DECADES WE RELY TOO
MUCH ON IN MAY LABOR?
INMATE LABOR IS NO LONGER IS
RELIABLE.
OR IS AVAILABLE.
ARE YOU LOOKING AT NEW
RELATIONSHIPS WITH SEE SEE SEE
IF WE CAN.
GET THEM FUND.
WE HAVE A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CCC'S AS IT RELATES TO
OUR FIRE TACK CRUISE SO.
SENATOR I WOULD LIKE TO GET BACK
WITH YOU ON THAT DEFERRED THAT
TO OUR OPERATIONS FOLKS.
I LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO
PREVENTION DOESN'T SPEAK FOR
OPERATIONS AND I WANT TO GET IN
THEY'LL GET AHEAD.
AT SNAGGING IT WELL IT WAS IT
WAS IT AN INSTRUCTIVE THAT LAST
YEAR WE WERE ABLE TO GET A SHE
SHE SHE CAP OPENED UP IN
PARADISE.
AND AT LEAST IT WAS TO A DEGREE
HELPFUL.
THAT THAT WAS DONE.
AND ALSO ANOTHER FACTOR IS THE
SURVEILLANCE TO IDENTIFY THE
FIGHTERS.
THAT REQUIRES NO MORE
APPLICATION OF TECHNOLOGY.
CAMERAS IT CETERA. TO IDENTIFY
FIRES WE USED TO HEAD THE OF
TOWERS ALL OVER THE PLACE.
WITH PEOPLE STATIONED THERE.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR THE FIRE
SEASON --
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS WE'RE
DEVELOPING A LOT NEW TECHNOLOGY
THAT CAN GIVE US.
SURVEILLANCE OUT IN THE FORCE TO
WILD LANDS.
THE TO IDENTIFY FIRES.
SOONER IS THAT CORRECT YES
THAT'S CORRECT AND THEN ALSO AN
ISSUE THAT HAS COME TO BEAR
WE'RE DEALING WITH IT EVEN RIGHT
NOW IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THAT'S RAPID RESPONSE AND
COMMUNICATION OF IDENTIFICATION
AND NOTIFICATION [inaudible] TO
CITIZENS.
WELL BACK TO ASIANS.
THAT IS ALSO A PART OF YOUR PLAN
FOR THE FUTURE CORRECT I WORKING
WITH -- YES
YES THAT'S THAT'S TRUE.
AND THEN ABOUT THE PRE
POSITIONING AND PLACING
RESOURCES.
IN MOST LIKELY MOST VULNERABLE
HIGH RISK AREAS AND ARE YOU
EMBARKING ON A COURT OF A
SCHEDULER PROGRAM TO BE DOING
THOSE THINGS.
CENTER I THINK THE QUESTION IS
IS REALLY SUITED ENHANCE MUTUAL
AID RESPONSE.
NUMBER YEAH --
IT IT WILL GREATLY ENHANCE OUR
FIRE CAPABILITIES HAVE CREWS
RESPONDING CLOSER TO MOVE TO
WHERE THE FIRES.
WELL AND THAT'S KEY WITH THE
GREATER FUEL AND ACTION
CIRCUMSTANCES AND MAKE THESE
FIRES SO MUCH MORE SEVERE.
A REPETITIVE IDENTIFICATION AND
RESPONSE.
IS MORE CRITICAL THANK YOU.
THEY SAID IN UNISON.
I'M LOOKING FOR OTHER QUESTIONS
IF NEEDED I DID HAVE ONE FOLLOW
UP WHICH IS JUST GIVE US A SENSE
OF COST ON THE REALLY SIMPLE
THINGS.
ON A SIMPLE RETROFITS THAT YOU
TALK ABOUT YOU AND YOUR TIME AT
THE GAS GETTING.
AROUND THE GARAGES.
THE THE THE AND THE VENTING
[inaudible]
SCREENING.
WALK US THROUGH CROSSES BASICS
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION I DON'T
HAVE THAT WITH ME I WILL
CERTAINLY GET OKAY.
IS SO WITH.
PORTER MAGNITUDE SENT I MEAN
WHEN I TALK WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT IS IT.
YOU'RE TALKING AT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR JOB ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
LIKE SOME YOU KNOW IN NO I WITH
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR JOB YES
UNDER FIVE THOUSAND FOR SURE.
SO OKAY WELL I DON'T HAVE THE
FORTIFIED WITH YOU ON THAT I
THINK I THINK YOU'RE HEARING
FROM A LOT OF THE MEMBERS UP
HERE IN INTERESTED AND
EXPEDITIOUSLY --
NOT JUST LOOKING AT NEW
CONSTRUCTION BUT HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY.
GET TO THESE HOMEOWNERS
ESPECIALLY IF IT'S SIMPLE OUT
ANY OTHER WELCOME SENATOR MONEY
SENATOR JACKSON'S YOU A QUICK
QUESTION I DO.
ON THE HARDENING ISSUE LAST YEAR
I DID LEGISLATION ALLOWS ACCESS
TO SOME OF THE FUNDS AVAILABLE
UNDER THE PACE PROGRAM --
HARDENING OF EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS I THINK A
CRITICAL.
PART OF THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION
AND I APOLOGIZE SO I I WAS HERE
ACTUALLY AT NINE THIRTY BUT YOU
WEREN'T.
SO WE DIDN'T START ON TIME AND I
STILL GET CHIDED YEAH YEAH YEAH
YEAH.
SO -- I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING PRESENT --
TO HEAR THIS BUT THE THE ISSUE
OF THE HEART HARDENING CURRENT
INFRASTRUCTURE YOU MENTION A FEW
THINGS WHAT IS CAL FIRE DOING
ARE THERE ANY PROGRAMS THAT
YOU'RE ADVANCING OR THINGS THAT
YOU'RE DOING.
IN THE PROCESS OF EVALUATING
HOMES IN THESE HIGH RISK AREAS
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS OF SOME
OF THE EASIER FIXES IF YOU WILL
THAT WERE SUGGESTED BY THE CHAIR --
IS THAT WITHIN YOUR BAILEY AND
ARGUES OR SOMETHING WE COULD DO
TO ENCOURAGE FURTHER
PARTICIPATION BECAUSE YOU DO.
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY INTERFACE
IN THESE COMMUNITIES WITH WITH
SOME OF THOSE CHALLENGES.
YES AND AND THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION ALLEN URBAN INTERFACE
COMMITTEE.
IT'S REPRESENTATIVE OF BUILDING
BUILDING INDUSTRY FORCED
PRODUCTS MANUFACTURERS --
THE VENTING COMPANIES BUILDING
FIRE OFFICIALS ACADEMIA AND
WE'RE ALL BRAINSTORMING IDEAS
AND TRYING TO SCALE THEM --
AS TO WHAT WORK WE GET OUT.
SOONER RATHER THAN LATER --
SO THAT SOME OF THE IDEAS SUCH
AS SCREENING NEEDS IN DANCE --
THE GASKET IN AROUND THE GARAGE
DOORS --
THOSE THOSE ARE EASY FIXES BUT
WE WE HAVE A COMPILED OUR LIST
YET.
I UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE'S
REQUEST FOR SENSE OF URGENCY IN
THIS AND I WILL CARRY THE
SPECTER WE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO THAT WAS MY LAST
QUESTION IS THERE SOME TIME LINE
HERE BECAUSE WE'VE HAD SOME NICE
RANGE BUT THAT MEANS THE YOU
KNOW THE GROWTH OF THE FUELS AND
WITH THE WE EXPECT THAT THERE
WILL BE SOME PROBLEM SINCE
YOU'RE ANYTHING WE CAN DO.
BUT TO EXPEDITED AND WHAT IS
YOUR TIME TABLE --
I DO NOT HAVE A TIME TABLE AT
THIS TIME SENATOR --
BUT I WILL GET BACK WITH YOU ON
IT ON THE TIME TABLE TABLE IN A
PLAN.
OKAY BUT THANK YOU CHIEF RICH
WINE I THINK WE'RE TO WRAP IT UP
HERE AND LOOK FOR THE FOLLOW UP --
AND I'LL TURN IT BACK TO THE
CHAIRED INTRODUCED THE THIRD
PANEL BUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TIME AND YOUR URGENCY
HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR IN WILL
BE HAPPEN --
BOTH I CAL FIRE ON DIDN'T KNOW
THE ANSWERS TO THE ENTIRE SET OF
COMMITTEES.
WE'D LIKE TO BETTER NOW
INTRODUCE OUR NEXT PANELIST.
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL THAT BOTH OF
THEM ARE HERE TODAY.
MARK OR DO CHIEF WHO IS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ALL
UNDER THE OFFICE OF GOVERNOR
NEWSOME.
WE'RE ALSO GRATEFUL THAT ROBERT
FINISH YOUR TODAY'S REGIONAL
MINISTER FOR FEMA REGION NINE
OVERSEAS --
THE ENTIRE WEST COAST IN OUT IN
THE PACIFIC --
JUST ON A PERSONAL NOTE I KNOW
THAT MANY ON THIS PANEL HAVE
WORK WITH BOTH MR FITNESS OCCUR
THE CHEEK --
THERE THE DREAM TEAM THE DYNAMIC
DUO -- WHO
HAD BEEN TRAVELING UP AND DOWN
THE STATE --
IN DELIVERING IN OUR DARKEST OF
DAYS -- AND
I KNOW WHETHER IT IS SENATOR
JACKSON -- A
CENTER MONEY IN SENIOR STERN --
CENTER NIELSEN WE ARE FOREVER
GRATEFUL WE'LL DO OUR AFTERMATH
MASTERS AND HELP US REBUILD.
THEY'RE GONNA BE FOCUS ON SOME
VERY SPECIFIC ITEMS WE'VE
ACTUALLY --
PROVIDED THEM WITH SOME
QUESTIONS SO THEY CAN COME FULLY
PREPARED TODAY.
THEY'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING ON ANY
POTENTIAL CHANGES THAT DATA
ACCURACY ON LOCAL PLANNING
DECISIONS AND DEVELOPMENT TOOLS.
WHAT WE SHOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
WHEN REBUILDING IN FIRE PRONE
AREAS -- AND
WHEN COMMUNITIES ARE.
HIT BY FIRES WHAT FEDERAL AND
STATE ASSISTANCE IS THERE THAT
IS AVAILABLE.
AND CAN THIS ASSISTANCE BE USED
TO REBUILD INFRASTRUCTURE TO BE
ABLE TO REBUILD MORE RESILIENT
ME ACROSS THE STATE.
WE'RE GOING TO TURN IT OVER
FIRST AND FOREMOST TO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE MERCY SEVICES MARKER
DUTY TO BE A TO GIVE US A
STATEWIDE FIRST PERSPECTIVE.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
FEDERAL I AND THE MISTER FENTON
IS NOT USUALLY HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND AGAINST AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR TAKING THE TIME.
FOR DIRECTOR THE TWO OF YOU HAVE
A COMBINED FIFTEEN MINUTES WILL
GIVE YOU A ONE MINUTE PROMPT IN
IF YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO GO
OVER THAT --
JUST LET US KNOW THE FORESHORES
CONSTRICTOR.
WELL FACTIONS CHAIR AND AND
KOSHER STAND AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE GREAT TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY -- AND
I THINK I'M ALL IN THE CONTEXT
OF OF THE OF THE DISCUSSION
TODAY ON HOW DO WE BUILD MORE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES AND AND
PREPARE FOR THESE EVENTS I WANT
TO TALK.
ABOUT THAT THE TOPIC OF HAZARD
MITIGATION BECAUSE WE HAVE A
VERY VERY EXTENSIVE.
HOW TO MITIGATION PROGRAM --
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND AND
REALLY ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
WAYS THAT WE CAN ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITIES.
I DO NOT HAVE TO EXPERIENCE --
LARGE SCALE EVENTS AND I AM OR
IF HE'S BY DOWN THE RISK OF
EVENTS THAT OCCUR.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES HIS --
TO IS PRIORITIZE IN FINE HAZARD
MITIGATION PROJECTS IN FACT.
THIS IS AT THE NATION WIDE
ENDEAVOR AND I KNOW THAT --
BOB BOB WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT THIS AS WELL BUT A
NUMBER OF STUDIES DONE.
OVER THE YEARS YOU'RE SAVING
CLOSE UP TO TWELVE THE ARE THE
KIND OF STRUCK IN THE IN THE
RECOVERY PROCESS SO THERE'S A
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE AS WELL AND
OF COURSE THAT'S ECONOMIC --
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC FACTOR FOR
COMMUNITY --
AS WE'VE LEARNED FROM TIME AND
TIME AGAIN NOW THAT --
BYE BYE DOWN THE RISK WE REALLY
BY DOWN THAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
IMPACT --
IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE THAT
MEDICATIONS THAT EFFORT TO
REDUCE --
AND FOCUSES ON REDUCING A LIFE A
LOSS OF LIFE AND PROPERTY --
BY LESSENING THE IMPACTS OF
DISASTERS --
AND IT'S REALLY DESIGNED TO TAKE
ACTION BEFORE THE DISASTER
CURSED TO REDUCE THAT --
THOSE DOES IMPACTS I MENTIONED
EARLIER.
EFFECTIVE MEDICATION REQUIRES --
THAT WE ALL UNDERSTAND FIRST OF
ALL WHAT THE RISKS ARE AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THEN THE
REGIONAL LEVEL --
AND THAT WE ADDRESS THOSE
CHOICES OF BEING ABLE TO
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS.
SOMETIMES NOT SEXY PROJECTS LIKE --
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROJECTS OR YOU
KNOW MAYBE --
DOING A A MEDICATION PROJECT
BEFORE YOU PUTTING IN A
BEAUTIFICATION PROJECT WITHIN A
A DOWNTOWN CORRIDOR --
INVEST IN THE LONG TERM
COMMUNITY WELL BEING.
NOT THAT WILL BUILD RESILIENCE
IN YOUR COMMUNITY --
AN IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
MITIGATION INVOLVES THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY OF COURSE AND
AND YES HAS BEEN IN DIALOGUE
WITH THE INDUSTRY --
NOW FOR THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS --
AND DISCUSS WAYS --
THAT THAT BOTH INSURANCE COMPANY
AND THE STATE AND THE LOCALS
COULD WORK MORE COLLABORATIVELY
TO BENEFIT AND SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE AGREE HOWEVER THAT
WITHOUT THE MITIGATION ACTIONS
WHICH WE DO CONTINUE TO
JEOPARDIZE --
ARE SUFFERS REAL RESILIENCE IT
IS ALL WRAPPED UP IN SOMETHING
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA HAZARD
MITIGATION --
PLAN IT'S A DEVELOPED --
EVERY FIVE YEARS BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S THE STATE'S
PRIMARY HAZARD MITIGATION.
DOCUMENT.
AND IT IS A PROVIDED --
TO ALL LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE BUILDING
THEIR HAZARD MITIGATION PLANS.
AROUND THE STATE PLAN --
PANIC INCLUDES AB OBJECTIVES AND
STRATEGIES AND ACTIONS THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
CAN TAKE IT IT'S A DOCUMENT THAT
IS -- SIGNED
OFF ON BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND THE THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
FEMA.
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE LOCALS IN THE AREA OF HOUSE
MITIGATION ALL HAS TO COME
TOGETHER BECAUSE AS WELL YOU
LEARN A FEW MINUTES THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF FUNDING THIS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR HAS MEDICATION THE
COMES DOWN.
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
THEY ARE THE TO MEET --
SO ON THIS PLAN REALLY
REPRESENTS OUR OVERALL
COMMITMENT TO SUPPORTING THE
MITIGATION STRATEGY AND AND AND
HOW WE CAN DO THAT THE STATE --
THE OTHER THING IS IS THAT THE
THE PLAN --
HAS INCORPORATED A VERY
EXTENSIVE CLIMATE ADAPTATION
COMPONENT IN FACT ALL PLANNING
NOW THAT WE'RE DOING AT YES
ACROSS THE BOARD --
ADDRESSES --
THE CLIMATE RELATED IMPACTS
WHILE FAR BEING OF COURSE ONE OF
THE RACE WE DEAL WITH AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT TODAY BUT
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT.
OUR ROLE AND YES IS REALLY ALL
HAZARD ROLE --
SO WE'RE TALKING --
IN FRONT OF YOU TO A ABOUT WHILE
FIRE MITIGATION --
YOU KNOW KNOCK ON WOOD WE COULD
EARTHQUAKE PROBLEM OR A FLOOD
RELATED PROBLEM WHICH WE JUST
ARE GOING THROUGH SOME FLIGHTS
NOW IN THE CINEMA VALLEY.
SO -- ALL WE
HAVE TO RE THINK ABOUT THIS FROM
AT ALL HAD HAUSER DAHLE REYES
PERSPECTIVE.
THE THE PLAN WAS JUST UPDATED IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND EXCUSE
ME CAN BE FOUND ON THE YES
WEBSITE.
OUR YES --
BIG BECAUSE OF THE HISTORY OF
DISASTER STRUCK CALIFORNIA --
WE REALLY ENCOURAGE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT AND AND PUT
IN PLACE LOCAL HAS OMITTED
CATION PLANS AS A PRIORITY WE
GENERALLY HAVE A PRETTY GOOD.
SUCCESS RATE WITH THAT IT'S NOT
A MANDATED ISSUE --
YOU KNOW WE WE WOULD IN FACT
WHAT WE LIKE TO SEE IS THAT THE
GENERAL PLAN OF A COMMUNITY AND
THE HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN ARE
TIED TOGETHER.
SO AS THE BUILDING OUT THE
GENERAL PLAN THAT HAVE A
MITIGATION PLAN.
IS TIED IN AND BUILD A CULTURE
OF PREPAREDNESS --
IN MITIGATION EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT THAT COMMUNITY IS RISING
AND IN THE LONG RUN --
NONE OF THIS IS MANDATED --
NOTHING SAYS THAT THEY HAVE TO
DO IT BUT WE DO KNOW THAT --
TO BE ABLE --
TO TO I HAVE A HAS MITIGATION
PLAN.
AND OF COURSE WE 1100% --
AT THEIR LOCAL COMMITTEE WANTS A
100% OF THE COST.
OF RECOVERY THEY THEY SHOULD
HAVE THAT PLAN IN PLACE
[inaudible]
ARM.
SO -- THE
FEDERAL DISASTER MITIGATION
ACTOR -- TO
THOUSAND OUTLINED A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT.
ISSUES THE ATTEMPT WAS THREEFOLD
TO GATHER HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
MITIGATION INFORMATION FROM
LOCAL LEVEL TO STATE LEVEL
PLANNERS.
ARE TO ENSURE THE STATE LOCAL
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN ACCORDING
TO THE GREATEST EXTENT PRACTICAL
AND ENSURE THAT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE MADE AWARE OF
THE HAZARDS OF FOUR ABILITIES
WITHIN THEIR JURISDICTION.
AND TO DEVELOP --
A PLAN TO REDUCE THOSE --
FOR AND YOU KNOW WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT.
DISASTER MITIGATION PROJECTS AND
MANY OF YOUR COMMUNITIES WITHIN
THE STATE --
LET ME SAY THAT --
THE WAY THE PROGRAM WORKS IS
THAT OF CALIFORNIA CAN RECIEVE
WHEN IS A FEDERALLY DECLARED
DISASTER UP 220%.
OF THE COST OF DISASTER CAN COME
BACK AND HAZARD MITIGATION FUNDS
THAT CAN BE UTILIZED BY THE
STATE.
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF WORKING
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD
AND HAZARD MITIGATION EFFORTS --
SINCE SIDE THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FLOODS THAT WE HAD
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WERE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE --
WE HAVE RECEIVED UP CLOSE TO
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
HAZARD MITIGATION GRANT FUNDING.
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IN THE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THESE
FUNDS --
INTERESTED PARTIES AT THE STATE
LOCAL CITY NONPROFIT TRIBAL
LEVELS --
SUBMIT WHAT'S CALLED A NOTICE OF
INTERESTS AND PARTICIPATE IN
THEIR HOUSE MITIGATION GRANT
PROGRAM.
AND THEN THOSE ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS INCLUDE ---OF INCLUDE REVIEW AND THAT WE
DID FOR WORKING WITH THOSE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IN WITH FEMA
ULTIMATELY FEMA SIGNS OFF ON
THOSE.
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAMS --
IN -- TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE'VE WE HAD --
OVER SIXTY SIX PROJECTS THAT
WERE --
IMPLEMENTED CLOSE TO NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS --
GRANTS TO DEVELOP --
LOCAL HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN SO
THERE IS A WAY FOR LOCALS. TO TO
GET FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO BUILD
THESE PLANTS SO FUNDING SHOULD
NOT BE AN ISSUE TO HAVE A
HOUSING MITIGATION PLAN IN PLACE --
WHILE WE DID BUT WORKING OFF --
BUILDING AQUIFER RECHARGE
PROJECTS --
WE'VE THAT --
WORK IN DOING --
OPERATION BOLTON SEISMIC
RETROFIT PROGRAMS AND IN --
200-018-0070 EIGHT PROJECTS THAT
WE DID --
INCLUDING --
NOT COMPETITIVE POST WHILE FAR
REGION CONTROL INITIAL
STABILIZATION PROJECTS --
PROJECTS IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
TO INCREASE TO PRE BASING
CAPACITY THAT WILL MITIGATE
FUTURE REST OF MUD AND DEBRIS
FLOWS --
WE'VE DONE SOME WORK IN SEA
LEVEL RISE --
A COMMUNITIES ALONG THE COAST
ARE SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION.
AND PROJECTS FOR FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES AND OF COURSE
AGAIN PUTTING WORKING WITH A
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY.
TO A PROGRAM CALLED GRAYSON BOWL
WHICH WAS WHICH WAS DESIGNED BY --
YES AND AND AND CALIFORNIA
EARTHQUAKE AUTHORITY --
THAT'S A PROGRAM THAT WOULD GO
IN TO IDENTIFY --
HOMES PRE NINETEEN FORTY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WHERE WE
ACTUALLY WOULD INCENTIVIZE
RETROFITTING BY PROVIDING GRANTS
TO HOMEOWNERS TO DO BASIC
RETROFIT PROGRAMS WHICH WOULD
SOLIDIFY THOSE HOMES ON OTHER
FOUNDATIONS.
THEREBY DECREASING THE POTENTIAL.
FOR DAMAGE AND AND AND AND SO.
THE THE OVER ARCHING SET OF OF
OF EFFORTS --
FOR MITIGATION --
IS REALLY CRITICAL I WILL TELL
YOU -- AS AS
THE DIRECTOR --
YES I IT'S HARD SOMETIMES TO GET
REALLY GOOD PROJECTS COMING IN
FROM FROM COMMUNITIES I THINK
THAT.
THEY'RE NOT THINKING.
ABOUT IT IN THEWAY THAT THEY
COULD THEY NOT LEVERAGING THE
PROGRAMS TO THE EXTENT.
ARE POSSIBLE --
BUT THERE'S ALSO --
REGULATION AND AND AND THE
LITTLE BUREAUCRACY THAT COMES
ALONG WITH THE WITH THE PROJECT
THAT COULD BE SORT OF A DOWNER
OF OF BUT COMMUNITIES WANTED TO
APPLY FOR THE PROGRAM --
BUT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS TO
STREAMLINED AS MUCH AS THAT AND
AND AGAIN MUCH.
MUCH THANKS TO BOB.
KNIGHT FEMALE TRYING TO FIND
WAYS TO STREAMLINE THOSE --
THOSE BUREAUCRACIES ENSURE AS
MEDICATION PROGRAMS GET PUT IN
PLACE -- I
THINK OUT YOU KNOW ONE BIG AREA
RECENTLY THAT --
WE'VE SEEN IN THE CINEMA VALLEY
FOR OF COURSE I THINK BOB WILL
TALK ABOUT THAT THERE WAS A LOT
OF MONEY THAT WAS PUT INVESTED
YEARS AGO TO RAISE HOMES --
DOWN ON THE RUSSIAN RIVER VALLEY
IN GREENVILLE --
PROVED TO BE BENEFICIAL DURING
THIS PARTICULAR FLOOD THAT JUST
HAPPENED TWO WEEKS AGO --
AND AS WE SPEAK --
AS A RESULT OF THE MODESTY TO
MUD SLIDES SINCE IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY WE ARE WE ARE.
TAKING OUT ALL OF THOSE HOMES
THAT WERE IN THAT MIGHT FLOW
ZONE AND COMPLETELY MAKING THAT
A A NON BUILDINGS OUT.
SO -- YOU
KNOW.
A COUPLE OF THE THINGS THAT
THEY'VE WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IS
FOR EXAMPLE MOVING FORWARD BASED
UPON A RECENT EVENTS IS
PROVIDING WAIVERS FOR HOMEOWNERS
TO CREATE DEFENSIBLE SPACE ON ON
A HOUSE BY HOUSE BASIS.
RESULTING IN LARGER SCALE
COMMUNITY FIRE PROTECTION
EFFORTS OKAY.
MAYBE WORKING WITH CAL FIRE IN
IN BEING ABLE TO AND FEMA BEING
ABLE TO CHANGE THE WHAT COULD BE
DETERMINED TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE --
DOING RETROFITS.
WITH REGARDS --
TO TYPES OF ROOFING AND OTHER
KINDS OF YVHS --
WINDOWS --
SCREENS KIND OF THINGS --
EXPLORING THE POTENTIAL FOR
STRATEGIC LANDS PURCHASES AND
HIGH FIRE.
HAZARD ZONE SIMILAR TO WHAT'S
THE POINT IN FLOOD PLAINS.
ALL OF THESE ARE THINGS THAT --
ARE POTENTIAL WITH REGARDS TO
HAZARD MITIGATION PROGRAMS AND
AND I THINK THAT YOU KNOW --
ONE THIS IS NOT JUST A FEDERAL
STATE PROGRAM THIS IS A FEDERAL
STATE LOCAL --
NON GOVERNMENTAL COMMUNITY BASED
LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENGAGEMENT
WHICH MEANS THAT.
YOU KNOW --
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT BUILDING
A SUBDIVISION OR HOMES IN A HIGH
RISK ZONE AREA I DON'T REALLY
CARE WHAT THE RISK IS BUT?
WE ARE GOING TO BUILD IN THE
HIGH RISK ZONE AREA --
AND YOU COME UP AGAINST --
THE ISSUE OF WE DO WE BUILD WE
MITIGATE HOW WE MITIGATE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE DEVELOPERS
THAT ARE WORKING TO MINIMIZE
THAT EFFORT AND THEN ULTIMATELY
THE SUBDIVISION GETS BUILT --
I THINK THAT THERE'S THERE'S A A
PIECE IN THAT AREA WHERE WE ALL
NEED TO COLLECTIVELY BE.
MORE HAVE MORE DIALOGUE AND AND
MAKE SURE THAT --
THE FISH SHOULD BE.
JOB ONE THEY HAVE A A A SAFE AND
SECURE COMMUNITY --
AND THEN AND THEN DO THE
DEVELOPMENT OR AROUND THAT TO
WITHOUT US MY TIME BOB THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR STRICTER RETIREMENT
FOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR WILL
GIVE YOU MEANT ONE MINUTE
PROMPTLY OF APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
MINUTES.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
THAT YEARS OF THE CULTURE
SEVENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE IT WAS
LIKE HE TOOK UP CITY FIVE
SOMETIMES ALL I'LL BE QUICK FOR
IT --
PARTNERS IQ --
SENATOR REQUIRE CENTER STERN AND
OTHER DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS OF
FORD'S WISHING YOU.
MANY VIEW TOO MUCH IN THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS --
THAT NOT SURE IF YOU'RE AWARE
BUT THE LAST THIS IS LUNCH TWO
YEARS ACROSS THE COUNTRY THEN WE
HAVE SENSE.
THEM SET IN INCEPTION IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE SO WE'VE
BEEN -- VERY
BUSY AND CALIFORNIA'S LEAD
UNFORTUNATELY --
SOME OF THE WAY WITH A MEAN THAT
MARK.
WELL THINGS ARE RESERVATIONS --
IN MY EXPERIENCE AND DISASTERS
IS RESPONSE RECOVERY WORK.
GOES BEST ONE IS FOR EARLY
SUPPORTERS STATE MANSION LOCALLY
EXECUTED.
EVEN WHEN ALL LEVELED Là
GOVERNMENTS ARE COORDINATED --
REALLY --
IT'S CRITICAL THAT HAVE PRIVATE
CITIZENS AND BUSINESSES BEING
PART OF THAT RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY IN THEIR CRITICAL TO
THE SUCCESS THAT.
THEREFORE --
WE REGULARLY ENCOURAGE --
THE DEVELOPMENT OF LOCALS RIVER
CURRENT IS THE INCLUDES
AWARENESS INDIVIDUAL RESPONSIBLE
AND COLLECTIVELY GAUGE RENT.
BUILDING A A MORE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES AS THE BEST WAY TO
REDUCE --
RHYS FOR PEOPLE PROPERTY AND
TAXPAYERS.
I CANNOT OVERSTATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOR SPEND OF
MITIGATION BEFORE DISASTER
STRIKES.
THE MOST CRITICAL TOOLS FOR
REDUCING THE RESTORE MANAGE AT
THE COMMUNITY LEVEL AND INVOLVES
ONLY PLANNING.
COULD IN ADOPTION ENFORCEMENT
AND DEVELOPMENT --
AND DECISIONS THAT BALLOTS
DISASTER RESILIENCE AND ECONOMIC
REALITIES.
ADDING -- TO
THESE ACTIVE MEASURES THAT HELP
MITIGATE AGAINST RISKS WE KNOW
THAT INSURNCE PROVIDES
FINANCIAL PROTECTION AGAINST
REST.
ROOM RECOMMEND THAT THE PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE CAN EASY CLEAN
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS SEEK
INSURANCE.
AS A FINANCIAL BACKSTOPS TO
ACTIVITY --
ARE TO BE ACTIVE AGAINST RISK.
AND REDUCE --
RISK.
DEVELOPER RESILIENCY CAPACITY --
BEFORE AN INCIDENT --
CAM REDUCE LOSS OF LIFE AND
ECONOMIC DISRUPTIONS.
WE COMMITTEES ARE AFFECTED --
WE WANT TO SEE REBUILDING THAT
IS SAFER SMARTER AND STRONGER.
BUT THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES THE PROPERTY OWNERS A
COMMUNITIES FACE IMPERSONAL
REFLECTS FOR THAT REASON
AGENCIES CALLING FOR A CHANGE.
AND THE CYCLE O OPPORTUNITY WE
ARE INVESTMENT IN FRONT OF THE
DISASTER CYCLE AND NOT IT THEN
WERE TYPICALLY --
SETS.
MARK TALKED A LOT ABOUT --
SUMMER NEW SORTIES AND THE COST
AND EFFICIENT.
BENEFIT RATE --
FOR MITIGATION --
FOR EVERY DOLLAR INVESTED SAGE --
SIX AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT TO
IF-- THAT --
WE'VE INVESTED OVER FIFTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS --
IN MITIGATION AND OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY BILL A HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN SAVINGS FROM
THAT -- IF
YOU MY MANAGE SEVERAL MITIGATION
PROGRAMS AS ONE MAKE SURE --
THAT WE'RE AWARE WHAT THOSE ARE --
WE HAVE GROUP RIGHT MITIGATION
EVERY FIRE MANAGEMENT GRANT OUT
THERE --
WHICH IS ABOUT.
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT THE
GOES DIRECTLY THE COMMITTEE
AFFECTED MARK TALKED ABOUT OUR
E. HAS A MEDIATION PROGRAM FOR
FOR WHERE WE PROVIDE --
FUNDING DIRECTLY --
TWO OF THE STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AS A 15220% BASIS OF
THE DISASTER COSTS --
WHICH CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN IS WITH
BROTHERS NOW HAS A SIZEABLE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING --
IN THEIR MEDIATION --
COFFERS --
THEY CAN BE USED TO PREVENT --
RISK ALSO WE ARE PRE DISASTER
MITIGATION --
WHICH IS --
THIS YEAR HAS BEEN BUDGET TO ONE
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY --
TO BE USE.
THOSE PROJECTS COULD BE USED FOR
DEFENSIBLE SPACE MEASURES SAYING
NEXT IGNITION RESISTING
CONSTRUCTION.
EARLIER THAT YEAR I THINK IT'S
FROM THE QUESTIONS YOU'RE SING
HOMES -- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT --
WE'VE DONE IS PROVIDE MITIGATION
MONEY -- TO
GO AHEAD AND REPLACE ROOFS ON
HOMES OR WERE BILL PREVIOUSLY
THAT ARE NOT UP TO THE CURRENT
CODES IN THOSE KIND OF THINGS
AND WHO DID THAT WAS TRICKY FIRE
DEPARTMENT TOOK ON THAT A GRANT
AND WORK WITH PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS
IN THE AREA. TO TO DO THAT --
THE OTHER THING --
THE BIGGEST COMMIT MONEY COULD
BE USED FOR AS HAZARDOUS --
FUELS REDUCTION --
SO OVER --
THE PASSOVER YEARS --
WE'VE TAKEN ON A NUMBER OF
PROJECTS IN THE FOURTEEN WORK
WITH -- CITY
CALIFORNIA --
TO LOOK FOR OTHER OPPORTUNITIES --
AGAIN NOT I THOUGHT TODAY --
IN THIS INFORMATION HEARING --
AND BEFORE FINISHING I WANT TO
WRITE IS JUST A FEW POINTS FOR
CONSIDERATION.
IF WE TRULY WANT TO LOOK AT MORE
WAYS TO CONFRONT AND ADAPT TO GO
ON RISKS WE CANNOT ALWAYS BILLED.
AS WE HAVE BUILT --
AND PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO
REBUILD THE BUILDINGS --
INFRASTRUCTURE COMMUNITIES THE
WAY WE BUILT IN THE PAST
GENERATIONS.
A CALIFORNIA HAS TREMENDOUS
NATURAL RESOURCES AND BEAUTY --
A FIFTH GENERATION CALIFORNIA --
CALIFORNIAN BUT BILLION CERTAIN
AREAS IN RIVR IN AREAS ALONG
CLOSE -- AND
THEN FORCES AREAS IN WHILE IN
URBAN INTERFACE BRINGS
ADDITIONAL RHYS.
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS --
THE COMMITTEE'S EFFORTS TO ASK
HARD QUESTIONS ABOUT LAND USE
PLANNING.
AS A FEDERAL OFFICIAL IS NOT MY
PLACE TO TELL PEOPLE WHERE TO
BUILD OR HOW TO BUILD.
BUT TOGETHER --
WE DO WANT THE REST SMART AND
MORE AWARE OF THE CONSEQUENCES
OF DEVELOPMENT DECISIONS.
DISASTER MANAGEMENT WE ALWAYS
ADVISE PEOPLE TO PUT.
AS MUCH SPACE --
AMPLE -- AS
POSSIBLE BETWEEN THEMSELVES AND
THE THREAT.
THANK YOU CREW THEN TO PROTECT
OR MITIGATE AGAINST THE THREAT
AND LASTLY TO ENSURE AGAINST.
THE REMAINING RHYS AT FEMA WE
SEE TOO COSTLY HELP.
SUPPORT AMERICA'S DISASTER
SURVIVORS.
RECOVERING FROM ANY DISASTERS A
WHOLE COMMUNITY EFFORT THERE
RELIES ON THE STRENGTH OF THE
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
OF BUSINESSES AND PRIVATE SECTOR
AND INDIVIDUALS.
AS OUT AS THE AS DISASTER
STRIKES ARE COMMUNITIES --
AND WE REBUILD WE ENCOURAGE THEM
TO MAKE TOUGH DECISIONS THAT
WILL ALSO A MAJOR TOO MANY MORE
RESILIENT TO FEATURES ASTERS.
THANK YOU MISTER MISTER MINISTER
VERY GRATEFUL I'M GONNA START
WITH A COUPLE QUESTIONS ARE AN
OPEN IT UP. TO THE COMMITTEE
THAT WORKS --
JUST IN YOUR CAREER.
BRIEF RESPONSE ZERO MINE --
HOW DO YOU SEEN FIRE CONDITIONS
CHANGE --
ONE SECURITY WHICH IS A FORMER
FIRE CHIEF.
THE SUGAR GOING THROUGH YOUR
LIFE -- IN
THE TEMA ORGANIZATION --
BRIEF RESPONSE ON THAT.
WELL FOR ME I THINK THAT IT'S A
SAFE SAY THAT OF THE THE KIND OF
FIRES WERE SEEN TODAY.
WOULD MAYBE BE SOMETHING WHAT
HAPPENED ONCE IN SOMEONE'S FIRE
SERVICE CAREER --
AND SO THEY WERE WE USED TO CALL
THEM CAREER FIRES BIG HUGE VERY
COMPLEX FIRES.
NOW WE'RE SEEING THESE ALLTHE
TIME --
CLEARLY YOU KNOW THE THE
CONDITIONS HAVE CHANGED THE THE
ENVIRONMENT CHANGED I THINK THAT
FIVE YEARS OF DROUGHT WAS A HUGE
FACTOR --
THESE ARE ALL CLIMATE DRIVEN
ISSUES --
AND THE WE SCENIC IN KIRK'S MOVE
OF OF PEOPLE FROM URBAN CENTERS
TO THOUGH WE WE INTO AREAS WHERE
THEY'RE GETTING CUT OUT OF THE
RAT RACE AND THAT THAT PUTS MORE.
PEOPLE AT RISK --
AND THEN LASTLY --
WE'VE MOVED WE'VE SEEN A
TREMENDOUS SHIFT TO THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY THE USE OF CELL
PHONES FOR COMMUNICATION AND THE
REQUIREMENT OF HAVING --
THE BACKBONE OF THE RESILIENCY
THAT SYSTEM --
THEY WERE ALL UTILIZING --
BE BE QUESTIONABLE SO THOSE ARE
THOSE ARE I WOULD SAVE IN IN MY
TIME --
WHERE WE'RE SEEING A MUCH MORE
COMPLEX SITUATION YEAH I THINK
IT'S THE RATES FOR STAND THAT
ISSUE OF TELECOM IN NEEDING MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM WHEN IT COMES
TO TELECOM KEEPING --
THOSE OPERATIONS NO MATTER WHO
THE KERRIER IS MOVING DURING --
IN EVACUATION AND OR IN THE
AFTERMATH AS WE SEE THE SYSTEMS
EVEN SOME OF THE SMALLER VEINS
AND PLEASE PUSH BACK ON ME IF
YOU THINK I'M WRONG.
THE SMALLER VENCER COLLAPSING
ENTIRE REGIONS WHEN IT COMES TO
SELLING DATA FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S
THAT'S CORRECT AND I MEAN YOU
KNOW WE KNOW THAT IN OUR RULE
AREAS WHERE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
MOVING.
THE SERVICES ARE ARE NOT YET UP
TO SPEED ANYWAY --
AND THEN AND THEN OF COURSE THE
CAPABILITY THAT EXISTS THERE
EVEN IN A MODERATE OR A SMALLER
BAD THOSE SYSTEMS --
ARE GOING DOWN AND SO --
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
NEED TO COLLECTIVELY WORK ON BUT
IT'S IT'S IT'S A ABOUT SOME OF
THESE THINGS AND AT PEOPLE THEY
JUST THEY JUST ALL STEP UP AND
AND AND CONSIDER.
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO DEPEND ON
IT.
IN OUR LIVES ARE DEPENDING ON IT
IT HAS TO BE RESILIENT AND
REDUNDANT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR MISTER
MINISTER.
YEAH MY TWENTY FOUR YEARS AND
FEMA MOST THAT HERE IN REGION
NINE I I THINK I'VE SEEN --
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE OVER THAT
TIME OF FIRES.
I THINK --
MOST NOTABLY IS --
JUST THE WIND DRIVEN FIRES THAT
WERE SEEN NOWADAYS THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND FIRE TORNADOES
AND THINGS THAT WE JUST REALLY
HAVEN'T SEEN EVER BEFORE --
A AND AND JUST --
THE FIRES NINETY MOVING OUT OF
THE FOREST AREA BUT INTO URBAN
INTERFACE --
E. YOUNG THE SANTA ROSA JUST A
BIG CHANGE OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS AT LEAST.
GOT IT --
WE'RE DUE TO MORE RAPID FIRE AND
TURNED OVER TO THE COMMITTEE
WHAT CHANGES.
SHOULD WE BE LOOKING AT IN
REGARDS TO THE LOCAL PLANNING
DECISIONS [inaudible]
AND CAN GUIDELINES CUT IT
ANYMORE.
OR DO WE NEED TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH MANDATES WHICH WAS THE SAME
QUESTION FOR THE FARMERS.
STRICTER.
WELL I MEAN AS A AS A BUBBLE
POPPING I MENTIONED YOU KNOW --
YOUR MEDICATION HAS TO BE AN
INTEGRAL COMPONENT TO THE
PLANNING PROCESS YOUR GENERAL
PLANS --
NEED TO HAVE A HAND IN GLOVE
WITH YOUR MITIGATION PLAN --
I YOU KNOW I THINK THAT THE WORD
MANDATE HAS BECOME.
ALL YOU KNOW CONCERNING --
I THINK IN CERTAIN AREAS OF
PUBLIC SAFETY --
I DON'T CARE FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT --
OR OR RESPONSIBILITY OF A OF A
COMMUNITY YOU HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COMMUNITY --
WE ALL SHOULD BE WE ALL SHOULD
BE FOCUSED ON MAKING THAT THE
MOST SAFE ISN'T SECURE NOW
SOMETIMES --
COST GETS IN THE WAY --
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S THERE'S
GOT TO BE A BETTER DIALOGUE AND
BEING ABLE TO WALK TO WORK
THROUGH THAT --
AS WE JUST ARTICULATED HERE
THERE ARE OTHER KINDS OF THINGS
TO BUY DOWN THE COSTS --
SO I THINK THAT --
WERE YOU SEE MANDATE --
I I THINK FROM A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT A LOCAL PLANNING
PERSPECTIVE LOCAL PLANNERS NEED
TO BE --
THINKING AND AND I'M NOT SAYING
THAT THEY THEY DON'T I'LL BUT I
THINK THAT IN THE NEW NORMAL --
THEY NEED TO BE THINKING AOUT
AS THEY APPROVE --
PLANS OR IF THEY'RE LOOKING AT
APPROVING A PERMIT FOR A RETRO
FIT -- THAT
THEY'RE THAT THEY'RE ENCOURAGED
THAT THAT THAT THERE ACTUALLY IS
REQUIREMENTS FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY BUILD THAT IN THE PLACE
AND THEN.
LASTLY THERE HAS TO BE
ENFORCEMENT --
THAT'S A BIG PIECE THAT DOES NOT
REALLY EXIST AND ENFORCEMENT --
CODE COMPLIANCE --
PETER GOING TO BEAT WASTE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BUILD IN --
THE RESILIENCY THAT YOU NEED IN
THE COMMUNITY.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF WE'RE LOOKING
AT REQUIREMENTS ON A LOCAL LEVEL.
MAKING THIS A BASED OFF OF
SQUARE FOOTAGE.
OUR WEEK IS A REQUIRED TO
MANDATE.
AND I'M JUST I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET FROM YOU I MEAN LOOK --
AND I'LL SPEAK FOR MYSELF AND
YOU CAN RESPOND.
THE AGENT MAKE  WHILE THEN
FIRES ARE HERE THEY'RE NOT GOING
AWAY.
BECAUSE THE CLIMATE CHANGE AND
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE LIMóN WITH
SO.
IS THAT MEAN WE HAVE TO BE A TO
TAKE.
ANOTHER STEP THE BILL TO KEEP
FOLK SAFE AND CANDIDLY KEEP HIM
ALIVE WELL THERE'S A THERE'S A
SEVERAL WAYS TO DO IT RIGHT IF
YOU LIVE IN A FLOOD PLAIN YOUR
REQUIRED. TO HAVE FLOOD
INSURANCE.
IF YOU'RE GONNA LIVE IN NO
HIGHER WILDLAND ZONE IT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND YOU KNOW KIND OF
A MISSION FIRST LINE DEFENSES
HAVING APPROPRIATE INSURANCE.
IF NOT THERE SHOULD BE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO PUT IN
PLACE. TO TO MAKE YOUR HOME MORE
RESILIENT BUT REMEMBER YOU'RE
BEING YOUR HOMES ARE IT'S JUST
MATERIALISTIC ITEMS YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A OF A HOME THAT
YOU CAN GET OUT YOU KNOW AND
COULD SAVE YOUR LIFE IN.
AND GET YOUR FAMILY OUT THAT
SHOULD BE THE ULTIMATE OBJECTIVE
ANY TYPE OF THESE CODE SHOULD BE
DESIGNED.
TO BEING ABLE TO SAVE LIVES IN.
THE APP AND PROTECT PROPERTY BUT
THERE.
THERE'S A LOT OF AS YOU KNOW
CENTERS THERE'S A LOT OF
CONSTRUCTION IT'S UP AND DOWN.
OUR SIERRA FRONT IN OUR WE WE
THAT IS QUESTIONABLE IN THAT
AREA AND SO --
MORE MORE THAT PARTICULAR YET
CAN BE DONE IN AND I THINK THE
WORD -- YOU
KNOW YOU WANT TO USE THE WORD
MANDATE REQUIREMENT --
YOU KNOW I'M I IN AUGUST.
THE RIVER THAT EIGHT MANDATE
REQUIREMENT IS TO SHOULD BE SOME
A REQUIREMENT TO HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY PLACE THANK YOU
STRUCTURE.
CEMENT SHOULD IDEALLY --
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU WOULD LIKE
KNOWN TO LIVE IN A HAS ARE PRONE
AREA BUT I DON'T THINK THAT'S
PRACTICAL --
IF COMMITTEES ARE GOING TO BUILD
IN HAZARD PRONE AREAS THEY NEED
TO TAKE STEPS TO MITIGATE --
THE DISASTER FENCE WILL SPACE WE
TALKED ABOUT --
IGNITION RESISTING CONSTRUCTION
HAS IT FEELS REDUCTION INSURANCE --
IN REGARDS TO PLANNING --
WE ENCOURAGE LOCAL PLANNING AND
ZONING BOARDS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS A FACTOR IN.
THOSE REGIONS THEIR DECISION
SENT TO LOOK JUST READ TODAY BUT
LOOK INTO THE FUTURE --
AND AND HOW THOSE IMPACTS IN
DECISIONS IN THE COMPOUNDING
IMPACTS OF THOSE DECISIONS --
AFFECT YOUR COMMUNITIES.
WE NEED TAKEN FACTORS QUITE
FRANKLY THAT --
IT WITH REGARD TO CHANGES TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE --
SUPPORT RESILIENCE WERE TO BE
ROSES ROADS WITHIN YOU KNOW A
NUMBER OF ISSUES ON EVACUATION
ROUTES BEING INSUFFICIENT.
SEEMS LIKE TO ME WE PUT A LOT
EFFORTS INTO EVACUATION PLANNING
FOR A BUILDING MATT IN THE OF
THE RIGHT NUMBER STEPS IN THE
RIGHT SPACES AND ALL THOSE KIND
OF THINGS AND DO WE DO THOSE FOR
COMMUNITIES AT THAT LEVEL THAT
WE DO FOR BUILDINGS --
WE NEED --
TO LOOK AT THE PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE THE POWER SYSTEMS
THE COMMUNICATIONS CAPABILITY IS
ABLE TO SUPPORT THE POPULATION
THERE AND OFFER THE PRICE OF THE
THE RIGHT WARNINGS.
ASSEMBLY THINGS AREN'T SEXY IS
MY COLLEAGUE POINTED OUT IN HIS --
OPENING REMARKS BUT GREATLY
IMPACT LONG TERM COMMITTEE
RESILIENCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
MINISTER LET'S OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS CONCERNS MISTER CHAIR.
WELL THANK YOU BOTH WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH IT [inaudible]
AND YOU'VE BEEN STEADY AND
BRAZILIAN YOURSELVES SO THANK
YOU.
BOTTOM OUR HEARTS AND EVERYBODY
DOWN SOUTH HE'S BEEN HURTING.
YOUR A YES THE PARTNERSHIP IS IS
HUGE AND YEAH WE WE WE NEED YOU --
HOW MUCH MONEY DO YOU THINK
WE'RE LEAVING ON THE TABLE --
WE FOR OUR SORT OF LACK OF SAY
ENTHUSIASM OR THROUGH PUT.
ON THIS SORT OF HAZARD
MITIGATION PROJECT PLANNING I
MEAN DO YOU HAVE A SORT OF SENSE
OF WHAT CALIFORNIA'S LEAVING ON
THE TABLE BY NOT TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
SCALE MAG ORDER MAGNITUDE WELL I
DON'T NEED I WOULDN'T I WOULDN'T
CHARACTERIZE WHAT FOR FIGHT I
NEVER GIVE ANY MONEY BACK TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO I DON'T EVEN IF IT ON THE
TABLE.
LIKE A PLACE THAT I I I I THINK
THAT -- I
THINK THAT IT HAS TO DO WITH --
THE KIND OF PRICE SOMETIMES
WRAPPING UP HOLD.
VERSUS YOU KNOW PUSH AND PULL --
THE GET GOOD PROJECTS I THINK
THAT --
MAYBE I'M GONNA GET YOU PROGRAM
IS NOT AS AND THE AVAILABILITY
OF THE RESOURCES ARE NOT AS
UNDERSTOOD IS THEY SHOULD BE --
WE WE WE ALWAYS TRY TO FIND WE
GET THE PROJECTS ACROSS THE
BOARD --
DONE BUT I WOULD JUST --
YOU KNOW IF IT'S SOMETHING THAT
THE THE COMMUNITIES REALLY NEED
TO THINK ABOUT BECAUSE THERE IS
A COST SHARE.
LET'S BE CLEAR ON THAT RIGHT AND
SOMETIMES THAT COST YEAR IS HARD
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO MEET.
AND SO THEY JUST DON'T GO DOWN
THAT PATHWAY.
AND SO WE'VE LOOKED AT WAYS THAT
MAY BE.
FEELING THAT COST SHARE THROUGH
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS OR
OTHER KINDS OF WAYS TO TO MAKE
IT EASIER SOME.
WEALTHIER COMMUNITIES THIS
SHOULD NOT BE A PROBLEM SOME ARE
SMALL RURAL COMMUNITIES THAT
BARELY CAN DO THAT.
BENNY LE MORE HELP GETTING THERE
SO WHAT I WOULD HAVE IMAGINED.
JUDGE WHAT KIND OF PROJECTS WE
TALK ABOUT YOUR THE WHAT WHAT
WHAT ARE.
I I THINK --
BY MANY OF MANY OF THE IF IT
CONTACTS A WALL FIRE IS IS MAYBE
IT'S REALIGNMENT OF ROADS COULD
BE -- TO
MAKE YOU KNOW BETTER VALUATIONS
ALWAYS MAYBE ITSELF ALERT AND
WARNING SYSTEM --
MAYBE IT IS A MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR BUT YOU KNOW.
THERE PUBLIC FACILITIES THERE
CRITICAL FACILITIES ARE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS HARDENED TO
THE GRACE IS THAT POSSIBLE --
AND OR IF THEY'RE WANTED TO
RETROFIT PROGRAM WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITY --
WHERE IT WHERE --
YOU KNOW IT'S ORGANIZED AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS --
CAN COME TO THE TABLE AND BE
PART OF THIS.
AND FOR EXAMPLE LIKE WE'VE DONE
AND SEE A IN ALL THESE
EARTHQUAKE ZONES.
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE OF TWO OR
THREE OR FOUR THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANT TO THE HOMEOWNER. TO BE
ABLE TO DO A RETROFIT OF THEIR
OF THEIR HOME THEREBY ONCE THEY
GET THAT RETROFIT DONE THEY TURN
TO THEIR INSURANCE COMPANY AND
THEY GET A REDUCTION IN THEIR
INSURANCE PREMIUM BECAUSE
THEY'VE DONE SOMETHING THAT.
REDUCE THE REST OF THE HOME SO
IT'S A WIN WIN ACROSS THE BOARD
BUT PIXAR COORDINATION TO GET
THAT DONE AND DOES THAT SAME
SORT OF RISK MITIGATION
OPPORTUNITY EXISTS FOR THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THEMSELVES MAN --
WE SEEN NEW LIABILITY EMERGE --
THERE'S LAWSUITS CURRENTLY UNDER
WAY AROUND --
PLANNING FAILURES AT LEAST BEING
ALLEGED --
ON BEHALF OF COUNTIES FOR THAT
STATE YOU KNOW ALLEGEDLY
IGNORING KNOWN RISKS --
BUT IF WE'RE PLANNING SMARTER
SAY HAVING SMARTER EGRESS OR IN
GRASSER --
SORT OF ANTICIPATION OF SLIDE
RISK OR THINGS LIKE THAT --
DOES THIS ALSO APPLY TO THAT
KIND OF PUBLIC IN IN PUBLIC
INSURANCE IS MAYBE WAY TO SCALE
THAT UP.
WELL I MEAN YOU KNOW IT --
I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER THAT ONE
I'M NOT GONNA CAN'T I CAN'T
SPEAK THAT SPECIFICALLY APPLIED
I WOULD MAKE MY TO JULIE I WOULD
I WOULD SAY YES DID YOU COULD
GET A PRODUCTION --
AS FAR AS A RAISE CONCERN BUT I
THINK THAT FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT.
ANY TIME YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING.
FORWARD LEANING TO BUY DOWN THE
REST THAT'S AND THAT'S IN THE
BENEFIT OF THE COMMUNITY
IMPRUDENCE THERE YEAH IT'S A
PRUDENT ACTION AND AND ALSO
COULD HELP WITH IN PLOY EASE --
THE POTENTIAL FOR WORKERS COMP
AND OTHER KINDS OF I THINK WE
CAN GET INSURANCE REDUCTION
PREMIUMS I KNOW THAT FOR A FACT
IF YOU PUT SAFETY ASPECTS WITHIN --
THE YOU KNOW THE INFRASTRUCTURE
I I JUST I'M.
I'M DRAWN TO AND I WANT TO GET
YOUR REMARKS HERE MR BUT YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE ABOUT TO
CONSTRUCT TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
NEW HOUSING UNITS --
WHAT IN THE SANTA CLARITA VALLEY
OUT HAVE PERMITTED BY LA COUNTY?
AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF FANFARE.
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY OR ZERO
EMISSIONS OR SOME --
SORT OF NEGOTIATION WENT FORWARD
TO MITIGATE ELISE FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL PERSPECTIVE.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING THERE THERE IS
NO --
INGRESS OR EGRESS TO THE ONE
EIGHTEEN FREEWAY THERE AND SO
EVERYTHING GOES TO THE FIVE
FREEWAY FOR TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
NEW HOMES.
AT THE MOST HIGHLY TRAFFICKED
REGION RIGHT THROUGH THE VERY
HIGHEST FIRE SEVERITY ZONE IN
THE WHOLE AREA --
HOW DOES HOW DOES CARILLO YES?
HELP INFORM MAYBE THAT LOCAL
PRINTING PLANNING PROCESS AND
WHAT WHAT WHAT COULD WE SEE
THERE HE LOOKED AT THAT THAT
POTENTIAL BOTTOM BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT THAT WASN'T
WILL THE RIGHT WILL WILL THE WAS
A LITTLE FURTHER WEST AND AND
NORTH BUT A WRY.
CERTAINLY WENT RIGHT THROUGH
THERE AND BUCKLEY DIDN'T JUMP
THE FOURTEEN BUT IF YOU LOOKED
AT THAT PARTICULAR REGION AND
THAT'S REALLY THAT ONE OF THE
EPICENTERS OF NEW HOUSING GROWTH
AT LEAST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THEY'RE SORT
OF RURAL POCKETS AND FOLKS ARE
TRYING TO BUILD.
CABINS AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT
IN TERMS OF WHERE THE REAL
DEMOGRAPHIC SHIFT IS HEADED IT
FEELS LIKE THE SOUTH LAND AND
IT'S NOT JUST THE SANTA CLARITA
VALLEY BUT IF YOU IF YOU. TO
LOOK AT THAT RISK AND HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU ELEVATE THAT FOR
LOCAL PLANNERS?
THAT'S A THAT'S A I KNOW IT'S
MAYBE A LOADED QUESTION BUT I
WAS A LITTLE BIT THAT'S OKAY --
SO WE WE HAVE A LOOK AT THAT --
PROJECT AT IT IT'S A HUGE
PROJECT.
THERE ARE NUMBER OF WAYS TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION SENATOR YOU
KNOW I WE LOOK AT IT FROM THE
EARTHQUAKE RISK WE LOOK AT IT
FROM THE FIRE RISK.
YOU KNOW OF EVEN THAT AREA HAS
FLOOD FLOOD PRONE PROTECT UP
POTENTIAL OF FLASH FLOODS --
AND YOU KNOW REALLY THE THE THE
LA COUNTY AND THE AND THE AND I
AND IS THAT A IS THAT COUNTY
JURISDICTION --
CS LOS ANGELES OR YOU KNOW
REALLY NEEDS.
TO YOU'RE WORKING WITH THEIR
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
AND THEIR PLANNERS --
THEY'VE GOT A HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN -- THAT
THE CLEARLY ARTICULATES WHAT THE
EXPECTATIONS ARE BY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BUILD IN THAT
RESILIENCY --
AND BEER THE ABILITY TO HAVE
EGRESS AND AND INGRESS UP POINTS
DURING A MONTH MORE THAN --
ONE OF A IN TIMES OF MAJOR
EVENTS CLEARLY IS ARTICULATE
THERE NOW I CAN'T TELL YOU TODAY
WHETHER.
THE STAFF MY STAFF SAT DOWN WITH
THE COUNTY AS THEY WERE
DEVELOPING THAT --
BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER PROJECT
THAT WE SORT OF LOOKING AT
BECAUSE IT'S ON THE SUSTAINABLE
PEACE THERE'S REALLY.
YOU KNOW ISSUES --
AROUND THAT AS WELL THAT WERE
CONCERNED ONCE YOU KNOW YOU CAN
BE SUSTAINABLE NOT RESILIENT YES
RIGHT ACTUALLY THERE'S A WAY.
I WANT TO MOVE ON BUT THAT
REGIONAL MINISTRY OR DID YOU.
JUST COMMENTS ON IS PUSH PULL
DYNAMIC THAT THE DIRECTORS BEEN
SPEAKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
STIMULATING --
MORE CREATIVE MORE COORDINATING
COORDINATED PROJECTS FROM LOCALS
I MEAN ARE YOU DO YOU SEE A
SIMILAR TREND FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE FOR IN FROM THAT
HAZARD MITIGATION.
YEAH I THINK WE NEED TO DO
COLLECTIVELY A BETTER JOB AT ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO HAVE --
IDENTIFIED THE PROJECTS BEFORE
THE EVENTS --
IT LETS THEM GO THROUGH QUICKER --
AND AND THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO
INCORPORATE THEM ON THE RECOVERY.
I THINK WHAT HAPPENS IS --
YEAH WE DO A GREAT JOB RESPOND
DISASTERS AND ALL THE FIREMEN
AND MEDICAL AND EVERYONE'S THERE
THAT BEGINNING IN PART OF THE
RECOVERY PART THAT TAKES A LONG
TIME AND AND THE NEWS IS GONE BY
THAT POINT AND AND EVERYTHING
CHANGES AND THE FOCUS IS HOW
QUICK CAN I GET.
MY HOUSE REBUILD AND WE NEED TO
TAKE IN ACCOUNT LED STEP BACK
AND LOOK AT THE WHOLE PICTURE AT
THAT POINT.
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO PUT THEM
AS A TOGETHER --
SO THAT WE IMPROVE AND MAKE IT
MORE RESILIENT AND WHAT HAPPENS
IS WERE.
YEAH -- MRS
SMITH IS GET --
CHARGES YOU TRY TO REBUILD YOUR
HOUSE OR MISTRESS MRS TRIED
REBUILD HIS HOUSE AND THINKING
SINGLE AND WE NEED TO THINK.
COLLECTIVELY ACROSS THE BOARD AS
WE DO THIS AND SO HAVING
PROJECTS.
AND UNDERSTAND A RESTAURANT OR
REDUCING CALIFORNIA PRETTY WELL
BY NOW -- WE
NEED TO START LOOKING AT
GEOGRAPHICALLY WITH RHYS.
AND WHAT ARE THE PROJECTS THAT
MAKE THINGS MORE DEPARTMENT DID
ARE TWENTY FIVE DEPARTMENT DID --
BY REPLACING BRUCE YOU KNOW UP
THERE YOU KNOW SO DOING THINGS
LIKE THAT WERE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ANY TAKES ON A
RESPONSIBILITY WHERE THEY SEE A
RHYS HAPPENED SO THAT WHEN AN
EVENT HAPPENS.
THAT IS SHOVEL READY IT'S THERE
WE'RE NOT WAITING FOR YEARS FOR
TO GO THROUGH HIS STORE PROCESS
OR ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS WILL
GET TAKE IT PULL DOWN FUND IT
AND MOVE ON IN JUST GIVE US A
LOT MORE DETAIL THE TRUCKEE
PROJECT BEFORE IT WILL I THINK
BE HELPFUL TO SOME.
OF THE MEMBERS HERE.
WHEN WHEN DID IT OCCUR AND AND
HOW DID IT?
COME ABOUT.
IT HAPPENED --
I DON'T HAVE A THE DATE BUT I
THINK IT HAPPENED OVER ITS --
IN KINGSBURY --
AND THEIR TAHOE IN TRUCK YOU
FIRE DEPARTMENT --
TOOK ON A PROJECT WHERE THE
NOLLIE REDUCTIONS DEFENSIBLE
SPACE --
AROUND --
RESIDENTS BUT THEY ALSO DID A
PROJECT WHERE THEY DID ROOF
REPLACEMENT FOR EXISTING ROOFS
THAT - THAT --
YOU KNOW NEEDED --
TO MAKE SO.
SO THERE ARE PROJECTS WE CAN DO
WE LOOK AT EVERYTHING FROM A
BENEFIT COST ANALYSIS WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE IT COMPLIES WITH DEEP
ON HIS STORE STATE HISTORIC
PRESERVATION.
BUT THE LET'S IDENTIFY THOSE
AREAS AHEAD OF TIME WHERE
THERE'S TO THE CHIEFS THE POINTS
BEHIND ME THERE'S EXISTING
STRUCTURES THAT --
MAYBE ARE RESILIENT --
WE CAN GO AHEAD AND TAKE THE
MITIGATION MONIES COME FROM
THESE ASTERS TO DO THAT.
WE DO THINGS LIKE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE WE COULD DO HAS --
FEEL REDUCTION --
IN A NEW CONSTRUCTION OBVIOUSLY
NATION RESISTING CONSTRUCTION
WHICH IT SEEMS LIKE YOU'RE CLOSE
REQUIRE ANYWAY WE REFUND YOUR
CODE REGARDLESS.
THANK YOU.
THE SWITCH WOULD TAKE ME TO SEE
IF WE HAVE ADDITIONAL WE HAVE
SENATE JACKSON CENTER ABOUT.
THANK YOU FIRST I WANT TO JOIN
IN AND THANKING YOU FOLKS FOR
THE EXTRAORDINARY EFFORTS I MEAN
WE WE HAVE SEEN OUR SHARE OF
DISASTERS I THINK WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE.
TO FIGHT THEM TO REDUCE THE AND
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS PROBABLY
BETTER THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
OUR OUR MUTUAL AID PROGRAM
EVERYTHING I THINK IS IS THE
MODEL FOR THE COUNTRY.
AND APPRECIATE THAT AND I WOULD
AGREE I DON'T USUALLY SPEAK
MISTER MCGUIRE LANGUAGE SHE'S
TOO YOUNG FOR ME BUT THIS IS THE
DYNAMIC DO WELL HERE --
IN TERMS OF THE WORK THAT YOU'VE
DONE BOTH WITH THE STATE THE
MISTER GELLER TO CHI AND OF
COURSE --
WITH FAMOUS WELL --
BUT THAT BEING SAID TO ME WE WE
ARE AS GOOD AS WE ARE IN GREAT.
MEASURE BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD
EXPERIENCE IN THIS WE'VE SEEN A
NUMBER OF THESE.
NATURAL DISASTERS FOR DECADES
AND AND WE ARE GETTING A BETTER.
SADLY -- AND
BETTER THROUGH EACH ONE OF THESE --
BUT I'M I'M KIND OF HOW WE CAN
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS IN
ADVANCE.
BECAUSE A LOT OF THESE INCIDENTS
OCCUR AND PEOPLE THINK OVER IT'S
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN HERE --
AND THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH A
LOT OF THIS HARDENING AND SO
FORTH ARE EXPENSIVE --
SO.
WE ALSO HAVE A PROBLEM I HAVE TO
SHARE WTH YOU SOMEONE WHO LIVES
NOT TOO FAR FROM WHERE THE
THOMAS FIRE ENDED IN WHERE THE
DEBRIS FLOW OCCURRED --
INSURANCE.
IS A REALLY SERIOUS PROBLEM THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE WITHIN THOSE
AREAS ARE FINDING IF THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE WILLING.
TO EVEN.
EXTEND INSURANCE ARE TRIPLING
AND QUADRUPLING THE COST OF
PREMIUMS MAKING FOR SOME PEOPLE
DIFFICULT IF NOT UNAFFORDABLE.
OTHERS OF US ARE GETTING NON
RENEWED.
BECAUSE WE LIVE IN QUOTE UNQUOTE
HIGH RISK AREAS.
SO I I SUSPECT THAT WILL BE A
LITTLE BIT OF AN INCENTIVE BUT I
WONDER IF THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WE CAN DO JUST GIVEN THE
HUMAN NATURE AS WE ALWAYS TEND
TO CLOSE THE BARN DOOR AFTER THE
ANIMALS OF LEFT.
ANY OTHER INCENTIVES THAT MIGHT
EXIST THROUGH THE STATE.
THROUGH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO NOT ONLY GET OUR COMMUNITIES
TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE CANDID
ABOUT.
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF?
STREETS IN MY COMMUNITY THERE
ONE WAY OUT.
WE WERE UP IN THE HILLS IT'S AT
THE PROBABLY I THINK FOR THE
MOST BEAUTIFUL PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT THERE'S A COST ASSOCIATED
WITH LIVING THERE.
AND THESE ARE RISKS THAT PEOPLE
TELL --
UNTIL THEY HAPPEN.
AND IT'S JUST THE HUMAN I GUESS
WHAT I I'M INTERESTED IN IS THE
HUMAN NATURE FACTOR.
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH WHETHER
IT'S A CITY PLANNING FINALS BEEN
BIG RESISTANCE IN IN THE
MONASHEE TO WORRY ABOUT LIFTING
HOMES UP FIFTEEN FEET REBUILDING --
UP AND THE COSTS OF SAUDI
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT ARE
ENORMOUS A LOT OF PEOPLE AREN'T
GOING TO WANT TO REBUILD THAT
WAY AND YET WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS A TOTALLY IMPERFECT
SCIENCE WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
NEXT EVENTS GOING TO BE.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO
BE A TORNADO.
I MEAN IT'S A YOU KNOW LET'S
LET'S FACE CLIMATE CHANGES HERE
IN ITS IN ITS WREAKING HAVOC.
ON THIS ENTIRE COUNTRY --
WHAT DO WE TELL THE PEOPLE IN
THE SO CALLED HIGH RISK AREAS
BECAUSE I CAN'T THINK OF PARTY
CALIFORNIA TODAY THAT ISN'T HIGH
RISK -- DO
WE LET THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
COME IN AND JUST BURY US.
WITH HIGH COST INSURANCE
PREMIUMS TO WE TRY TO WORK WITH
OUR CITIES AND OUR COUNTIES TO
FORCE THEM TO DO.
SOME MAKE SOME VERY TOUGH
DECISIONS THAT ARE NOT POPULAR --
THE END AND YET YOUR USER
THERE'S MONEY WE'RE LEAVING ON
THE TABLE TO DO THIS.
MAYBE IT'S MAYBE I'M ASKING A
QUESTION THAT REALLY IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF OF US AS
POLICYMAKERS BUT YOU FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF EXPERTS DO YOU
HAVE SOME THOUGHTS.
pCOMMUNITIES AND HELP OUR
NEIGHBORS.
AND AND ALSO YOU KNOW LET'S NOT
LET THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY OFF
THE HOOK HERE.
ARE THEY RAISING PREMIUMS JUST
BECAUSE OF THE INCREASED RISK
FACTOR OR THEY DOING IT TO BE
ABLE.
TO GOUGE THE THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA GREATER GREATER LEVEL --
THERE A GET A LOT OF PLAYERS
HERE AND SOME ARE GOING TO USE
IS TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE ARE PROTECTED?
AND THAT WE ARE STILL ABLE TO
ACCESS SOURCES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO US JUST A SMALL
QUESTION [inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL ALL STAR THE HELLO BOB I
MEAN --
SENATOR ROBB.
IN AGAIN I THINK IT'S FIRST OF
ALL LET ME SAY THAT.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE HAVE TO
MOVE FORWARD IN A WHOLE OF
COMMUNITY APPROACHES ISN'T JUST.
ONE ELEMENTARY ASPECT --
IT'S PUBLIC PRIVATE WHICH
INCLUDES INSURANCE COMPANIES AT
THE TABLE IT'S OUR COMMUNITY.
BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS THE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THEMSELVES.
WE NEED TO BUILD A CULTURE
PREPAREDNESS WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT'S IN OUR
PLANNING IT'S IN OUR POLICY.
IS THAT OUR COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ARE CITY CANCERS
THAT ARE MAYOR.
AS WE YOU YOUR WERE FACED WITH
TWO THINGS WERE FACED WITH
EXISTING DEVELOPMENT THAT'S IN
PLACE.
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
YEARS THAT NEEDS TO BE
RETROFITTED OR UPGRADED.
BACK COULD BE PROGRAMS WHERE IN
THE KICK IN THE CONTEXT OF
WILDFIRE BECAUSE THERE'S A YOU
SAID THERE'S SO MANY RISK.
WE HAVE WE HAVE.
WE HAVE EARTHQUAKE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT IN CONTEXT A
WILDFIRE YOU KNOW.
HAVING --
THE THE THE CITY OR COUNTY
PLANNERS WORKING WITH THE MERGES
HE MANAGEMENT WORKING WITH --
I WAS AT A WE ANSWERED CAL FIRE
AT THE STATE.
OFFICE OF A POP GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH --
BEING ABLE TO LOOK AT OF HIGH
SEVERITY SEVERITY FIRES JONES
AND THEN AND THEN BUILDING SOME
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THROUGH SOME
OF THESE MEDICATION PROGRAMS --
TO WORK ON WAYS TO MAKE YOUR
HOUSE MORE HARDENED MORE
RESILIENT THROUGH A COULD BE
THROUGH CAPPING ALL THE EAVES IT
COULD BE THROUGH PUTTING CERTAIN
SCREENS ON THE WINDOWS.
THE LITTLE THINGS THAT MATTER
BUT BUT CAN BE OFFSET BY CERTAIN
LOANS WE ENCOURAGE HOMEOWNERS TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION WITH THEIR
INSURANCE COMPANIES SAY LOOK.
YOU WANT TO RAISE MY RACE BUT
WHAT IT WHAT ARE YOU DOING AND
HOW CAN WE WORK TOGETHER TO HELP
BY DOWN THE RISK WHAT CAN I DO
AS A HOMEOWNER TO HELP.
IN THIS EFFORT RIGHT TO BUY DOWN
THE RISK BECAUSE I NEED
INSURANCE AND INSURANCE IS
IMPORTANT --
AND AND AND THEN AND THEN
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY SAY
OKAY LOOK AT IT FOR A TIGHT.
TIGHTLY IMPACTED AREA IN THE WE
WE WE HAVE SMALLER ROADS OR OR
PLACES AND I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT CENTER IT
BEAUTIFUL PART OF IT --
RAMANA CO --
MAYBE WE NEED TO HAVE --
SIGNAGE PUT UP IN SOME TRAINING
TO THE PUBLIC ON EVACUATION
ROUTES THOSE SIGNS ARE CLEARLY
ARTICULATED IN MARK PEOPLE NOW
MUCH LIKE WE DO WITH OUR SON A
TSUNAMI BACK.
YOU ATION ZONES HOW TO GET OUT
OF AN AREA VERY FAST AND THEN
DIVERSITY PUBLIC EDUCATION
CAMPAIGN THAT ABSOLUTELY HAS TO
GO WITH THAT BECAUSE EVERYBODY
NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
WE LIVE IN A HIGH RISK AREA
WHICH MEANS THAT WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT GOES ON IN THE HIGH RISK
AREA AND WERE PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO THAT.
SO THAT'S SORT OF PRE VET POST
EVENT -- YOU
KNOW OF OR OR WHEN YOUR BILL
BUILDING THE OTHER THE OTHER
PIECE WHEN YOU ACTUALLY
APPROVING.
A DEVELOPMENTS FOR COMMUNITY
CITY COUNCIL OR BOARD TO RESERVE
REDEVELOPMENT THEY ABSOLUTELY
HAVE.
TO APPROVE THAT DEVELOPMENT IN
THE CONTEXT --
ARE ARE REALLY SELL DEVELOPERS
PRIVATE SECTOR TYPE A LOT --
TRYING TO TO MINIMIZE THE COST
OF DEVELOPMENT WE HAVE TO BUILD
IN AS A AS A ETHOS OF OF OF OUR
COMMUNITIES A SAFETY A COMPONENT
DOES.
DOES NEW DEVELOPMENTS FIRST OF
ALL WE HAVE TO DETERMINE WHERE
WE PUTTING DEVELOPMENT.
I KNOW FOR A FACT SINISTER THAT
THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSIONS IN BUILDING IN SOME
PLACES UP IN THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS THAT ARE RIGHT
DIRECTY IN THE PATH OF FUTURE
FIRES I WILL GUARANTEE YOU.
RIGHT AND SO WE HAVE YOU FOR
WHAT ONE WHERE WE BUILDING TO
HOW DO WE MITIGATE THAT AND WHAT
IS A DEVELOPER RESPONSIBILITY TO
MITIGATE THAT BEFORE WE ACTUALLY
APPROVED THE PLAN.
AND THEN THAT THE COMMUNITY THAT
BUYS INTO THAT AREA KNOWS MUCH
LIKE IF YOU'RE BUYING INTO AN
AREA FLOOD PLAIN THAT YOUR
INSURANCE BECAUSE YOU'RE
PROBABLY GOING TO BE A LITTLE
HIGHER OR YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DO A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SO THOSE ARE ALL PRE ABOUT IDEAS
OF COURSE THE POST EVENT IT
GIVES YOU AN OPPORTUNITY
UNFORTUNATE OPPORTUNITY NOW YOU
HAVE A DESTROYED COMMUNITY THAT
YOU CAN CUT A BILL BACKS BETTER
AND AND STRONGER --
MOVIE FOR BUTTHAT IS A HARD
LESSON LEARNED TO DO IT THAT WAY
AND OF AND IN THAT CONTEXT
HERE'S THE CHALLENGE WE HAVE.
MOST COMMUNITIES DO NOT WANT TO
TAKE THE TIME TO BUILD OUT A
LONG TERM PLAN THEY GOT TO GET
THE TAX BASE GOING AGAIN SO JUST
LIKE BILL BACK.
FAST AND BILL BACK EXACTLY THE
WAY WE WERE BEFORE SO WE CAN GET
THE TAX BASE GOING AGAIN AND AND
THAT'S SOMETHING WHERE WE
COLLECTIVELY.
NEED TO BE MORE LEANING IN
ENSURE THAT WE'RE GOING TO BUILD
IT BACK IT'S GONNA BE VERY FOR
FUTURE.
THANK YOU INSTRUCTORS SHORT
QUESTIONS.
BUT A VERY GOOD ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH STRUCTURE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER
GRILLER DILLER DO CHI --
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL THAT
HEARINGS YOU BEEN.
TO THIS HOW MANY HAVE YOU DONE
SO FAR THIS YEAR LOTS ARE YEAH.
AND YOU VISITED PROBABLY WITH
ALL OF US INDIVIDUALLY SO I JUST
WANNA THANK YOU I APPRECIATE --
THAT CENTER JACKSON GAVE YOU A
SOAPBOX AND YOU TOOK IT AND I
WAS.
A GREAT ANSWER BUT I I'M KIND OF
THINKING IS I'M WATCHING YOUR IN
AND IN THIS YEAR --
THIS SORT OF IN A DIFFERENT
QUESTION BUT HAVE YOU HAD IT.
WHAT WE WOULD CALL AN AHA MOMENT?
THIS FROM THE COUNTY HIT YOU
BECAUSE YOU YOU HAD SO MANY
POINTS HERE I'M JUST WONDERING
IS THERE ANYTHING THAT YOU KIND
OF HAVE WELL THIS IS SOMETHING.
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
THAN BEFORE.
WELL I MEAN.
THE EVENTS A PARADISE WERE JUST
[inaudible]
ON BELIEVABLE LITTLE THAT'S ALL
I CAN DESCRIBE IT I MEAN I'VE
BEEN TO MANY EVENTS --
I THINK BUT BOB WOULD AGREE WE
WE THE THE THE AHA MOMENT.
AFTER LOOKING GOING THROUGH THE
SMOLDERING POWER AND I SOMEWHERE
LONG LOST THE WHOLE PLACE
BASICALLY.
WAS THAT WE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
BE DOING THIS DIFFERENTLY.
THERE IS THERE WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER WHATEVER THE DISASTERS
BECAUSE I WILL TELL YOU YOU
FOLKS TODAY RIGHT NOW AND AND
I'LL BE LONG GONE HOPEFULLY I'LL
BE LONG ON POINTS HAPPENS.
BUT WE'RE GONNA BE BACK HERE
AGAIN IN ON THESE FIRES AS BAD
AS THEY ARE ARE GOING TO BE
NOTHING.
FOLLOWING THE CATASTROPHIC
EARTHQUAKE IT'S GONNA HIT IN ONE
OF OUR URBAN CENTERS RIGHT.
SO IN AND THEN WE'LL BE REALLY
TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
DEVASTATION ON THE LEVEL THAT
WE'VE WE'VE LITERALLY NEVER
COPYCAT.
BUT THE AHA MOMENT IN IN
PARADISE WAS THAT LOOK WE WE WE
WE CANNOT WE WE HAVE TO THINK.
DIFFERENTLY AND ALL ALL OF US
HAVE TO COME TO THE TABLE IT
CAN'T BE NIBBLING AROUND THE
EDGES ANYMORE WE WE WE CAN'T BE
NECESSARY POLITICALLY CORRECT
AND SAY WELL WE'RE NOT WE DON'T
USE THE WORD MANDATE BECAUSE GOT
UPSET.
SOMEBODY SOMEPLACE OR WEEK WE
CAN WORK WE CAN'T YOU KNOW --
UP SAY SOMETHING ABOUT THE
INSURANCE WE WE ABSOLUTELY NEED
TO COME BECAUSE THIS IS A
PROBLEM THAT WE ALL HAVE AND WE
ALL CAN SOLVE IT WHERE WE HAVE
THE BEST MINDS HERE IN.
AND THAT USE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
SCIENCE AND UNIVERSITIES AND ALL
OF THE POLICY MAKERS --
LAWMAKERS COMING TOGETHER TO TRY
TO MAKE THIS THIS COME TOGETHER.
THANK YOU THANK FRAWLEY WORK
MISTER FENTON JUST ONE QUICK
QUESTION AND THAT IS --
OR MAYBE A COMMENT THANK YOU.
THE FEMA --
I GUESS THE QUESTION WOULD BE
THAT WHEN A DECISION IS MADE TO
HELP OUT A COMMUNITY.
THAT IT IS NOT REVOKED OR USED
AS LEVERAGE FOR SOMETHING ELSE
IS THERE A WAY.
THAT COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED.
YEAH I'M NOT --
BUT I'M NOT SURE A KNOW THE
CONTEXT BUT ONCE FEDERAL
DISASTERS ARE DECLARED --
THE AUTHORITIES GIVEN TO ME TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE FROM THE SAD
FACT -- I
PROVIDED --
TWO FOOLS EXTENT POSSIBLE --
MY PERSONAL --
THE WAY I PERSONALLY HAVE DONE
IT IN TWENTY FOUR YEARS AS I TRY
TO GO.
TO THE GREATEST PART OF MY
AUTHORITY --
TO HELP ACCOMPLISH --
AND GET THE SURVIVOR BACK ON
THERE FOR COMMUNITY TO THE FULL
SIX AND I CANCEL AYE.
I TRIED TO GO --
TO THAT POINT --
THERE IS A LIMIT TO MY
REGULATIONS WHAT I CAN AND CAN'T
DO.
AND FROM TIME TO TIME I HIT
THOSE LIMITS I USUALLY TRY TO
COMMUNICATE THOSE AHEAD OF TIME
AND MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS --
YEAH WHERE THE BLACK LINE IS ON
THOSE BUT I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
AREAS --
THAT WE DO THAT I BELIEVE IN --
YOU KNOW --
THE CARE VERSES A STAKE IN AND
TRYING TO AND I I TRY TO COME UP
WITH PROGRAMS THAT.
HELP PEOPLE OF OTHER THAN YOU
KNOW -- YOU
KNOW ME --
DO SOMETHING THAT --
WILL YOU AND ONE LAST QUESTION
AND THEN AND AGAIN WANT TO THANK
YOU.
FOR IF IT'S EVEN A TEMPORARY
HOUSING THAT YOU PROVIDE --
WE HAVE ALMOST ISSUE AT THE END
AND I'M WONDERING I LOOK AT
THOSE ANGELES GESTURE TESTS LE
USUAL.
I I LOOK AT I LOOK AT WHAT
YOU'RE USING YOUR MODULAR.
AND AND I'M WONDERING IF THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY WHEN YOU'RE DONE
THAT WE STORE THEM FOR YOU
SOMEWHERE TEMPORARILY --
AND THEN UTILIZE SEMI.
SO LOW ALL OR MODULAR HOMES --
AND TRAVEL TRAILERS ARE ACCESS
THE GSA PROCESS AND WE HAVE DONE
THAT --
BEFORE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN A FEW SOME FOR ACTUALLY
PASSES Là OF FIRES THAT DID NOT --
WARD LE FEDERAL DECORATION LEVEL
SO -- WE'RE
GLAD TO DO THAT TRIBES OF TAKING
THEM FROM US AND PRITCHARD AND
FOR US SO THEY GO --
AND AND GET ACCESS TO THAT
PROCESS IN ITS --
OFFICIAL --
PROCESS AND CHIU STATES THAN
CITIES AND THEN GOES OUT TO
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS THAT COULD
PROJECTED THEIR THANK YOU MISTER
THANK YOU RICHARD THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IT WOULD LIKE ME TO
LOOK TO THE COMMITTEE OF ONE
LAST QUESTION.
AND THAT WOULD BE SO WE'VE HEARD
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
COMPREHENSIVE THERE IT IS BECOME
FRIENDS ARE APPROACH INSURANCE --
MANDATED BUILDING STANDARDS WITH
EXISTING AND NEW CONSTRUCTION.
I NEED TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
BETTER SIGNAGE AND POTENTIALLY --
AFTER A REBUILD OF A DISASTER
NEW EVACUATION ROUTES
[inaudible]
TELECOM.
IN WHAT ABOUT STRATEGICALLY BY
NOW PROPERTY OWNERS IF THEY LIVE
IN HIGH FIRE.
THREAT ZONE MISTER FENTON.
YEAH WE I MEAN IT'S SOMETHING WE
COULD DO WE DO OFFER FLOODS
OBVIOUSLY --
THERE'S A BENEFIT COST ANALYSIS
THAT MUST BE DONE --
AND WE'RE GLAD TO ENTERTAIN
THOSE PROJECTS AND HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ON THOSE ONCE IT'S
DONE THOUGH IT TURNS INTO GREEN
SPACE -- ANY
BY OUT IN FLOOD PRONE AREAS OR
FOR IN AND YOUR EXAMPLES GO YOU
IN A FIRE PRONE AREA IF WE DID
THAT IT WOULD TURN TO GREEN
SPACE YOU CAN NEVER THEN BE USED
AGAIN.
FOR A BUILDING A THING ON IT BUT
WE'RE GLAD TO ENTERTAIN THOSE
PROJECTS AND HAVE DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT HIM --
AND AS LONG AS A BE TO MEET THE
BENEFIT COST ANALYSIS WE CAN GO
AHEAD AND FUN WITH HAS MEDIATION
FOR ME MISTER MINISTER MISTER
DIRECTOR.
COMMENTING ON THAT.
WELL I MEAN I I AGREE WITH BOB I
MEAN WE WE WE CERTAINLY ARE ARE
WOULD BE.
WILLING TO FIND THOSE AGAIN IT'S
A IT'S A BALLOTS RIGHT SO WHERE
WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA WITH A
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND THEN WE'RE WE'RE LIMITING
STE PLACES THAT YOU'RE BY.
YOU KNOW CAN YOU THE IDEA WE
GONNA COST BENEFIT ON CAN YOU
MAY GET IT ENOUGH TO MAKE IT A
SAFE AREA RIGHT --
SO -- AND
THEN IF IF IT'S YOU CAN'T AND
IT'S GREEN SPACE THEN AND GREEN
SPACE AND A HIGH FIRE AREA NEEDS
TO BE MAINTAINED.
IN THE YEARS TO COME SO THERE'S
A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS TO
LOOK AT BUT CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE DONE THAT IN
THE PAST AND IT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO AND IN
OUR IN OUR HIGHEST AYE STONE AYE
AYES FIRES ON AREAS.
THANKS SO MUCH AS A DIRECTOR
<c.cyan>G TURNED OVER TO THE CHAIR</c>
AND BEFORE I DO JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO IS HE IS ONE TO
SHOW QUESTION AND THEN WILL
INTRODUCE OUR NEXT PANEL TO SAY
THANK YOU MISTER FENTON.
MR DUTY FOR THE INCREDIBLE WORK
TRULY MEAN IT AT THE TWO YOU
HAVE JUST BEEN FANTASTIC.
IN OUR DARKEST DAYS AND WILL
NEVER BE ABLE TO EXPRESS HOW
GRATEFUL I KNOW MANY OF US ARE I
THINK SO MUCH AND TURNED OVER TO
THE CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU. ONE ONE POINT FOR THE
QUESTION DRILLING DOWN A LITTLE
FURTHER MAYBE IN FOLLOW UP ABOUT
WHAT THAT THRESHOLD IS BETWEEN
MITIGATE HERBAL.
RISK FOR LACK OF A BETTER WORD
VERSUS.
IF IT'S TO THICK WHAT'S THAT
THRESHOLD WHAT RIGHT.
WHERE DO YOU DRESS THE TALKING
WITH SOME DEVELOPMENTS IN THE
SANTA MONICA MOUNTAINS?
THAT'S THAT'S A BIG CONCERN AND
I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO MANAGE
THAT OPEN SPACE INTELLIGENTLY IF
WE DIDN'T ACTUALLY DEVELOP THEIR
BUT IS.
I'M I'M ASSUMING FROM WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S IT'S IT'S
SORT OF A GRAY AREA IS GRAY.
COMPLEX AND AND IT DOES REQUIRE.
I MEAN LOOK I MEAN I DON'T THINK
IT'S THE FIRST.
WHEN A BUILDING AT ALL THEY'RE I
MEAN THEY'RE THE WE HAVE TO
REALLY DO AN ASSESSMENT AND A
GOOD STUDY TO DETERMINE?
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT KIND OF
PROGRAMS COULD BE PUT IN PLACE --
YOU'LL GET A LOOK AT THAT.
IT KIND OF FUELS BEDS THAT ARE
THERE WHAT THE WHAT THE FIRE
HISTORY IS WHAT ONE OF THE
PREVAILING WINDS ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE FACTORS HOW DO YOU
WANT TO BUILD STRUCTURE YOU WANT
TO BUILD THERE WHERE THE
BUILDING MATERIALS YOU'RE GOING
TO USE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WHAT'S THE EGG
INGRESS AND EGRESS AND SO
THERE'S THEIR STUDIES THAT CAN
BE DONE TO TO LOOK AT ALL OF
THAT AND AND THEN MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT -- IT'S
A VIABLE TO BUILD IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA RIGHT SO WE'RE
NOT JUST SAYING NO WE'RE SAYING
CONDITION OLE I MEAN THIS RIGHT
YOU'VE GOT INTIMATELY THE AND
YOU MAKE A LOOK WE'VE WE'VE
LOOKED AT ALL THE MEDICAID OF
ALL THINGS AND THIS IS STILL.
A DISASTER WAITING TO HAPPEN.
WE WE SHOULD JUST NOT GO THERE
AND SO.
I WITH THE ONE THING WE DIDN'T
TOUCH ON AND OF ALL THE SORT OF
MITIGATION --
TOOLS WE'VE GOT IS ON THE POWER
SIDE --
POWER IS LIFE IN IN THESE
MOMENTS IS WHAT YOU KNOW KEEP IN
URGENT CARE CENTER ONLINETO DO
WITH VICTIMS IT'S HOURS ARE CELL
INFRASTRUCTURE --
I HEARD AN IDEA AND I WANT TO
GET YOUR TAKE ON IT IN TERMS OF
HAVING PROPER BACKUP POWER
SYSTEMS IN PLACE --
BOTH FOR CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AND POTENTIALLY EVEN GOING ALL
THE WAY DOWN TO RESIDENTIAL
SCALE.
BUT NOT I'M NOT SO MUCH ON THE
GENERATION SIDE PER SE BUT BUT
STORAGE OF OF THAT --
BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY GENERATION
BUT IF WE HAD BATTERY BACKUP
POWER FOR INSTANCE FOR ALL
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
THROUGHOUT THE HI FI SEVERITIES
ON THE STATE --
DO YOU SEE THAT IS A IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR AT LEAST ON THE THE
RESPONSE I DON'T KNOW DOESN'T
ACTUALLY MITIGATE RISK
NECESSARILY BUT WHAT WOULD IN IN
ENTERING THESE DISASTERS I MEAN.
THAT THAT POWER CHALLENGE IN
REBUILD CAN BE WOULD WE BE
BENEFITTED FROM.
SORT OF MORE RESILIENT POWER
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THOSE AREAS.
ABSOLUTELY CELL.
BATTERY BACKUP POWER IS A GREAT
THING THEY HAVEN'T --
I'D LIKE TO SEE YOU KNOW
SOMETHING WHERE EVERY GAS
STATION HAS EITHER --
A SMALL GENERATOR CAPABILITY TO
KEEP THE POWER RUNNING FOR FUEL
SO THAT PEOPLE WERE EVACUATED TO
GET FEEL WHEN THEY NEED IT
BECAUSE WHEN THE POWER GOES DOWN.
THE POPS SHUT DOWN AND THEY
BASICALLY GO OF GOLD BOB YOU
KNOW INERT --
THAT'S A SMALL THING THAT COULD
HAVE A HUGE IMPACT --
WITH THE NOW NEW TECH BATTERY --
SUSTAINABLE LITHIUM BATTERY
BACKUP CAPABILITIES THAT COULD
BE EVEN BATTERY --
IF FLORIDA BAY MANDATED THAT
THEY THEY PUT A LONG PLACES SAID
THAT GET GAS STATIONS NEEDED TO
HAVE A GENERATOR POWER TO RUN
THEIR GAS IS BECAUSE IN FLORIDA.
WHEN THEY HAVE A HURRICANE
COMING IN THEY HAVE TO MOVE
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE?
THEY WERE HAVING GAS STATIONS
THAT WOULD YOU YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THE POWERS GOING OUT THEY JUST
THEY THEY THEY COULDN'T DO IT SO.
THEY REALLY LOOK AT LOOK AT THAT
AND I THINK THAT THERE'S AS OF
THINGS THAT -
THAT YOU COULD LOOK AT TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT AND AND YOU
KNOW CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CRITICAL MEDICAL --
SENIOR CARE FACILITIES ARE BIG.
ONE SPEAKER CARE FACILITIES
GENERALLY OR DO NOT HAVE THE THE
THE BACKUP POWER --
IN PLACE AND WHEN WE HAVE
SOMETHING YOU KNOW WHAT WE LOSE
THE POWER THERE ARE THE IT'S A
HUGE.
PRIORITY FOR US TO GET ANALYST
TEAMS TO THESE FACILITIES IN AS
MANY OF THEM AND AS THAT OUR
SOCIETY AGES GREATLY.
THERE ARE INCREASING IN NUMBER
AND SO IT'S IT'S THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE WE
COLLECTIVELY NEED TO FOCUS ON
AND AND SO ANY OF THOSE KINDS OF
MEDICAL HEALTH THINGS SHOULD
HAVE.
BACK UP AND WHAT THAT DOES IS
THAT MITIGATES --
THE IMPACTS AND QUITE FRANKLY IN
IN MANY CASES THAT COULD BE A
MEDIC THAT COULD BE A PROJECT
THAT COULD BE FUNDED THROUGH THE
MEDICATION PROGRAM SO THE COULD
BE FUNDS TO HELP GET THEIR WE
WOULD LOVE YOUR HELP GOING
FORWARD ON THAT LIST.
RIGHT HOW TO ACTUALLY AND IF
THAT TAKES GETTING BETTER LOCAL
DATA UP TO THE STATE LEVEL WE'RE
WILLING TO GO THERE --
MORE I I PERSONALLY AM BUT IS
WHAT WE DON'T KNOW WE DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHERE SOME OF THE SENIOR
CARE FACILITIES ARE FOR INSTANCE
AND MANY OF THESE JURISDICTION
SO WE COME IN WE HAVE A DISASTER
AND LIKE WHERE DO WE GO.
WE DON'T KNOW RIGHT SO I I'VE
HEARD THAT FROM LOCAL FIRE ON
NUEROUS OCCASIONS --
HOW TO GET THAT DATA SAID RIGHT --
SOMETHING WITH HOPEFULLY WORK ON
GOING FORWARD THANKS AGAIN.
ALL RIGHT --
WE'RE GONNA.
LET YOU GUYS GO TO YOUR
IMPORTANT JOBS.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE ND
INDULGING US AND FOR ALL YOUR
SERVICE AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE
FORWARD --
TO OUR I GUESS IT'S OUR THIRD
PANEL NOW --
SO I'D LIKE TO WELCOME UP DOCTOR
MATS MORE MAX MORITZ WHO'S A
STATEWIDE WILDFIRE SPECIALIST AT
THE UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION --
AS WELL AS JEFFREY LAMBERT WHOSE --
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT DIRECTOR
FOR THE CITY OF OXNARD PAST
PRESENT ALSO THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER --
AND FINALLY CHIEF KATE DARGAN --
THE RETIRED CALIFORNIA STATE
FIRE MARSHALL --
WELCOME TO ALL THREE OF YOU --
WE'RE GONNA DO FIVE MINUTES EACH
IF THAT'S AND THEN WE'LL OPEN IT
UP FOR QUESTIONS --
I SUPPOSE I CAN DEFERRED
WHOEVER'S GOT THEIR POWER POINT
FIRED UP FIRST OR WE CAN WAIT.
FOR WE CAN GET SOME HELP ON THE
THE DISPLAY AND GO TO THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE A POWER POINT FIRST.
OR DO ALL THE OF POWER POINTS.
OKAY SO WHEN WE START WITH A
LEFT TO RIGHT THAT MY LEFT TO
RIGHT WELCOME.
THANK YOU ARE.
DEFINITELY WORKS AS YOU
MENTIONED CITY OF OXNARD
ALTHOUGH ALL BE TALKING MOSTLY
THIS MORNING ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE
WITH THE CITY OF VENTURA.
IN THE THOMAS FIRE ON IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN ARE YOU ALL KNOW IT
WAS AT THE TIME THE LARGEST FIRE
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
IT DIDN'T LAST IN THAT CATEGORY
VERY LONG BECAUSE WE'VE HAD A
LONG HISTORY OF FIRES SINCE THEN --
JUST THE BASIC FACTS OF OUR
EXPERIENCE AND ENSURE WE LOST
FIVE ENGINE TWENTY FOUR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES ABOUT A HUNDRED
MULTI FAMILY UNITS INCLUDING A
MENTAL HEALTH A MENTAL HOSPITAL.
IN OUR COMMUNITY --
I WANT TO FIRST ALSO THANK THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAD A
TERRIFIC EXPERIENCE IN OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE --
BOTH CAL RECYCLE OUR CALVET
CAUGHT FIRE AND CAL WE **** WERE
ALL IMPORTANT PARTNERS IN OUR
SUCCESS --
AND I KNOW SENATOR JACKSON LEFT
BUT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT OUR
RECOVERY --
AND I I THINK THE FIRST POINT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE TO THE PANEL
TODAY IS ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
AHA MOMENTS FOR ME IN THE
RECOVERY SINCE I WAS IN CHARGE
OF RECOVERY NOT THE FIRE
FIGHTING PART OF IT --
AS A COMMITTED ON THE DIRECTOR
AND THE CITY OF AN A A IS WE
STARTED WITH THE WITH THE
RECOVERY ON DAY.
ONE WE WERE REALLY IN THE FIELD
LOOKING AT THE EXTENT OF THE OF
THE DAMAGE AND WHAT WE HAVE
AHEAD OF US FOR THE RESULT
PROCESS ON DAY.
ONE AND THE KEY THE CALIFORNIA
SYSTEM IS INCREDIBLE AND
IMPRESSIVE WE HAD EIGHT THOUSAND
FIREFIGHTERS IN OUR COMMUNITY --
BUT I'M NOT SURE THE SYSTEM IS
SET UP TO HELP CITIES FIGURE OUT
HOW TO RECOVER SO ONE OF THE
THOUGHTS I HAD IS IT IF IF THAT
GOT THAT WHOLE COMMAND CENTER.
CENTER WHICH IS AS YOU ALL UP TO
TRIXIE IS IMPRESSIVE.
HAVING A BETTER SENSE OF HOW TO
HELP CITIES HAVE IT TO RECOVERY
ACT ON DAY ONE BECAUSE WE HAD TO
DO THAT.
OUR COMMUNITY EXPECTED TO
RECOVER AND REBUILD --
AND THEY WERE ASKING US THOSE
QUESTIONS IMMEDIATELY AND WE
DIDN'T HAVE A REAL PLAN AHEAD OF
US WE GOT THERE.
ARE THROUGH OUR PARTNERSHIPS BUT
IT WASN'T ALWAYS I I ALSO WILL
SAY THAT WE ARE WE DID NEVER
QUESTION THE IDEA OF REBUILDING
IN OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE WE WERE
SET UP WITH.
BOUNDARIES --
WHERE ARE DEVELOPMENT LIMITS
WERE BASED ON OUR --
PROTECTION AGRICULTURE AN OPEN
SPACE SO THE IDEA OF REBUILDING
WAS AN OBVIOUS CHOICE FOR US AND
WE DIDN'T SECOND GUESS THAT
PROCESS --
SO WE HAD TO GET THERE PRETTY
QUICKLY A AND SO THAT US SOME
HELP THROUGH THE COMMAND CENTER
HOW CITIES CAN MAKE THAT
TRANSITION TO RECOVER WOULD BE.
REALLY HELPFUL FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
I THINK THE MANY THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF ASKING THIS QUESTION
AND DEBT I THINK THE OTHER PART
MOVING FORWARD TOWARDS.
PROTECTING OUR NEIGHBORHOODS IS
WE HAVE TO TALK A LOT ABOUT HOW
TO PROTECT OUR EXISTING HOMES
BEFORE THE FIRE.
ON AND I THINK YOU'VE TALKED A
LOT ABOUT THAT AND I DON'T NEED.
TO EMPHASIZE IT TOO MUCH THEY
THINK YOU'RE HEADING IN THAT
DIRECTION BUT HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT HOMES --
THAT ARE EXISTING BEFORE I FIRE
ARE BETTER THAT'S PROTECTED ONE
OF THOSE WAYS IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE WE HAVE MORE MORE
ROBUST DEBRIS I SEE MOBILE MORE
ROBUST --
REMOVAL OF VEGETATION AROUND
HOME SYSTEM.
IN OUR PARTICULAR CASE WE HAD
WERE VERY GOOD ABOUT THE HOMES
AT THE EDGE OF THE FIRES ON SO
IN OUR IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
THOSE HOMES AROUND THE EDGES
WERE VERY MUCH PUSH TO DO THAT
THAT CLEARANCE EVERY YEAR.
WE DIDN'T DO SO MUCH OF THE
HOMES IN THE MIDDLE OF HEY SOME
OF THE HOMES AT THE EDGES DID
BETTER THAN THOSE IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE WE WERE FACED WITH THE
HUGE AND VERY FAST FIRE --
AND THE FLAMES ACTUALLY JUMPED
THE EDGE AND WENT INTO THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE MIDDLE AND
THOSE HOMES IN THE MIDDLE OF
THOSE NEIGHBORHOODS WERE NOT
PROTECTED BECAUSE WE DID NOT
PUSH.
A ROBUST WAY THAT THEY DO THAT
CLEARANCE SO I THINK ANYTHING
THE STATE CAN DO TO HELP
ENCOURAGE MANDATE --
OR PROVIDE THE RESOURCES THAT
CITIES CAN DO A BETTER JOB OF
MAKING SURE THAT HOMES ARE
PROTECTED IN ADVANCE OF A FIRE --
WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL I I THINK
THE OTHER THING AND WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT TOO IS HOW
DO WE RETROFIT HOMES IN ADVANCE
OF A FIRE --
THE BUILDING CODES ARE IN THE
PROCESS BEING UPDATED TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY EVERY TIME WE'D UP
CODES WE LEARN FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE --
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO LEARN
FROM OUR EXPERIENCE FROM FIRES
WHAT ADDITIONAL.
RESTRICTIONS ON ON BUILDING
CODES THAT WE CAN PUT IN PLACE.
TO MAKE SURE THAT NEW
DEVELOPMENT MEETS THOSE HIGHER
STANDARDS OF BEING MORE
PROTECTED MORE FIRE RESISTANT IN
THEIR CONSTRUCTION.
BUT I THINK THE SECOND PART OF
THAT IS HOW DO WE GO BACK TO
RETROFIT EXISTING HOMES YOU ALL
MENTIONED THAT A LOT ALREADY
THIS MORNING.
I THINK THE MORE THE STATE CAN
DO TO PROVIDE THE REQUIREMENTS --
IN THE CODE THAT THAT WOULD PUSH
THOSE -- BUT
ALSO --
INCENTIVES TO HELP YOU DO WITH
THE THE SEISMIC SYSTEM FOR
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
CAN MAKE THEIR HOMES MORE
RESISTANT.
ON BEFORE FIRE IT WILL STILL
SAVE THEM AND ALL OF US IN OUR
RESPONSE THE FIRES OF THOSE
THINGS HAPPENED I THINK THAT
WOULD BE A VALUABLE.
EXPERIENCE I WILL NOTE ON A SIDE
NOTE ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
KEEPS ME UP AT NIGHT --
POST FIRE IS --
WE LOST FIVE AND TWENTY FOUR
POOR HOMES WE WOULD NOW WE
SHOULD PERMITS FOR OVER THREE
HUNDRED OF THOSE HOMES TO START
CONSTRUCTION.
THOSE HOMES WILL MEET ALL
CURRENT BUILDING CODE
REQUIREMENTS RIGHT TO THE HOMES
THAT SURVIVED THE FIRE.
WERE BUILT IN THE EIGHTIES WHEN
WE HAD THE SEISMIC EVENT THEY
WILL NOT SURVIVE SO THE THE
PEOPLE THAT GOT THROUGH THE
THOMAS FIRE WILL NOT GET THROUGH
THE NEXT EVENT SO HOW CAN WE DO
MORE TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
HOMES THAT ARE EXISTING.
WHETHER IT'S SEISMIC OR FIRE
AREAS ARE ARE ARE TAKEN CARE OF
IN ADVANCE.
I THINK THE OTHER PART IS IS
FRANKLY CONTINUING TO PUSH
CITIES TO BUILD INFILL
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S WHERE THE
DEVELOPMENT SHOULD BE --
AND I I CAN SAY THIS BECAUSE I'M
NOT REPRESENTING THE CITY I WORK
FOR DURING THE FIRE --
AND I WORK FOR CITY NOW IT
DOESN'T REALLY HAVE A FIRE --
LIKE THE VENTURE DID BUT YOU
KNOW AND ENSURE IT DOES DO
INFILL IT'S OUR IT REALLY IS A
CORNERSTONE OF OUR LAND USE
POLICY BUT REALLY PUSHING MORE
CITIES TO DO INFILL DEVELOPMENT --
AND AND KEEPING THAT EDGE ARE
PROTECTED FROM DEVELOPMENT SO
THAT WE'RE NOT PUTTING MORE
HOMES AND MORE PEOPLE AT RISK I
THINK THAT WOULD BE IMPORTANT --
EFFORT FROM THE STATE TO HELPCITIES DO THAT --
I THINK THE MORE THAT YOU CAN DO
TO HELP AND ENCOURAGE CITIES TO
EVALUATE THE CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS OF THEIR RISK POLICIES
INCORPORATING THE RESULTS OF
THAT.
AND THE STATE I THINK CAN
PROVIDE THE SORT OF DATABASE AND
MAKE SURE IT'S A DATA DRIVEN
POLICY DECISION AND THAT DATA
CAN COME FROM THE STATE TO HELP
CITIES BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
STRETCHED TO DO EVERYTHING THAT.
I THE MORE THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE
US THE DATA IN ADVANCE SO THAT
WE UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THAT
DATA TO DRIVE POLICY AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WILL BE IN A BETTER
POSITION.
AND THAT DATA WILL ACTUALLY
PROVIDE BETTER RESULTS FOR US --
GOING FORWARD.
AND I I LOOK THE LAST THING I'LL
MENTION BECAUSE I WANT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE CAN MOVE ON TO YOUR
OTHER SPEAKERS IS. ONE OF THE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE AND
AND PRACTICALLY FOUND IN OUR
EXPERIENCE AND AND RECOVERING
AND REBUILDING FROM THE FIRE IS.
THE SORT OF A BUILT IN --
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE THE THE
DESIRE FOR DISPENSABLE SPACE.
AND THE DESIRE FOR A LANDSCAPING
PLAN IN THEM THE MODEL
LANDSCAPING PLAN ORDINANCE AT
THE STATE DR --
INTO SOMETIMES --
SINCE COMPLECTED AND WE FOUND
PEOPLE REALLY STRUGGLE WITH HOW
DO I COMPLY WITH THIS MODEL
LANDSCAPE ORDINANCE THE STATE
MADECITY ADOPT.
AND ALSO THE DEFENSE OF SPACE
THAT ARE FAR DEPARTMENT ASKED
THEM TO DO OR DEMANDED AND TO DO
ITS PART OF REBUILDING SO I
THINK MAKING SURE THAT THE CITY.
HAS UNDERSTANDS HOW THOSE
POLICIES A CONFLICT HOW DO WE
DEAL WITH THOSE CONFLICTS I'LL
LEAVE IT AT THAT THIS MORNING
AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU MISTER
LAMBERT [inaudible]
CHIEF JARGON.
SWITCH OVER DR MORITZ.
WHEN YOU HAVE BEEN HERE THANKS
TOM?
YEAH I APOLOGIZE FOR HAVING YOU
GUYS STARE AT A PICTURE OF ME
FOR THIS WHOLE TIME SHOULD IN
SOME FLAMES OR SOMETHING MORE
INTERESTING --
I'VE BEEN --
STATEWIDE COOPERATIVE EXTENSION
SPECIALIST IN FIRE FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS -- AND
DURING THAT TIME I HAVE
DEVELOPED A RESEARCH PROGRAM ON
HAZARD MAPPING EXTREME WIND
EVENTS THAT BECAUSE MOST OF OUR
LOSSES.
CLIMATE CHANGE MODELING AND MORE
RECENTLY ON LAND DEVELOPMENT
PATTERNS AND HOW THAT.
PLAYS A ROLE.
AND I MIGHT THROUGH MAKE SENSE
PROGRAM A TRY.
TO TRANSLATE THAT FOR DECISION
MAKING.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND IT'S COME UP ALREADY TO TO
SORT OF DISTINGUISH BETWEEN
WHICH PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING TO
SOLVE HERE I THINK IT'S IT'S
GOOD WHAT I'VE HEARD SO FAR --
WE WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
DO HAVE A WILDLAND FIRE PROBLEM
OUT THERE RIGHT.
THERE ARE FORCED LOS CLIMATE
CHANGE BARK BEETLE KILL DROUGHT.
THAT WILDLAND FIRE PROBLEM IS
DAUNTING AND IT HAS A LOT OF
LAND MANAGEMENT IMPLICATIONS.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE SEPARATE
FROM WHAT I WOULD CALL OUR HOME
LOS PROBLEM OUR HOME LIFE LAST
PROBLEMS --
THIS IS ONE OF OF WHERE AND HOW
WE BUILD IT'S ONE OF HOW WE GET
PEOPLE OUT OF THESE PLACES WHEN
THERE ARE FIRES.
AND THIS ISN'T A WILDLAND FIRE
PROBLEM THIS IS A WILD AND URBAN
INTERFACE PROBLEM RIGHT SO THESE
ARE REALLY DIFFERENT PROBLEMS
AND I THINK THAT.
TALKING ABOUT THEM AS SEPARATE
PROBLEMS THIS.
IS IMPORTANT SO I'M I'M
ENCOURAGED BY WHAT I'M HEARING
TODAY.
THERE ARE THAT MANY HOMELESS
STUDIES SURPRISINGLY I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN A COUPLE SOME FROM
AUSTRALIAN SOME FROM CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS ONE THAT'S GOING TO THE
FINAL STAGES OF PEER REVIEW.
I'M LOOKING AT THREE DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA OVER FIFTEEN
YEARS -- AND
ALSO LOOKING AT THE LAST FEW
LARGE FIRE EVENTS THIS GRAPH
HERE BASICALLY SHOWS --
HOUSING DENSITIES AND THE RED
BARS ARE THE NUMBER OF THE
NUMBER OF HOMES LOST DURING
FIRES.
AND THE BLACK BARS ARE OUR HOMES
THAT WEREN'T BURNED RIGHT AND
WHAT YOU SEE FROM THESE DATA.
ARE THAT LOWER HOUSING DENSITIES
AND THIS HAS BEEN REPEATED OVER
AND OVER IN IN OTHER STUDIES.
LOWER HOUSING DENSITIES TEND TO
BE WHERE WE LOSE MOST HOMES.
RIGHT AND THAT'S DESPITE.
EXCUSE ME THAT'S DESPITE SOME OF
THESE.
RECENT KIND OF CA AS I URBAN
FIRES WERE WE LOST A LOT OF
HOMES. THREE TIME IF YOU LOOK AT
THE BROADER PATTERNS ACTUALLY
LOWER DENSITY --
RURAL AREAS ARE PROBABLY THE
MOST AT RISK AND THAT THAT'S
KIND OF AN IMPORTANT.
IMPORTANT POINT.
I SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF TIME
THE LAST TWO YEARS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT GOES INTO URBAN
PLANNING AND LAND USE PLANNING
WITH RESPECT TO FIRE.
AND WHAT'S MISSING.
AND SO ARE.
WHAT'S BEEN KIND OF SURPRISING
TO ME IS TO FIND THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF GOOD.
EFFORT AN EMPHASIS ON THIS ON
THE BUILDING CODES AND THAT THE
SCALE OF AN INDIVIDUAL STRUCTURE.
BUT AS YOU ZOOM OUT AND LOOK AT
WHAT'S ON THE BOOKS.
FOR A CITING A COMMUNITY OR HOW
IT'S LAID OUT THERE'S ALMOST
NOTHING ACTUALLY.
THERE'S NOTHING CODIFIED ASIDE
FROM INGRESS AND EGRESS AND A
LITTLE BIT OF OF OUR WATER
REQUIREMENTS.
REGULATIONS THERE'S VERY LITTLE
AT BROADER SCALES ABOUT HOW WE
SITE AND LAY OUT A COMMUNITY
WHICH IS KIND OF SURPRISING --
AND SO AFTER INTERVIEWING AFTER
LOOKING THROUGH THE LITERATURE
INTERVIEWING FIREFIGHTERS THAT
OF WORKING FIVE MARSHALS OFFICES.
INTERVENING LAND USE PLANNERS
HOW THEY'VE INTERACTED WITH
THEIR FIRE PROFESSIONALS AND HOW
THE HOW THE PROCESS WORKS
INTERVIEWING THE CALIFORNIA LAND
USE PLANNING PROGRAM TEAM --
I REALIZE THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF RISK REDUCTION MEASURES WE
MIGHT CALL BEST PRACTICES THAT
ARE ACTUALLY NOT CODIFIED IN THE
NEED TO BE SO WE NEED STRONGER
LAWS ON THESE ISSUES.
THERE'S ANOTHER PIECE OF WORK
THAT -- I AM
INVOLVED WITH WITH A A COLLEAGUE
AT BERKELEY THIS IS --
EARLY EARLY IN THE PERIOD YOU
PROCESS BUT WE'VE COME UP WITH
THE TABLE BASICALLY OF OF THESE
RISK REDUCTION MEASURES WE DON'T
HAVE TIME TO GO THROUGH THE MALL
I JUST WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW.
PLEASE GET IN TOUCH WE ACTUALLY
HAVE COME UP WITH THE A SERIES
OF THESE THAT MAKES SENSE.
SOME OF THEM INVOLVE GETTING
FIREFIGHTERS OR FIRE
PROFESSIONALS INVOLVED EARLIER.
IN THE IN THE STRATEGIC PLANNING
CONVERSATIONS.
A LOT OF THEM ARE ABOUT THE
CITING AND THE LAY OUT OF AN
ACTUAL.
A NEIGHBORHOOD OR OR SUBDIVISION --
REDUNDANCIES.
REFUGES OF LAST RESORT FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO GET OUT
AND CAN'T --
WATER SUPPLY REDUNDANCIES AN
AUGMENTED --
SPRINKLER REQUIREMENTS.
AND IGNITION MANAGEMENT
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES SO ALL
THESE EXIST --
IN THE LITERATURE OR IN THE
MINDS OF OF IMPORTANT PEOPLE
PLAYING ROLES ON THIS BUT
THERE'S NO A FORTY THERE'S NO
REGULATORY --
REGULATORY AUTHORITY FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY REQUIRED THESE SO
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT'S NEEDED. FOR SO WE
ALREADY TALKED ABOUT THIS
LOOKING AT THE THE PROBLEM
SEPARATELY I EVEN THINK THAT IF
WE LOOKED AT WILDFIRE AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUE.
INSTEAD OF A LAND MANAGEMENT
ISSUE WE MIGHT HAVE A DIFFERENT
SET OF PLAYERS DIFFERENT SET
CONVERSATIONS --
AND HE'S COMMUNITY SCALE RISK
REDUCTION MEASURES WE CAN EXPAND
THE OFFICE OF PLANNING AND
RESEARCH CRITERIA THAT'S ONE
PLACE FOR THESE COULD GO.
AND THAT GIVES THEM SOME WEIGHT
THEY GIVE SOME SOME.
SOME AUTHORITY --
THE GENERAL PLAN ASSESSMENTS
THAT THAT CAL FIRE DOES.
THOSE ARE ALL RECOMMENDATIONS.
RIGHT.
THEY GET TO WEIGH IN ON THE
SAFETY ON THAT THOSE COULD BE
MORE THAN RECOMMENDATIONS THOSE
COULD BE MANDATORY.
RIGHT THAT'S NOT MY I THINK
SHOULD BE STRONGLY CONSIDERED
ALSO THE LOCAL FIRE MARSHALS
THAT ARE WEIGHING IN ON THESE
DEVELOPMENTS.
THEY'RE ALL RECOMMENDATIONS.
TO THE DEVELOPER CAN COME BACK
AND SAY NO I DON'T WANNA.
I DON'T WANT TO DO THAT I DON'T
WANNA MAKE THAT PERIMETER ROAD
LOOK LIKE THIS INSTEAD OF THIS
SO THERE'S NOTHING REQUIRED
THERE EITHER SO I THINK THE
LOCAL FIRE MARSHALS.
COULD BE GIVEN SOME MORE.
AUTHORITY AND THAT WOULD BE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
A VERY GOOD THANK YOU WELCOME
BACK TO AN ENDO DOWN IN A FEW
TOPICS BUT CHIEF TARGET
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TEST TEST THERE AGAIN.
AND LET'S GO.
TO WRITE THANK YOU --
I APPRECIATE BEING INVITED HERE
TODAY --
SENATORS AND AND STAFF.
SENATOR STERN YOU ASKED A
QUESTION A PRIOR HEARING WHAT.
IS THE RATIO OF AYE MITIGATION
TO OTHER KINDS OF INVESTMENTS
THAT WE CAN MAKE TO BUY DOWN
RISK AND I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
ANSWER ABOUT WHAT IT COULD BE MY
PROFESSIONAL.
JUDGMENT OR X. EXPERTISE ON THAT
IS IT SHOULD BE. TEN FORTY FORTY
TEN TEN IN OUR PLANNING PROCESS
40% OF OUR EXPENDITURES IN OUR
MEDICATION PROCESS 40% AND OUR
RESPONSE AND 10% IN A RECOVERY.
IF WE ARE SPENDING AN EQUAL
AMOUNT ON MITIGATION THAT WE'RE
SPENDING ON RESPONSE WE WILL
EVENTUALLY GET THERE
[inaudible]
AND IF WE HAVE TIME TODAY I'LL
GIVE YOU SOME OF THE BACK OF THE
AT BACK OF A NAPKIN NUMBERS
ABOUT THE COSTS OF RECTOR FITS
THE NUMBER OF HOMES THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
THE COST OF STAFFING TO MAKE
THAT A REALITY FOR US.
SO TO GET TO MY PRESENTATION --
I'VE SPENT FORTY YEARS IN THIS
FIELD AT EVERY ASPECT OF THIS
FROM THE GROUND LEVEL TO THE AIR
LEVEL TO THE TECHNOLOGY TO THE
PREVENTION MITIGATION POLICY
INSURANCE.
THERE IS NOT A PLACE OF THIS
THAT I HAVE NOT THREE THINGS TO
TRY TO COMMUNICATE TO YOU TODAY.
SEE WHAT'S MINE [inaudible]
THE ANSWER.
SO HERE ARE A US ALL THESE
THINGS THAT ARE COMPOSED IN THE
LAND USE PLANNING WORLD.
RELATIVE TO THE THINGS THAT WE
DO TO ADVANCE THE DISCUSSION.
YOU I DITTO VERYTHING THAT YOU
HAVE HEARD HERE TODAY THERE'S
NOT A SINGLE THING THAT I WOULD
SAY I COULD NOT STRONGLY
ADVOCATE.
FOR VERY FEW OF THESE THINGS
WHICH WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
FOR TWENTY YEARS NOW ARE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED OR EVEN
STAFFED OUT FOR AND SO THE THREE
THAT I'M BRINGING TO YOU TODAY
ARE.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT LAND USE
PLANNING FOR FIREFIGHTERS I
STARTED TEACHING THIS COURSE
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO.
IT HAS NOT LIFTED OFF THE GROUND
YET.
WHICH ONE THIS.
ONE YEAH THAT'S BETTER THANK YOU.
TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR WE BROUGHT
THE ENTIRE NAPA COUNTY BUILDING
PLANNING AND CONSERVATION
DEPARTMENT LAND USE PLANNERS
ALTOGETHER WE SHUT DOWN ALL OF
THE BUILDING AND PERMITTING
DESKS FOR THE DAY AND WE BROUGHT
ALL THE STAFF TOGETHER. FOR AN
EIGHT HOUR TRAINING COURSE IT IS
MY RECOMMENDATION THAT THE LAND
USE PLANNING PROFESSIONALS IN
THIS STATE THE BUILDING
INSPECTORS THE BUILDING
OFFICIALS THE LOCAL FIRE
MARSHALS IN THE LAND USE
PLANNING PROFESSIONALS.
AND CONSULTANTS THAT WANT TO
WEIGH IN ON LAND USE PLANNING.
BE REQUIRED TO ATTEND AN EIGHT
HOUR TRAINING COURSE THAT COURSE
DOES NOT EXIST YET TODAY
ALTHOUGH SEVERAL MODELS FOR THAN
DO EXIST.
BUT THE REQUIREMENT TO BUILD THE
REQUIREMENT TO UNDERSTAND THIS
RATHER THAN TRYING TO HAVE FIRE
FIGHTERS WEIGH IN ON A
PROFESSIONAL BODY OF KNOWLEDGE.
WE NEED TO CREATE A
CERTIFICATION PROCESS IN
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE LAND
USE PLANNING AND ASK OUR
PROFESSIONALS TO ATTEND THAT AT
LEAST ONE TIME IN THEIR CAREERS
SO THAT THEY'RE BRINGING THEIR
THEIR EXPERTISE IN LAND USE
PLANNING. TO THE ISSUE AT HAND
FOR THIS TYPE OF OF RISK.
AND ARE AND THAT WOULD BE A
RELATIVELY LOW COST WAY TO
IMPLEMENT AND THEN CREATE THE
ABILITY TO MOVE THAT BODY OF
KNOWLEDGE ACROSS THE
PROFESSIONALS THAT WILL CREATE
CONSISTENCY AND ALL OF THE PLANS.
AND DEVELOP THE THE CONCEPT THAT
YOU'RE HEARING.
THANK YOU MAX I ALSO THEN WANT
TO TALK ABOUT RISK AND
MITIGATION ANALYSIS.
WE ARE EMBARKING ON A
CONVERSATION OF SHOULD WE BUILD
IN CERTAIN SECTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE STARTING TO Q. THAT
DECISION UP BEHIND THE FIRE
HAZARD MAPS.
EXISTING ONES OR NEW ONES THEY
TELL US.
A CERTAIN COMPONENT OF THIS
QUESTION BUT THEY DO NOT TELL US
WHAT THE RISK IS THEY WILL TELL
US WHAT THE HAZARDOUS THE
PROBABILITY OF THE FIRE
OCCURRING AND THE RELATIVE
SEVERITY OF THE FIRE ITSELF.
BUT THEY DO NOT TELL US WHAT THE
DAMAGES BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
MEASURE THE MED MEDICATIONS THAT
WERE ASKING US TO COMPLETE
THERE'S NO WAY TO PUT THAT
TOGETHER IN A SYSTEMATIC MODEL.
SO WE HAVE AN EXAMPLE HERE THIS
IS WHAT FIRE HAZARD JONES LOOK
LIKE THEY'RE BIG THEY MAKE IT
DOWN TO SMALLER ACREAGES BUT
HEY'RE NOT OF THE PARCEL LEVEL
AND THEY WILL NOT TELL US
WHETHER WE CAN BUILD ON THAT
PARTICULAR PIECE OF GROUND OR
NOT.
WHY DO WE NEED TO KNOW THIS?
IT'S BECAUSE IT'S THE WAY THAT
OTHERS ARE STARTING TO DO THIS.
I HOW DID THIS IN ANOTHER
HEARING COLORADO SPRINGS IS AN
EXAMPLE OTHER COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE STARTED TO DO
THIS BUT ANALYZING RISK OF THE
PARTIAL LEVEL WHERE WE'RE
MEASURING THE MEDICATIONS THAT
WERE REQUIRING.
AGAINST THE HAZARD OF THE FIRE
BEHAVIOR ITSELF WILL START TO
TELL US IS IT BUILDABLE OR NOT
BASED ON AN ACCEPTABLE LEVEL OF
RISK.
THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE ONCE
YOU'VE IMPLEMENTED THAT
PROGRAMME ACROSS THE COMMUNITY
YOU START TO HAVE DISTINCTIONS
BETWEEN THOSE THAT ARE
RELATIVELY LOW RISK AND THOSE
THAT ARE EXTREMELY HIGH.
SO I BRING THAT TO YOU AS AN
EXAMPLE COMMUNITY TO LOOK TOWARD --
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO DESIGN A
PROGRAM LIKE THAT.
YOU HAVE MITIGATION METRICS THAT
ARE ACCESSIBLE AND INFORM
HOMEOWNERS --
YOU'VE HEARD A FEW ABOUT SOME OF
THE APPS IN OTHER.
PROGRAMS THAT HOMEOWNERS CAN AT
AND YOU GET DOWN TO THIS
QUESTION OF WHAT IS A STRUCTURE
IGNITION'S ON ASSESSMENT LOOK
LIKE THIS IS WHAT THE BODY OF
KNOWLEDGE IS OUT THERE IN THE
FIRE FIGHTING ARENA.
AND IN THE PLANNING ARENA THAT
SLOWLY STARTING TO DEVELOP WHY
IS THAT IMPORTANT IT'S BECAUSE
THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY METRICS
RISK THIS WAY THEY LOOK AT THE
PARTIAL Là OF ALL.
THEY LOOK AT WHAT A HOME IS LIKE
THEY MEASURE IT PARTIAL BY
PARCEL AND THEN THEY COSTS THAT
OUT THROUGH THE RATE SETTING
GUIDELINES WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE.
SO FOR EVERY PROPERTY IN THIS
STATE THERE'S AN INSURANCE.
ALGORITHM THAT IS DETERMINING
RISK AND THAT IS BEHIND WHAT IS
GOING ON WITH THE RISK STTING
POLICIES AND LESS OUR PUBLIC
POLICY AND OUR PUBLIC MAPPING
POLICIES ALIGN WITH THE
INSURANCE RISK SETTING.
METHODOLOGY WE'LL HAVE A BIGGER
AND BIGGER DISCONNECT.
WHICH IS WHY I RECOMMEND IN
RECOMMENDATION NUMBER TWO THAT
YOU ADOPT BOTH THE ZONING
OVERLAY WHICH COULD BE TEAR TO
THE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITIES ON
MAPS THAT'S A VERY CAPABLE TOOL
FOR DOING A ZONING OVERLAY.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO GET DOWN TO A
RISK ASSESSMENT YOU NEED A MODEL.
THAT EVERYONE AGREES TO SO IT'S
CONSISTENTLY A FORCED ACROSS THE
STATE THAT'S OF A VERY CAPABLE.
CAL FIRE IN CONJUNCTION WITH OPR
NOTE -- YES
WOULD BE VERY CAPABLE IT
DEVELOPING THAT MODEL AND IT
WOULD THEN IMPLEMENT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AND THEN THAT DATA
WOULD MOVE BACK AND FORTH
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCALS AT THE
PERSONAL LEVEL THAT IS
TECHNOLOGICALLY.
QUITE DOABLE TODAY.
LASTLY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
EDUCATION AND ENFORCEMENT WE
HAVE HAD THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
ORDINANCE ON THE BOOKS SINCE.
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR NOW I'M JUST
GOING TO MAKE A LITTLE BIT OF A
LECTURE MOMENT FOR ALL OF US IN
CALIFORNIA.
IF WE HAD ENFORCED DEFENSIBLE
SPACE CONSISTENTLY WHERE IT WAS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED SINCE
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR WE WOULD NOT
BE IN THE MESS WE'RE IN TODAY.
WE WOULD HAVE ISSUES AND WE
WOULD BE HAVING CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING
WITH LAND USE PLANNING AND SOME
OTHER THINGS BUT WE WOULD HAVE
GONE A LONG WAY IN ACCOMPLISHING
THAT.
SO STATUTORILY.
IT'S GOOD TO HAVE A MANDATE TO
REQUIREMENTS I SUPPORT THOSE BUT
IT'S THE CAPACITY BUILDING AND
THEN ENABLING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
TO ACHIEVE THE RESULTS OF THAT
STATUTE OR REQUIREMENT OR
MANDATE.
THAT WE NEED THIS IS WHAT IT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
AT THE TECHNOLOGICAL LEVEL WE
NEED A SET OF BOOTS UP EVERY
DRIVE WAY ON TWO MILLION
PROPERTIES IN THIS STATE TO HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
RETROFIT.
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO?
HOW TO ENFORCE THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE IT NEEDS TO BE?
REQUIRED.
AND WE NEED TO HELP LOCAL
AGENCIES FUND FOR THAT SO THAT'S
MY RECOMMENDATION IS PUT
TOGETHER A THREE YEAR BLOCK
GRANT PROGRAM THE NUMBER OF
HOMES THAT NEED TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED.
IF YOU ROLL IT OVER A THREE YEAR
PERIOD YOU NEED TO HAVE A BOOT
UP BOOTS UP THE DRIVEWAY FOR SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
PARCELS.
A YEAR FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS
TO START TO MAKE SENSE OF THE
RISK ASSESSMENT.
THE RETROFIT AND THE DEFENSIBLE
PEANUT BUTTER THAT ACROSS THE
COUNTIES NOT NECESSARILY
ADJUSTING FOR LEVEL OF PARCELS
BUT THAT'S GOING TO BE TWENTY
PEOPLE WORKING SIX MONTHS A YEAR
FOR THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THAT'S A HEAVY LIFT BUT THAT'S
NOT AN IMPOSSIBLE LEFT WE COULD
DO THAT. TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER HOUSE IS THE IS THE
COST OF THE MOST REQUIRED
RETROFITS.
A ROOF THE VANCE AND THE SOFFIT
TO EVE'S PLUS THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE WILL COST ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM BOTH FEMA AND OUR
CALLOW YES DIRECTOR. EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IS
CURRENTLY IN THE BUCKET TO HELP
WITH THOSE IF YOU HAVE A 25%
COST YEAR WITH THE HOMEOWNERS
25% COST YEAR TO THE STATE AND
50% FROM FEMA.
YOU CAN GET THEIR I WANT TO CALL
YOUR ATTENTION LASTLY TO JUST
OFF THE PRESSES THIS MONTH'S
FIREHOUSE MAGAZINE NATIONAL
MAGAZINE HAS AN ARTICLE ON HOW
TO TRIAGE STRUCTURES.
RELATIVE TO FIRE FIGHTING
TACTICS AND THEY CATEGORIZE THEM
INTO.
NON THREATEN STRUCTURES THOSE
WITH IGNITION RESISTANT
CONSTRUCTION AND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AND A SAFE PLACE FOR
FIREFIGHTERS IN THE EVENT OF A
REFUGE.
THEY HAVE THREATENED BUT
DEFENSIBLE AND THEN NON.
NON DEFENSIBLE STRUCTURES THIS
IS HOW THE FIREFIGHTERS ARE
LOOKING AT OUR PROPERTIES HOUSE
BY HOUSE DURING THE FIREFIGHT
WE NEED TO DO THIS UP EVERY
DRIVEWAY GATHER THE DATA MAKE IT
TECHNOLOGICALLY AVAILABLE TO THE
FIREFIGHTERS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT BACK TO THE
STATES AND BUILD A COMPREHENSIVE
SYSTEM AND AND WITH THAT I THINK
YOU I ALSO WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT
OUT.
SENATOR STERN TREEPEOPLE AS
HAVING A WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
PROGRAM IN YOUR AREA.
AND I JUST LIKE TO COMPLIMENT
THEM FOR THAT VERY GOOD.
I'M GOING TO THAT.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD I'LL SWITCH
IT APPEARS POSE COMING STRAIGHT
TO ME.
AS CHAIR ANY OF THE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MEDIA QUESTIONS.
I'VE GOT A FEW BUT WE'LL SHARE
OKAY WHAT I THINK IT COMES DOWN
TO IS --
MAKING A PRIORITY IN MONEY
[inaudible]
RIGHT -- IN
IF THE STATE WERE TO PUT.
IN FORCE WHAT IS ALREADY
SUPPOSED TO BE ENFORCEABLE
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND PUT DOLLARS TOWARDS IT.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT --
EMPIRE MARSHALL'S JUST TAKING A
LOOK AT THREE YEAR PROGRAM FIVE
YEAR PROGRAM WATER MAY BE --
BOTTOM LINE.
HOW LONG YOU THINK IT'LL TAKE ME?
SIX OR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS IN THREE YEARS.
IT'S PRETTY AGGRESSIVE JUST
BEING HONEST IS THE WAY THINGS
MOVE RIGHT IN THE AT RURAL
COUNTIES IN URBAN COUNTIES IN
JUST WAY DIFFERENT.
PLANS MOVE SO.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IT IS IT
REALISTIC TO HAVE A TIME LINE?
NO THREE YEARS IS NOT A
REALISTIC GOAL LINE.
IT IS A GOOD FIRST WAVE TIME.
IT'S AN ASSESSMENT PERIOD I
THINK IF YOU PUT YOUR BACKS TO
IT IN TEN YEARS TO START TO SEE
A DIFFERENCE.
IN THE FIRE METRICS A LOS
METRICS NO THANK YOU SO WE WHEN
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT DEFENSIBLE
SPACE IN JUST TALK ABOUT.
GERMAN IF YOU DON'T MIND
COMMENTING ON THAT AS WELL.
I WOULD ONLY SAY FROM VENTURES
PERSPECTIVE WE LITERALLY ONLY
ONLY NOTIFY THOSE HOMEOWNERS AT
THE EDGE --
AND WE MET WE MISSED 80% OF THE
HOMEOWNERS I WERE IN THE FIRE
HAZARD ZONE BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T
AT THE EDGE SO WE PRIORITIZE
WITH LIMITED RESOURCES AND
FRANKLY IT LIVE LIMITED FOCUS IN
WOULD THAT BE. FOR EXAMPLE WE
DEBATE ME NOTICES OR YES OKAY SO
WHAT DOES IT WE HAVE FORCED THE
RULES ON PART OF THE PROPERTIES
THAT WERE SUBJECT TO THE RULES --
BECAUSE OF LIMITED RESOURCES AND
THE JUST THE AND IT ACTUALLY
PROBABLY MORE ALSO TO AVOID TO
THE PANIC FROM A LARGER GROUP OF
HOMEOWNERS.
BUT HAD WE REALLY ENFORCE THE
RULES ACROSS EVERYBODY THAT WAS
SUBJECT TO THOSE RULES WE WOULD
HAVE HAD LESS DAMAGE AND ARE FAR
SOUNDS BECAUSE THE FIRE JUMPED
THE EDGES AND WENT INTO THE
MIDDLE.
SO WITH THE GRANTS THAT ARE
BEING THAT ARE BEING MOVED NOW
BY CAL FIRE ---THAT --
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES CAN SECURE --
WORKING WITH NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATIONS FOR EXAMPLE CITIES
COUNTIES FIRE DISTRICTS --
CC SIX ADDRESS.
EATING ADICIONAL PENETRATION
WITH IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS JEEZ
WOULD IT BE HELPFUL IF WE DO A
MORE TARGETED APPROACH.
WITH CAL FIRE NON ON THOSE
GRANTS.
YEAH I THINK THAT I THINK THAT
WOULD HELP A LOT --
WE JUST SO YOU YOU ALL KNOW WE
DID POST A FIRE IN OUR COMMUNITY
THE NEXT YEAR WE DID NOTIFY
EVERYBODY WE SORT OF LEARNED
THAT LESSON --
BUT I'M NOT SO CERTAIN THAT A
CITY LIKE OURS COULD SUSTAIN
THAT ANNUAL NOTIFICATION GOING
FOR WITHOUT SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES KIND THANK YOU.
I THINK FROM RESEARCH STUDIES
THAT.
THE SIGNAL DEFENSIBLE SPACE DOES
ACTUALLY TURNED OUT TO BE
IMPORTANT SO --
SO YES I THINK THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S NO THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT IT'S ENFORCING IT --
EXPAND THE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION --
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT BEYOND ABOUT A HUNDRED
FEET SO THIS IDEA THAT WE'RE
GONNA DO DEFENSIBLE SPACE OUT
INTO THE THE THE HINTERLAND AND
AND DO SOME GOOD ISN'T SUPPORTED
BY.
BY THE WITH FEW STUDIES THERE
ARE -- BUT I
DON'T THINK THAT YOU CAN.
DO THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE PART
WITHOUT THE STRUCTURE HARDENING
PART THEY HAVE TO GO HAND IN
HAND BECAUSE IF YOU DO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE USED.
YOU'VE ACCOMPLISHED SOMETHING IN
YOU SPENT A FAIR AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES TO DO IT BUT YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GET WHAT YOU WHAT
YOU.
NEED TO I'M REALLY GLAD YOU
MENTIONED THAT AND I THINK SHE
CANNOT WAIT ON THIS IN THE NORTH
A FIRE STORM.
IMMERSE REFINED ABOUT TWO MILES
AHEAD OF THE FRONT LINES OF THE
FIRE.
AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THAT WHOLE KMART SHOPPING CENTER
THIRTEEN HUNDRED HOMES A COPY
PARK AT THE PARK.
IS ALMOST THREE MILES AWAY FROM
ANY TYPE OF GROWTH --
WITHIN A WEEK AIDS IN THE MIDDLE
FLIPPING TOWN --
AND THAT'S THE OTHER ISSUE THAT
WE ARE SEEN --
IN WILL ASK THE CHIEF --
TO AS WELL.
THE AMBER FLOW THAT WERE SEEN
FROM THESE FIRES --
IS IT'S ASTRONOMICAL AS FAR AS
WHAT HOW FAST THIS IS MOVING IN
HOW FAR THESE NUMBERS ARE NOW
FLYING --
AND PLANNING ON ROOFS MANY
VEGETATION.
SO I AYE GREETING REQUIRES A
HARDENING YEAH AND THAT'S WHY
YOU DON'T SEE A BIG A BIG SIGNAL
VEGETATION BEYOND A CERTAIN
AMOUNT BECAUSE EMBERS CAN BE
COMING FROM FAR FAR AWAY.
AND MOST HOMES ACTUALLY DO BURN
FROM FROM MEMBERS RIGHT AND
EITHER FROM AWHILE THEN FIRE OR
FROM A NEIGHBORING HOME.
THAT'S BURNING SO HARDENING
HARDEN THE STRUCTURES.
BUT GO BACK TO TO WHAT I WAS
FINDING FROM --
FROM LAND USE PLANNERS ACTUALLY
LAYING THE COMMUNITY OUT
DIFFERENTLY.
HAS A BIG IMPACT AND WE'RE NOT
WE'RE GENERALLY NOT EVEN
DISCUSSING THAT AND I THINK
THAT'S A AN IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT THAT'S
FALLING SHORT OF SAYING YOU
CAN'T BUILD THERE THAT'S SAYING
OKAY IF YOU'RE GONNA BUILD THERE
LET'S DO IT DIFFERENTLY THAT'S
DO IT SMARTER SO THAT'S ACTUALLY --
FALLING SHORT OF OF THAT
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
KERN WHAT SORRY LOSS --
SENATOR BILL SORRY YOUR NEXT
[inaudible]
OF ABOUT FOUR WEEKS AGO I HAD A
MEETING IN LOS GATOS SAW ON
EMERGENCY SERVICES --
WITH --
PEOPLE FROM CUPERTINO LOS GATOS
SIR TO THE SAN JOSE WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE THE SANTA CRUZ
MOUNTAINS.
IN THE FOOTHILLS ABOVE THOSE
TOWNS AND THEIR ENOUGH FIRE
SEVERE THING --
THAT'S EXISTING --
FROM THE CAL FIRE THERE IN THE
WHAT THEY CALL THE RED ZONE.
THOSE AREAS BECAUSE THERE'S A
LARGE AMOUNT OF HOUSING THAT WAS
BUILT TO A HUNDRED YEARS AGO
FIFTY YEARS AGO ALL UP IN THE
MOUNTAINS UP THERE.
AND THERE'S ALSO BEEN SEVERAL
FIRES AND GONE THROUGH THEIR AND
THEIR THE REGROWTH --
IS QUITE THICK.
UP THERE SO IT'S WE ALSO HAVE A
THING CALLED THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT THERE ARE.
SO WE HAVE LIKE A COMBINATION OF
THINGS GOING ON SO WE HAD THIS
COMMUNITY ME WE HAVE LIKE OVER
THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE SHOW UP.
AND THE THE THE THE KINDA ISSUES
WERE WHAT CAN WE DO TO BEEF UP
[inaudible]
THE INSPECTIONS [inaudible]
OF HOMES ROSE --
THE PUBLIC LANDS OWNED BY THE
PARKS DISTRICTS.
ALL THESE KINDS OF THINGS --
AN AREA THAT'S ALREADY.
HAD.
A LOT OF HOUSING BUILT IN IT BUT
IT'S IN A REALLY A HI
PROBABILITY OF FIRE AREA.
SO HOW DO YOU DO WITH THE THOSE
KINDS OF AREAS --
THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS OF A
PLANNING PROCESS --
SHOULD WE PUT THE STRICTER OF
LAND USE REQUIREMENTS.
ON THOSE AREAS OF CCAR'S --
SHOULD WE HAVE.
OUR HOME INSPECTIONS OF HOME
INSPECTIONS WHEN THE HOUSE IS
SOLD.
WHAT KIND OF THINGS CAN WE DO
THE?
B..
FIVE FOUR THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
IN --
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES IN THOSE
AREAS THOSE KINDS OF AREAS.
YOU KNOW THE SOUND OF YOUR FROM
AREA TO AREA TALKING BUT I GREW
UP IN HALF MOON BAY AND MY FIRST
FIRE STATION ASSIGNMENT WAS FELT
IN SO I AM.
AND SO THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES
YES YES AND YES ALL OF THE ABOVE --
ARE ARE YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
TRYING TO CREATE A REQUIREMENT
THAT YOU WANT TO LOOK FOR ALL OF
THE POINTS OF CONTACT WITH THAT
PROPERTY.
YOU KNOW THAT MAKES SENSE SO YOU
KNOW IF I WERE YOU KNOW WAVING A
WAND.
AND I WERE CALIFORNIA AND TRYING
TO DO THIS AS QUICKLY AS I. POP
POSSIBLY COULD.
THEN -- I
WOULD PUT CONDITION SAY ALL
SUBSEQUENT DECISIONS ABOUT THIS
PROPERTY --
IT NEED TO COMPLY WITH THE WITH
THE CONDITIONS ATTACHED TO THE
ZONING OVERLAY --
AND SO I WOULDUSE THAT AS AN
EMBEDDING PROCESS AND THEN I
WOULD --
TAKE A LOOK AT THE POINTS OF
SALE.
BECAUSE THAT IS ANOTHER POINT
WHERE THE PROPERTY GOES THROUGH
A PROCESS I KNOW IT'S UNPOPULAR
IT'S ALWAYS BEEN CONTROVERSIAL
BUT IT IS EFFECTIVE --
AND THEN I WOULD --
I WOULD BE THOUGHT MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE THERE ARE.
A THERE ARE.
LITERALLY THOSE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND GOING UP THOSE DRIVEWAYS
TAKING A LOOK AT THOSE
PROPERTIES AND THERE IS --
SOME LEVERAGING OF COMMON
PURPOSE INCOME AND EXPENSE OF IT
COULD BE HAD IN PARTNERING WITH
THE INSURANCE PROCESS AS WELL.
AND AND THEN TO YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT.
THE NEED FOR INSPECTIONS I THINK
THERE IS GOING TO END UP BEING A
KIND OF A TWO TIERED APPROACH
THERE IS AN ASSESSMENT PROCESS
THAT CAN BE DONE BY RELATIVELY.
A LESS EDUCATED AND MORE
COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS OF THAT
ARE LIKE THE LOCAL FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS FIRE WAYS COMMUNITIES
THAT TALK WITH HOMEOWNERS AND
THOSE ARE PEOPLE THAT USE THE
COMMUNITY BASED PROCESS.
JUST TELL TOPIC TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY AND THEN THERE'S IN
ENFORCING PROCESS WITH SOMEONE
WHO COMES UP THE DRIVEWAY AND
RIGHT TO TICKET.
IF YOU HAVEN'T COMPLIED WE COULD
SEPARATE THOSE IN IN IN IN AN
ENABLE THE ASSESSMENT PROCESS
WITH COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS
WHILE THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW SENDING SOME MONEY
ASIDE FOR THE ENFORCEMENT
PROCESS IT BECOMES THE MANDATE
THE STATE --
I KIND OF ROOM THAT'S KIND OF
WHAT WE WERE TALKING ABOUT --
SHOULD THE STATE GET INVOLVED IN
SUPPORTING THESE --
PUBLIC INFORMATION ACTIVITIES
MORE FUNDING AND SO FORTH THAT
THE FIRE SAFE COUNCILS.
GO OUT AND DO THESE --
INFORMATIONAL.
INFORMATIONAL THINGS FOR
HOMEOWNERS OR RESIDENTS THAT
LIVE IN THESE AREAS.
YEAH YES.
AND BECAUSE IT'S THOSE COMMUNITY
BASED GROUPS THAT HAVE THE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE THAT ARE GOING
TO HELP ENABLE THIS IN THE MOST
SOCIALLY.
JUST LESS DISRUPTIVE WAY
POSSIBLE AND USING COMMUNITY
BASED GROUPS.
ARE TO CARRY THE MESSAGE OUT
THERE -- BUT
THROUGH AN ENABLED PROCESS YOU
KNOW MAKING THOSE AVAILABLE
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR THOSE GROUPS --
WILL HELP RATHER THAN JUST THE
APPROACH OF THE ENFORCING AS THE
FIRST CONTACT AND AND THAT WILL
BE IMPORTANT --
SINCE IT IS TO BE MANNER.
LONG TIME AGO.
WHILE AGO.
I ACTUALLY --
WAS A PLANNER FOR LOS GATOS.
AND WE DID THE PUBLIC SAFETY
PLAN.
BUT I WAS INVOLVED IN WRITING
THAT -- THE
PUBLIC SAFETY PLANS --
WE DID -- OF
BEFORE COMPUTERS SUPPORTERS
CAUSES NAILS STONE AGE WHEN I
WAS THERE BUT WE DID WHAT WE
CALL -- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER THIS --
OVERLY RISK ASSESSMENTS.
WITH WE CALLED IT MY CAR AGAIN
RISK ASSESSMENTS O A FEW MEMBER
THAT.
YOU DO OKAY SO SO WE DID --
THOSE KINDS OF ANALYSIS AND WE
THE WORSE.
THE MORE TARGETED AREAS.
AND THAT THOSE ARE THE AREAS
THAT WE FOCUS ON FIRST.
AS THE HIGHEST RHYS AREAS IS
THAT A GOOD APPROACH --
TO START WORKING ON THIS PROBLEM
BY FOCUSSING ON THE HARD THE THE
ONES THAT HAVE SO MUCH OVERLY
RISK.
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
MORE IN AN IMMEDIATE WAY.
I WOULD SAY YES IT'S REALLY
ABOUT TRIAGE RIGHT YOU KNOW WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN I DO THESE RISKS OVERLAYS
HAVE YOU OVERLAY MULTIPLE RECESS
WHERE THE PROPHET HAD THE MOST
POTENTIAL RISK ACROSS DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES PRIORITIZE THEM FIRST
BECAUSE YOU GET THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR THE BUCK IF THE BIGGEST BANG
FOR YOUR BUCK?
AND THERE WE AND THEN WE AT THE
COMMUNITY MEETING WE TALKED
ABOUT --
PEOPLE ARE AFRAID OF INSPECTIONS
AND REQUIREMENTS AND SO WE
TALKED ABOUT --
LIKE I USED TO DO WHAT WE CALL
SOFT INSPECTIONS.
THEN A THAT WAS INSPECTION YOU
GO AND YOU COULD JEWEL THE
HOMEOWNER TO DO THINGS --
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WAS GOOD AT
THAT.
SO I WOULD I WOULD HAVE LIKED A
LITTLE DISCUSSIONS WITH PEOPLE
AND SAY WELL YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
TO DO.
THESE KINDS OF THINGS AND THEN
LATER.
WE WOULD SAY OKAY WE'RE GOING TO
SCHEDULE LATER A IN IT --
HARDER INSPECTION THAT WE'RE
GONNA MAKE THE REQUIREMENTS.
IS THAT A GOOD APPROACH SO WE DO
THE COMMUNITY INFORMATION.
AND THEN WE DO THE SOFT
INSPECTION AND THEN WE DO THE
HARD INSPECTION.
THAT PROCESS IT'S A THREE STEP
YEAH THAT'S EXACTLY THE I THINK
THE BEST WAY TO GET THE
COMMUNITY TO TO REMOVE CHANGE
BEHAVIOR.
I THINK I WOULD ADD ALSO THAT IF
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE AN INSPECTION
THE PERSON YOU'RE MOST LIKELY TO
WANT TO SEE IF YOUR HOUSE IS A
FIREMAN.
YEAH RIGHT THERE WELL LIKED --
FOR THE ADD TO THIS A LITTLE
SENSE OF URGENCY RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE OF THAT WHAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED LAST COUPLE YEARS I
THINK THERE'S A MORE COMMON
SENSE OF URGENCY THAT WE SHOULD
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT SO THOSE
HOMEOWNERS THAT.
SURVIVED THE FIRE MIGHT BE MORE
PRONE TO MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THEIR HOME TO HARDEN HOME
TODAY AS A NO WITH THE
ALTERNATIVE IS IF THEY DON'T DO
THAT.
I THINK IT'S GOOD FOR THE
PLANNERS TO LEARN HELPING SKILLS
TO JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW AND ON
THE ON RATHER JUST BEING
REGULATORS YEAH.
IT'S IMPORTANT AS
PSYCHOLOGICALLY FOR THE PLANNERS
TO THAT HELPING.
THE POINT BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN
THE OTHER THE OTHER --
THE LAST ISSUE I WANNA RAISES.
SIR OF FUNDING AND WHAT WOULD BE
THE PRIORITY OF FUNDING AT THIS
POINT IN TERMS OF THESE KINDS OF
THINGS WOULD YOU SAY.
YOU MENTION --
ONE ASPECT YOU HAVE EITHER THE
ELEMENTS THAT YOU WOULD YOU HAVE
TO DO RIGHT AWAY KIND OF KIND OF
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO.
THE DANGER DID THE DANGER AND
ASKING THE QUESTION OF WHAT IS
THE PRIORITY BEGS THE HOLISTIC
APPROACH THAT NEEDS TO OCCUR
RIGHT OKAY SO --
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS.
DEVELOPING THE BODY OF KNOWLEDGE.
IT'S RELATIVELY LOW COST TO PUT
THE LAND USE PLANNING
REQUIREMENTS IN STATURE
STATUTORY LAW AND CODIFY THEM
THAT'S A LOW COST SO THAT COULD
BE DONE LITERALLY THIS SESSION.
AND THEN APPROACHING THE ONCE
AGAIN KIND OF EDUCATING THAT
THOSE PROFESSIONALS OUT THERE SO
THEY KNOW HOW TO QUICKLY APPLY
THOSE LAWS.
AND THEN I WOULD SAY GOING BACK
TO THIS RETROFIT THE HARDENED
COMMUNITY OR RESILIENT COMMUNITY
IS BUILT ON THIS --
THIS REQUIREMENT THIS NEED THAT
WE HAVE FOR THE RETROFIT OF BOTH
THE BUILDING AND THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE AND THAT.
WHICH IS NOT GONNA MAKE MUCH
PROGRESS ON THE FIRE LOSSES INTO
WE GO THROUGH.
THE ENFORCEMENT AND THE ENABLING
A BOTH RETROFITTING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE TO JUST HAVE A WARNING
THESE --
NICE WAYS OF DOING THINGS WHAT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I THINK ONE OF
THINGS WE DISCOVERED IN WHEN I
WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
AND AN AFTERMATH REPORTS ON BIG
FIRES AND IN THE MOUNTAINS IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY WE FOUND THAT --
OVER 50% OF THE DWELLINGS BURN
HAD NO BUILDING PERMITS
WHATSOEVER.
OKAY SO YOU HAVE A LOT OF
STRUCTURES THAT ARE.
NOT PERMITTED AND THAT GOES FOR
WIRE RINGING --
THE STRUCTURAL PERMITS OR ANY
KIND OF PERMITS SAID NO PERMITS
WHATSOEVER.
AND THAT IS A PERVASIVE PROBLEM
ALSO.
THAT REQUIRES MAYBE A LITTLE
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAN THE KIND
OF THE PLANNING --
PROCESS.
SOFT --
SHARKS INSPECTION HARD
INSPECTION IF WE COULD GO IN AND
IN MAY BE.
SCREEN AND REMOVE SOMEHOW
[inaudible]
ILLEGAL STRUCTURES AND WIRING.
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD BE A QUICK
FIX DO YOU DO YOU AGREE WITH THE
WHAT I'M SAYING.
I'M NOT SURE I WOULD.
CALL IT A QUICK FIX JUST BECAUSE
THAT WOULD REDUCE RISKS AS WHAT
I'M SAYING.
BUT OVERALL THE THEN CARE THE
ILLEGAL STUFF THE AMOUNT OF
RESISTANCE TO THAT SORT OF QUICK
FIX WOULD MAKE THE QUICK FIX NOT
SO QUICK I THINK.
MY SENSE IS THE MORE THAT WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY MAKE THIS AN URGENT
MATTER AND AND ACTUALLY PROVIDE
THAT WHAT IS NECESSARY FOR
REGULATIONS AND INCENTIVES FOR
HARDENING HOMES AND DEALING WITH.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE TO PROTECT THE
HOME NOT BEEN BURNED BY THE FIRE
THAT'S THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE
BUCK GONE FOR THE NIGHT MY
APPROACH WOULD BE LIKE IF YOU
GOT A REALLY.
SEVERE WRIST AREA.
AND YOU HAVE SOME.
BUILDINGS THAT HAD ILLEGAL
WIRING AND ALL KINDS OF
HAZARDOUS KIND OF BASICALLY
HAZARDOUS [inaudible]
SITUATIONS.
YOU CAN'T JUST.
WAIT FOR THAT TO GET BETTER YOU
HAVE.
TO RIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO GO ON DEALWITH A I
MEAN OTHERWISE YOU'RE JUST
WAITING FOR AN EXPLOSION TO
OCCUR BASICALLY.
I WOULD LIKE TO GO BACK AND
ADDRESS SENATOR MAGUIRE'S
OPENING COMMENTS TOM.
WELL I'M HERE ADVOCATING --
FOR FOR THESE THINGS --
AS A GROUP WE ARE I DO WANT TO
GO BACK TO YOUR STATEMENT ABOUT.
THE RESPOND ORDERS YOU KNOW THE
FIREFIGHTING FORCES CRITICAL
THESE PROVISIONS ARE NOT GOING.
TO REDUCE THE FIRE IN THE FIRE
OCCURRENCE ON OUR COMMUNITY ALL
OF THIS IS DESIGNED THE BUILDING
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
BUILDING STANDARDS A DEFENSIBLE
SPACE.
ARE DESIGNED SO THAT WE REDUCING
THE NUMBER OF HOUSES THAT ARE
STARTING TO IGNITE AND
OVERWHELMING THE FIREFIGHTING
RESOURCES SO WHAT WE WANT TO DO
IS.
IS GET THE FIRE IGNITIONS OF THE
STRUCTURES DOWN TO A POINT WHERE
THE FIREFIGHTERS CAN THEN HANDLE
THOSE.
AND IT IS THE COMBINATION
REPARATION IN THE MILITARY TRIMS
ITS CALLED SHAPING THE
BATTLEFIELD YOU GET THE THE
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND
SUFFICIENT SO THAT THE RESPONSE
FORCE.
CAN EFFECTIVELY DEAL WITH IT --
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MITIGATE OUR%
WAY OUT OF THE RESPONSE
REQUIREMENT BUT WE CAN MAKE IT
EASIER FOR THEM TO SUCCEED.
THANK YOU --
BEFORE I MOVE ON JUST.
MAYBE SOMEONE YOU ALL COULD GET
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ON NOT
NECESSARILY YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY
BUT WANTED FEEDBACK ON THE
COMMUNITY WILD FIRE PREVENTION
AND MITIGATION REPORT THAT CAL
FIRE JUST RELEASED.
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND.
PRIORIDAD SORT OF THIRTY FIVE
HIGH PRIORITY FUEL MITIGATION
PROJECTS THEY'VE IDENTIFIED JUST
TO GET SOME FEEDBACK ON THE
METHODOLOGY USED --
IT IT MOSTLY TARGET SAY
RESPONSIBILITY AREAS --
AS WELL AS WITHIN SOME OF THE
CONTRACT COUNTIES BUT THE VALUE --
WHAT THE BASIC A BIG TREES
ANSWER THIS WILD LAND ISSUE IT'S
IT'S HEAVILY WEIGHTED THERE JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY IN PLACE
AND SHOVEL READY BUT I SORT OF
WANT TO GET A SENSE FROM YOU ALL
JUST -- THE
BALANCE ON THIS SORT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY VERSES BROADER --
JUST TO MITIGATE FUEL LOAD WRIT
LARGE.
AND QUESTION AND THEN THE OTHER
FEEDBACK WE LOVE FROM YOU ALL IS
ON THE THIRTY MILLION I BELIEVE
IS A THIRTY MILLION DOLLAR
APPROPRIATIONS STAGES --
AUTHORIZED --
ON THIS SORT OF LOCAL OUTREACH
COMPONENT YOUR TO THAT YOU ALL
OF ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT --
AND BEST PRACTICES THERE --
WE WE HEARD IT FROM --
CALLOW YESTERDAY ABOUT A BIG
NEED FOR BIG PUBLIC OUTREACH
CAMPAIGN --
BEST PRACTICES WHO WHO'S DONE IT
WELL WHAT P. OURS WORKED HOW
MUCH OF IT IS JUST DIGITAL BUZZ
IS IT ABOUT YOU KNOW.
SOME CELEBRITY PUTTING SOMETHING
ON THERE INSTEAD THE COUNCIL'S
ACTUALLY GOOUT AND KNOCK ON
DOORS IT MAY ACTUALLY BE A
STRANGE MIX OF A LOT OF
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES OUT THERE
TO GET THIS ON THE FRONT OF
PEOPLE'S MINDS SAID THAT.
THERE'S A CULTURAL MOVED TO GO
THERE SO WE DO WE LOVE SOME
INPUT THERE AS WELL --
AS PROBABLY MORE FUNDING IS
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD SO --
AND THEN THE FINAL PIECE JUST
FOR POTENTIAL FOLLOW UP HERE IS --
ON THE DATA SAID THAT THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY HAS --
ON OUR HOMES SEEMS TO BE THE
MOST GRANULAR DETAIL DATA SAID.
THAT IS PRIVATELY HELD --
THE STATE DOES NOT HAVE THAT.
HOW WHAT IS THAT INTERFACE LOOK
LIKE YOU SAID DR MORE ENGAGING
WITH THE --
WHY -- WOULD
LOVE SOME FEEDBACK THERE ABOUT
WHAT'S A COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
KIND OF SHORT CUT TO THAT DATA
IT MAY BE THROUGH COLLECTION
DOOR TO DOOR.
BUT IF IT IF THIS DATA SAID
ALREADY EXISTS --
I MEAN WE COULD BUY.
RIGHT SO --
AND SORRY I SAID THAT WAS THE
LAST ONE BUT EXAMPLES OF
STRONGER JUST BEST PRACTICES
ALLEN ON PLANNING LIKE WE WERE
WHO'S DOING THIS WELL --
IT WOULD REALLY HELP US YOU KNOW
WE SHOULD IT WOULD FROM A SHOULD
HAVE A PR HERE TODAY AND WILL BE
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT BUT REALLY
HOW TO START TO INTEGRATE SOME
OF THE BEST LAND USE PLANNING
OUT THERE INTO THE OPR GUIDELINE
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS BE VERY
HELPFUL.
SO -- YES SO
SORRY WE KEEP WE'VE WE'VE HEARD
AUSTRALIA ON A NUMBER OF
OCCASIONS IS REALLY THE ONLY
ANALOGY THAT WORKS OUT IN THE
WORLD FOR FOR IT YOU KNOW NATION
THAT'S HAD THAT KIND A SEVERITY.
OF RISK --
SO MAYBE WE CAN DRILL DOWN A BIT
MORE THERE AND I KNOW TREAT
PEOPLE IN AUSTRALIA BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY TOGETHER BY THE WAY
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT PLUG.
ANYHOW THIRTY QUESTIONS WITHOUT
ANSWERS BUT IF YOU'RE UP FOR IT --
SOME WRITTEN FEEDBACK THAT BE
AWESOME LET'S KEEP THIS ROLE AND
I KNOW WE'VE GOT A BIG FINAL
PANEL WITH A LOT OF HEAVY
HITTERS HERE --
SO --
INCLUDING THE ANOTHER --
I STEAM THE RETIREE WHO WE HAVE
NOT LET OUT OF SERVICE YET THANK
YOU AGAIN CHIEF JARGON --
BUT CHIEF PIMLOTT --
WELCOME BACK --
SO WE HAVE DIRECTOR PAM ON HERE --
WITH CAL FIRE.
AS WELL AS SCOTT LAUDER --
FORMER MAYOR FROM THE TOWN OF
PARADISE --
TIM SNELLING IS DIRECTOR OF
BUTTE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES --
CHIEF MIKE MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN
FROM THE CONSUMERS COMMUNITY
SERVICE DISTRICT FIRE DEPARTMENT.
AS WELL AS T<c.cyan> BAILEY FROM</c>
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THE SACRAMENTO AREA
FOR LOCAL FIVE TWENTY TO THE
FIRE CAPTAIN --
AN ALTERNATE OVER TO MY CHAIR
THAT VILLAGER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR FUTURE
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO EACH OF OUR
PANELISTS INTO OUR PREVIOUS
PANEL REALLY WONDERFUL FEEDBACK
IN THE FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU
HERE IN THE WEEKS AND MONTHS TO
COME.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM --
THE STATE FARMER FEMA AND STATE --
YES ON WHAT WE NEED TO BE TO DO
BETTER WHEN IT COMES TO RECOVERY
RESPONSE AND REBUILD WE JUST
HEARD FROM --
PLANNING TEAM AND NOW WHAT WE
CAN DO TO REGULATE DEVELOPMENT
DO MORE TO REGULATE DEVELOPMENT
IN FIRE PRONE AREAS WE WANT TAKE
MOMENT. TO TALK ABOUT OUR LEAD
OFF AND THAT IS AT CHIEF HIM
WHAT --
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR HIS SERVICE
AT TO THE STATE OVER THIRTY
YEARS -- AND
HE HAS MANY MANY MORE DECADES TO
BE ABLE TO GIVE BACK AND WE ARE
SO GRATEFUL THAT HE IS DECIDED
TO BE ABLE.
TO GET BACK HERE TODAY HE'S
REALLY THRILLED ABOUT THAT BY
THE WAY --
AND HE'S ABOUT TO START BUILDING
A HOUSE WHICH IS PRETTY EXCITING --
BUT CHIEF --
AND ON BEHALF OF THE COMMITTEES
WE JUST WANTED MOMENT SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MASON SERVICE THIS
STATE -- YOU
ARE THINK THE ONLY ONE IN THIS
NATION THAT HAS SEEN THE
CONDITIONS THAT YOU HAVE IN YOUR
CAREER CHANGE.
AS SEVERE AS A I AND THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THAT HAS BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES LIKE YOU.
AND WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU
CHOSE TO PICK CALIFORNIA.
AS TO YOUR CAREER A GREAT THE
CITY STATE ON REGULATION AND
DEVELOPMENT IN FIRE PRONE AREAS.
MISTER CHIEF THE FOUR DOORS
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AREA REGULAR RATE WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON --
CHAIRS MCGUIRE AND STERN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
BY SYNDICATED CAN TIM WATER
RETIRED --
DIRECTOR OF CAL FIRE.
AND YES I HAVE BEEN A LIFELONG
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA AND
OBVIOUSLY HAVE.
IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS SEEN --
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THE
LANDSCAPE BOTH IN WHERE PEOPLE
LIVE AND HOW MANY PEOPLE ALMOST
FORTY MILLION NOW --
AS WELL AS THE CONDITIONS THAT
WERE FACING --
EVERY DAY.
BOTTOM LINE IS --
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE TODAY --
HAS REALLY BEEN SPOT ON I CAN'T.
WITH BABY LITTLE EXCEPTION TAKE --
ISSUE WITH ALL OF THE SUBJECT
MATTER THE RECOMMENDATIONS THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
THAT -- WERE
CHALLENGED WITH EVERY DAY IN THE
STATE.
ON THE CIRCLE BACK SINCE WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT WHAT WE'VE BEEN
FACING AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
HEARING --
AND THEN DOVE DEEP INTO SOME OF
THE CONCERNS AND MEDICATIONS BUT
RE CERTAINLY BACK TO NOT
FORGETTING.
THAT JUST WITHIN THE LAST YEAR
WE HAVE SEEN THE MOST DEADLY.
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND THE
LARGEST FIRE IN THE STATE'S
HISTORY.
JUST IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN IF YOU LOOK AT FIVE IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS OR SKIN
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS.
WE'VE HAD THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE.
OUR AND AT THE DEADLIEST FIRES
ARE AND IN.
THE LAST TOP TEN OF THE OF THE
TWENTY HAVE OCCURRED JUST IN THE
LAST DECADE SO EVERYTHING IS
TRENDING TOWARDS A MORE COMPLEX
MORE CHALLENGING.
SITUATION AND CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG KNOWN FIRE CHALLENGES IN
THE WILDLAND FIRE MARM YOU GO
BACK TO THE NINETEEN SIXTIES
BELLAIRE FIRE IN.
LOS ANGELES CITY YOU CAN GO TO
THE COUNTY IN. NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOR A TEN DAY CATASTROPHIC EVENT
IN THE STATE IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FROM THE OAKLAND HILLS ALRIGHT
HUMBOLDT COUNTY OAKLAND HILLS
ALL WE SOUTH INTO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND THREE AND
AGAIN IN. TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
FIVE AND OF COURSE THE LAST FIVE
YEARS WHERE WE HAVE BEEN USING
OF SUFFERING FROM THE IMPACTS OF
CATASTROPHIC DROUGHT AND QUITE
FRANKLY YES THE IMPACTS OF OF A
CHANGING CLIMATE WHERE WE'RE
SEEING OVERALL I MEAN%
TEMPERATURE INCREASE ACROSS THE
STATE -- AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT CHANGES IN
WEATHER PATTERNS WERE LOOKING AT
CHANGES IN WHERE VEGETATION
GROWS WRIST LITERALLY AND REALLY
AN OVER SIMPLIFIED APPROACH WERE
SEEING THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FIRE ENVIRONMENT MOVE NORTH.
IN LATITUDE IN RACING VEGETATION
MOVE UP.
IN ELEVATION --
IN TERMS OF VEGETATION THAT'S
VERY CONDUCIVE. TO THIS --
FIRES CYCLE IT'S MORE FREQUENT
AND MORE DEVASTATING.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY SEEING IN
THESE FIRES JUST WE'VE HAD
DEVASTATING FIRES WE'VE HAD SEEN
AND WIND DRIVEN WE'VE HAD?
THE THE OAKLAND HILLS FIRE --
IN THE EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES --
BUT THE WHAT'S DIFFERENT --
BURNING WITH JUST INTENSE RATES
OF SPREAD YOU KNOW FIFTEEN MILES
IN ONE AFTERNOON FOR ALSO
LASTING LONGER THEIR BIKES
POSING FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
PUBLIC AND COMMUNITIES TO RISK.
FOR IN THE CASE OF THIS LAST
SUMMER SIX WEEKS OR MORE WE
FIGURED THE BETWEEN THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX.
AND THE CAR FIRE BOTH OF THOSE
FIRES WERE VERY LONG DURATION
THE THOMAS FIRE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
LONGEST RECORDED RED FLAG
WARNING.
THAT I'M AWARE OF THIRTEEN DAYS
STRAIGHT OF EXTREMELY LOW
HUMIDITY THESE WIND ARE PRODUCED
JUST CONDITIONS THAT WERE
OBVIOUSLY RIGHT. FOR MULTIPLE
FIRES AND CATASTROPHIC FIRE.
SO THE CHALLENGE GOING FORWARD
AND I CERTAINLY YOU KNOW HAVING
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WORKING IN
THE STATE AND BEING PART OF IT
BUT ALSO WATCHING WHERE THINGS
ARE GOING --
AS THE STATE IS RELEASED ITS
FORTY FIVE DAY REPORT OBVIOUSLY
VERY AGGRESSIVE LOOK.
AT THAT SOME VERY TARGETED
THINGS BUT IT'S THE CAN TO THE
INVESTMENT THE STATE CONTINUES
TO MAKE.
OUR IN THESE KEY AREAS NOW ARE
AT IS DOCTOR MORRIS SAID THERE
YOU YOU HAVE THE FORCED.
WOW MAN ENVIRONMENT AND YOU HAVE
THIS URBAN FACED ENVIRONMENT
WHILE THEY ARE CAN BE DISTINCTLY
SEPARATE I WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY
WERE OUR BIGGEST CHALLENGES ARE
OFTEN WHERE THEIR OVERLAPPING
BECAUSE IT ISN'T JUST.
A COMMUNITY OR SUBDIVISION
PLOPPED --
IT IN AN URBAN AREA NEXT TO THE
WHILE AND WE HAVE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT.
THE SIERRA FOOTHILLS OF THAT OUR
INNER MIX TO THE SO COORDINATING
THESE ACTIVITIES AND REDUCING
FUEL LOADINGS USING PRESCRIBED
FIRE LOSING ALL THESE TOOLS.
CAN HAVE AN IMPACT ON HELPING
PROTECT COMMUNITIES OR
STRUCTURES THAT MAY BE WITHIN.
THE AREA BEING TREATED
ABSOLUTELY THE WIND DRIVEN FIRES
THAT WE'RE SEEING --
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT EIGHTY
MILE AN HOUR WINDS?
BLOWING THROUGH CANYONS VERY
LITTLE CAN BE DONE TO REDUCE
THAT KIND OF INTENSITY WHEN
THOSE THINGS ARE OCCURRING AND
THAT'S WHY.
EVERYTHING WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
TODAY.
IT'S SORT OF A WHOLE OF
COMMUNITY AS YOU HEAR PEOPLE
TALK ABOUT IT'S THAT IN.
HOLISTIC APPROACH IT'S ALL OF
THE ABOVE WE NEED TO BE LOOKING
AT OBVIOUSLY TREATING VEGETATION
IN STRATEGIC PLACES AROUND OUR
COMMUNITIES.
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ALL OF THAT
HARDENING THE COMMUNITIES IN AND
I KNOW THE QUESTIONS GOING TO
COME LATER ALL DON'T THROW A
LITTLE BIT OF IT OUT NOW AND WE
CAN TALK MORE.
BUT THE IT ALWAYS COMES DOWN TO
SHOULD WE BE MANDATING OR SHOULD
WE BE.
ENCOURAGING THROUGH --
INCENTIVES AND I I THINK WHAT
WE'LL TALK ABOUT IS THAT IT'S
REALLY A COMBINATION OF BOTH AND
I THINK WHAT WHAT WE'RE FINDING
IS.
IS THAT.
AS OF FIRE MARSHAL MIKE RICH
WINE TALKED ABOUT THE VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY SOON.
IDENTIFIED ACROSS THE STATE CAME
OUT OF THE FIRES --
YEAR THE OAKLAND HILLS FIRE IN
THE EARLY NINETIES BECAUSE WHAT
WE SAW WAS WHILE NGUYEN
VEGETATION IN AN URBAN AREA.
ORNAMENTAL VEGETATION AND
REMEMBER SOT TO PARTNER FOR YOU
SAW THINGS THAT WERE DRIVING
FIRE CONDITIONS.
OUR GREAT LARGE APPROACH TO
LOOKING IN IDENTIFYING FIRE
HAZARD BUT WHAT CAN I THINK
CHIEF JARGON REALLY HIT IT IT'S
WE NEED TO HAVE THIS DOWN TO THE
PARCEL LEVEL WE NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO LOOK AT AN INDIVIDUAL HOUSE
AN INDIVIDUAL DEVELOPMENT AND
INITIAL STRUCTURE AND SAY.
CAN I MITIGATE THE RISK OF FIRE
LIFE LOSS OF LIFE ON THAT PIECE
OF PROPERTY.
BASED ON WHERE I WANT TO PUT
THAT STRUCTURE LOCATED NEXT TO A
CANYON THAT THE VEGETATION THE
PREVAILING WIND PATTERNS ALL OF
THOSE THINGS INGRESS EGRESS ALL
THE THINGS YOU FOR TODAY.
ALL THOSE EVALUATIONS NEED TO
OCCUR AND IF WE CAN'T GET TO
THAT PLACE THE NOSE OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT
ARE HARD ABOUT NOT MAYBE.
PUTTING A HOME THERE WHAT.
I DON'T WANT TO BE.
BUT LITERALLY WATER CORRECT IS
THE ASSOCIATED PRESS ARTICLE
THAT QUOTED.
ME OUT OF CONTEXT SAYING THAT
THE CHIEF WANTS TO BAN BUILDING
IN THE WILD MANNER INTERFACE.
SENATE MCGUIRE SAID I'M BUILDING
A HOUSE IN THE URBAN INTERFACE I
KNOW TRUE WELL.
THE IMPACTS ON THE CHALLENGES
BUT WE HAVE TO DO IS UNDERSTAND
THE RISKS.
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS AND THAT'S
GONNA BE A COMBINATION OF A
CARROT.
AND A STICK AND I THINK THAT'S
REALLY THE END OF THE DAY WHERE
WE NEED TO GET --
TO IS CONTINUING TO HAVE THAT
DIALOGUE AS TO HOW WE IMPLEMENT
ALL OF THAT. TO GET TO THAT IN
STATE AND IT'S THE LEGACY
CONSTRUCTION THE THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT THAT WAS THERE PRIOR.
TO THE STATE'S VERY AGGRESSIVE
URBAN INTERFACE BUILDING CODES
THAT HAS ONLY BEEN IN PLACE FOR
DECADES IT'S THIS ORDER
CONSTRUCTION THAT IS YOU'VE ALL
TALKED ABOUT.
THIS MORNING IS CONTINUING TO BE
OUR CHALLENGE IN ONE MINUTE THAT.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND SEE TO THE REST OF MY TIME I
KNOW WE'VE GOT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
QUESTIONS AND WOULD LIKE TO
ADMIT PANELS TO THANK YOU.
I SHOP TO THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY
FOR YOU HERE WILL BECOME BACK
QUESTIONS WERE IN TURN OVER TO
MR LOTTERIES THE FORMER MAYOR
TOWN OF PARADISE THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE MISS MAYOR.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU WE'RE GOING
TO THE FLOOR FOR OKAY --
GIVE MY NAME SCOTT WATER --
I WAS --
COUNCILMEMBER IN PARADISE FOR
OVER SIXTEEN YEARS SAID A
BUSINESS OWNER ON A MOVIE
THEATER IN PARADISE --
ALSO OVER IN LAKE COUNTY HAVE A
COUPLE BUSINESSES.
THERE I SPENT FOURTEEN YEARS ON
LAUGH CO --
SO IN A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
LAND USE AND PLANNING AND ALSO --
FOURTEEN YEARS ON THE LEAGUE
CITY SET PUBLIC SAFETY POLICY
COMMITTEE SETS NEAR AND DEAR TO
ME -- ALSO
FOR FULL DISCLOSURE I'M VERY
PROUD OF MY SON IN LAW WHOSE --
CAL FIRE ENGINEER AND YON PHIL
SO -- MY MY
NOSE GET OUT OF BED BUT ABOUT
THIS -- MY
HOME BURNED IN THE WILL
PROPERTIES MY AND AND AND IT OF
A MY HOW ABOUT TWENTY YEARS OLD --
BUILT OF THOSE FIRE RESISTANT
MATERIALS --
STUCCO HARDY PLANK --
MY DECK WAS CONCRETE AND STEEL
IT'S STILL STANDING --
OF THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE I LIVED
ON THE EDGE OF THE EDGE OF THE
CANYON ON THE EDGE OF THE CITY
LIMITS --
WE'RE TRULY IT MEETS TO BE ALONE
BLM LAND --
BUT THE FIRE CAME FROM WITHIN
THE CITY EIGHT EIGHT CAME DOWN
MY DRIVEWAY.
ACCORDING TO THE NEIGHBORS --
AND ANDYOU TALK ABOUT THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE THOSE OF US
THAT LIVE ON THE CANYON WE LIVE
ON THE EDGE WE'VE BEEN VERY
VIGILANT.
PEOPLE WITHIN THE TOWN.
NOT SO MUCH AND THAT'S A THAT'S
A CHALLENGE --
MIGHT WERE MY DAUGHTER WAS WHEN
I WAS LISTEN THE SCANNER THE
FIRE IT'S SPOTTED OVER.
HAD MOVED --
FROM POLKA. NINE MILES AND THEN
WAS BURNING THE EDGE OF TOWN BUT
WAS BURNING FARTHER INTERIOR.
OF THE CITY --
LONG BEFORE ANYTHING ELSE IS
BRING SO WE STARTED BURNING ON
THE EDGES AND THEN IN THE MIDDLE
AND THEN ON THE END OF THE FOR
THE SAGES SO.
OF LOTS OF CHALLENGES AND WE
WERE HAD MY I LAID OUT MY FIRE
HOSES --
AROUND THE HOUSE SO IF SOMEBODY
GIVE FIRE ENGINES CAME SOMEBODY
CAME SAVE IT --
THEY COULD TRY TO DO IT THE
CHALLENGES OF EVACUATIONS YOU'RE
STUCK IN TRAFFIC. FOR HOURS AND
THE PROBLEM WASN'T OUR TRAFFIC
IN THE TOWN OF PARADISE.
IT WAS DOWN AT THE BOTTOM SKY
WAY FIFTEEN MILES.
AWAY AT HIGHWAY NINETY NINE
WHERE THEY WEREN'T PREPARED FOR
HAVING. TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
THOUSAND VEHICLES SOME ARE MAYOR
WHO'S A FORGE FORMER CALTRANS
DISTRICT DIRECTOR KNOWS A BIT
ABOUT TRAFFIC MOVEMENT SHE SAYS
THERE'S NO PHYSICAL WAY.
THAT YOU COULD MOVE THAT MANY
VEHICLES ON THE SQUARE FOOTAGES
STREET THAT WE HAVE IN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME WE HAD.
THE JUST NO WAY TO DO IT --
THEY HAVE BEEN ADDED THE UPPER
REACHES SCAPE ROUTE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AFTER THE HUMBLE
COMPLEX FIRES --
THAT HELPED A GREAT DEAL.
BUT WE WE HAD THAT WE USE CONTRA
FLOW.
ALL LANES WHAT WAS NORMALLY
COMING INTO TOWN AND TWO LANES
GOING OUT OF TOWN BECAME SIX
LANES GOING OUT OF TOWN.
BUT YOU WERE HAVING TO DODGE
FIRST RESPONDERS TRYING TO GET
INTO TOWN TO IS WE HAD A LIMITED --
WORK CAL FIRE --
CONTRACTS CITY --
THEY DO AN EXCELLENT JOB --
WE HAD EXCELLENT RESPONSE BUT IT
WAS -- TRULY
AB CHALLENGING UP SOME OF THE
TAKE WASTE JUST QUICKLY --
AN ADVANCED RAPID WARNING SYSTEM
IS SOMETHING WE NEED --
BEEN OUR WE WE COMMUNITIES.
AND INCIDENTLY ALL THE REBUILD
IN PARADISE HALF TO MEET WILLIE
STANDARDS EVERYBODY'S GONNA HAVE
TO BE SPRINKLER --
THEY HAVE TO BE THAT NON
COMBUSTIBLE MATERIALS --
SO THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT I VERIFIED THAT THIS
MORNING WITH THE TOWN MANAGER
BUT WE NEED TO HAVE MORE --
AS A DATE THE ADVANCE RAPID
WARNING SYSTEMS --
WE HAVE TO BE MORE AGGRESSIVE IN
THE IN THE WET SEASON TO BE ABLE
TO USE --
CONTROLLED BURNS ARE PRESCRIBED
FIRE.
WITHOUT RUNNING AFOUL OF THE AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S --
THAT THE KIND OF CONTROL OUR
ABILITY TO DO THAT AND AND WE
NEED TO STAFF CAL FIRE YEAR
ROUND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THEIR
TEAMS WORKING ON THAT STUFF
REALLY NEEDS TO BE A FULL TIME
THING.
AND THEN.
THE OTHER THING WE FOUND IT WE
NEED TO REALLY LOOK MORE AT IN
THESE COMMUNITIES.
IS A BUILDER AT BILL THAT HE TO
SHELTER IN PLACE --
CROSS FOR MY MOVIE THEATER TO
KMART PARKING LOT --
SIX OR SEVEN HUNDRED VEHICLES
SHELTERED IN PLACE THERE BECAUSE
THEY COULD NOT GET OUT BECAUSE
THE TRAFFIC THAT WAS THE SAFEST
PLACE FOR THEM TO BE.
CAL FIRE WAS THERE AND THEN WHEN
IT WAS WHEN THE TRAFFIC IT LET
UP THEN THEY LET THEM OUT OF
TOWN.
AND AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THAT AND
IDENTIFY PLACES WHERE --
THE STRUCTURES ARE SUCH THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BURN.
AND AND THAT WE CAN SHELTER RE
EMPLOYED SURE OFF AND THEN ALLOW
THE FIRST RESPONDERS TO DO THEIR
JOB --
BECAUSE ALL OF THEM THAT ARE IN
TOWN THAT DAY WERE.
ONLY WORRIED ABOUT LIFE SAFETY
GETTING PEOPLE OUT THEY WEREN'T
FIGHTING THE STRUCTURE FIRES AT
THAT POINT IT WAS JUST GETTING
PEOPLE OUT ONE MINUTE.
OKAY AND THEN LASTLY P. JEANNIE --
HAS THE IN THEIR IN THEIR
REBUILD PROCESS --
IS USING SOMETHING THEY CALL
TREE RATED WIRING.
AND I THINK THAT SOMETHING A LOT
OF THESE FIRES SEEM TO BE
ATTRIBUTED TO PGA OR THE
UTILITIES AND AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IS SPENT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PUTTING
IN.
TREE RATED WIRING P. JEANNIE HAD
NOT BEEN DOING THAT THEY'RE
DOING THAT NOW IN PARADISE BUT
THERE'S A SHORTAGE OF THAT --
THAT WIRING.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT AND THEN ALSO THINGS
LIKE A HIGH IMPEDANCE ARC FAULT
INTERRUPTERS --
WHICH CAN STOP THINGS FROM
SPREADING --
AND THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
BECAUSE LET'S LET'S STOP THE
IGNITION --
BUT LOTS OF BUG.
REALLY INTERESTING WELL INFORMED
COMMENTS HERE TODAY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE REST OF THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU EVEN SHARE YOUR
STORY TAKES TIME TO BEAR TO BE
HERE AND ALSO LEARN THE LESSONS
THAT YOU SEEN ON THE GROUND.
I LIVE IN THROUGH THAT HELL THAT
WAS -- FIRE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT MR SMELLING
HIS HERE HE'S ATTRACTED THE
BUTTE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENT SERVICES WAS SELLING
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HI YOU ARE IN THE THICK OF IT AT
THE MOMENT IN REGARDS TO THE
REBUILD.
YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES IN WILL
GIVE YOU A ONE MINUTE PROMPT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE
TODAY.
SOME GREAT TO BE HERE AS WELL.
WE ENJOYED LEARNING HOW FROM SO
MANY SPEAKERS THIS MORNING
HAPPENING HERE WE'RE ALL GONNA
GO ON A FIELD TRIP TO AUSTRALIA
EIJI WAS SEE THINGS OVER THERE.
THAT WAS GOOD NEWS.
I THINK THE THE QUESTION I CAME
PREPARED ANSWERS SO SHOULD THE
STATE DO MORE TO REGULATE
DEVELOPMENT IN FIRE PRONE AREAS.
AND I THINK I CAN TELL YOU FROM
RURAL CALIFORNIA GENERALLY THE
ANSWER IS NO.
I HAVE THE STATE --
MANDATES ARE NOT WELCOME BUT%
INCENTIVES IN A I THINK THERE
ARE AND WE RECOGNIZE NAY GREEN
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER SAID
REALLY IT'S GONNA BE A
COMBINATION OF BOTH SOME
INCENTIVES AND MANDATES.
AND MY BACKGROUND IS I'M.
OVERSEE PLANNING BUILDING AND OF
ARMED SERVICES SO ALL OF THE
PLANNING BUILDING IN COULD
FORSMAN.
AT ALL OF THESE SERVICES ARE
RELATED TO LAND USE IN SO WE'RE
WE'RE INVOLVED WITH PLANNING TO
THE JOURNAL PLANS ONLY PROCESS.
IN AND WE'RE INVOLVED WITH
TEACHING BUILDING PERMITS ISSUED
ACTUALLY GET BUILT WITH THINGS
DON'T GO WELL WERE INVOLVED CODE
ENFORCEMENT TO SEE THINGS GET
REPAIRED SO WE'RE ALL OF ONE
STOP SHOP.
I HAD FOUR DIFFERENT AREAS I WAS
GOING TO COMMENT ON THE LEGACY
COMMUNITIES THAT'S BEEN
ADDRESSED PRETTY WELL BY A LOT
OF THE SPEAKERS.
HI YOU KNOW. FOR ME THE LONG
DEAD --
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA COUNTIES
IS -- YOU
KNOW THESE FIRE TRAPS ARE
SERIOUS ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS IN OUR LEGACY
COMMUNITIES.
YOU KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THE NEED
FOR EVEN COVERS GUTTER COVERS --
LANDSCAPE REPLACING WOODEN DECKS
ALREADY THOSE KINDS OF THINGS I
MY RECOMMENDATION IS LIKE YOU
FOR BEFORE TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY.
AND ALSO YOU KNOW WE COULD
INCORPORATE SOME OF THE
TECHNOLOGY POSSIBLY IN THE
FUTURE PROGRAMS WERE PEOPLE DO
THEIR OWN VIDEO INSPECTIONS OF
THEIR HOMES --
THAT GETS FORWARDED ON YOUR
INSURANCE COMPANY THAT BECOMES
PART OF YOUR RECORD FOR SHOWING
YOUR DEFENSIBLE SPACE YOUR YOU
KNOW YOU'VE MADE IMPROVEMENTS TO
CATCHER --
AND GUTTERS COVERED YOU CUT EVEN
COVERS --
YOU WEN YOU REPLACE WOOD DECKS
I MEAN ALL THOSE THINGS COULD BE
VERIFIED THERE ARE THERE WE GOT
TO BE THINKING MORE CREATIVELY I
THINK.
THEY'RE JUST GOING OUT TO EVERY
HOUSE AND KNOCKED ON EVERY DOOR
I THINK WE HAVE A LOT OF TOOLS
TO USE SO LET'S PUT HIM TO USE.
ANOTHER IDEA WAS TO HAVE
SOMETHING KIND OF LIKE A A
NATIONAL FIRE INSURANCE PROGRAM.
SIMILAR TO NATIONAL FLOOD
INSURANCE PROGRAM.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S BEEN
TALKED ABOUT BUT I'VE MY FIRE
FOLKS TELL ME THAT GAINES LIVE
IN THE WE WE IN THAT PUTS US ON
THE SCALE I THINK OF OF A FLOOD
THE NATIONAL FLOOD INSURANCE.
TYPE OF PROGRAM THE OTHER IDEA
WOULD BE IT'S TAX SEASON.
NO SIR TAX CREDIT POSSIBILITIES
SIMILAR LIKE WE DO A SOLAR --
FOR SOME OF THESE TYPES OF
IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD BE
SOMETHING. TO TAKE A LOOK AT
NEXT THERE IS FUTURE DEVELOPMENT
IN FIRE PRONE AREAS [inaudible]
I AM.
YOU KNOW THIS THIS FIRE THAT WE
HAD THIS THIS WAS A WILDLAND
FIRE.
THAT BECAME AN URBAN FIRE AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING
WITH HIS COFFEE PARKER PARADISE
IN THE COUNTY.
I YOU KNOW YOU HEARD THE EMBERS
JUMPING FIVE MILES IF YOU LOOK
AT THE PROGRESSION MAP OF THE
FIRE WRITTEN IN RAM PARADISE
IT'S SWALLOWED PARADISE FROM
BOTH SIDES.
AND IT WAS THE SCARIEST THING
THING TO LOOK AT IN THE
PROGRESSION --
BUT THESE ARE ANGRY FIRES AND IT
TAKES IT'S GOING TO TAKE
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT I'M SURE AND MORE.
AND I DON'T KNOW THE WE CAN STOP
THE FIRES --
I THINK YOU DO WHEN THE FIRE
COMES.
THAT'S A SOBERING THOUGHT TO
THINK ABOUT.
I KNOW THIS FIRE I HAD A VERY --
POINT COUNTERPOINT CONVERSATIONS
WHEN MY FIREMAN I SAID WHY DID
YOU GUYS JUST NOT THIS DOWN FROM
THE AIR RIGHT WHEN IT HAPPENED.
AND YET SIX THREE MORNING.
SAID THE WINDS WERE SO HIGH THE
SMOKE WAS SO THICK THEY COULD
NOT GET IN THERE.
AND YOU KNOW THAT WAS WELL DON'T
YOU HAVE A SUPER DUPER PLAYING
THE CAN GET AND YOU KNOW HIM.
SO ANYWAY --
IT WAS VERY FRUSTRATING BUT THE
REAL.
OF THE FIRST TEN HOURS OF THE
EMERGENCY RESPONSE WAS
ESSENTIALLY A LIFE RESCUE EVENT
ALSO I THINK THERE'S A LOSING
THAT THE THEY'RE FIGHTING THE
FIRE THERE ARE FIGHTING THE FIRE
THEIR THIEVING FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
THAT'S WHAT WAS GOING ON FOR THE
FIRST TEN HOURS IN PARADISE IN
IN THE COUNTY.
A PARADISE I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THE TOWN MANAGER ALSO AND
WHEN.
THINGS PRETTY BROAD STILL IN IN
OUR AREA BUT I I ASK A QUESTION
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO ARE YOU GONNA
REPLANT OR JUST REBUILD.
AND THE INSTINCT TO THE IN LOVE
WITH IS TO REBUILD.
GET IN THE PEOPLE GET BACK ON
THE PROPERTY YOU KNOW IT'S GONNA
TAKE AS A YEAR MORE TO CLEAN UP
THE PROPERTIES.
SO NOW TO THEIR CREDIT THE TOWN
IS UNDERTAKING A PROCESS CALLED
MAKE IT PARADISE.
ADULT.
IN THAT CITY COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS TO LOOK TO RE
PLAN.
ARE THE TOWN IN MAKING A FIRE
RESILIENT CAM SERVED UP TO YOU
AN OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THE TARA
PARADISE BECOME THE MODEL FIRE
RESILIENT COMMUNITY.
SO THAT'S THAT'S SOMETHING I
THINK IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY.
UP YOU CARRY RECOVERS DOT ORG IS
ALSO WEBSITE THAT'S GOT A LOT OF
GREAT INFORMATION. ONE MINUTE
OKAY.
I GOTTA GET INTO LAND USE
PLANNING LAWS --
SB TWELVE FORTY ONE WE TALKED
ABOUT A LITTLE EARLIER IN UNDER
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE ALSO WE
HAVE --
REQUIREMENTS FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS AN
ADAPTATION STRATEGIES.
ALSO THE LOCAL HAS MITIGATION
PLANS A CONNECTION WITH THE
SAFETY ON THE TO THE BOTTOM LINE
THERE IS THAT WE NEED TO CONNECT.
WITH OUR SAFETY ELEMENTS ARE
GENERAL PLANTS AND GET SOME REAL
ACTION ITEMS OUT OF OUR GENERAL
PLANTS THAT GET SPECIFIC WITH
WHAT THE TARGETED ISSUES ARE IN
OUR JURISDICTIONS.
IN I THINK THE REALITY TO DO
THAT IS WE NEED SOME FUNDING
NEED SOME GRANT FUNDING TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
SO CONNECTING LH MPS GENERAL
PLANS SB.
THREE SEVENTY NINE AND FRANKLY
WE PROBABLY OUGHT TO THROW IN
THE U. S. B. ONE THOUSAND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE WHILE
READY BECAUSE WE GOT TO DO THAT
ANYWAY WOULD WORK.
ADJUSTING ARSENAL PLANS AND GET
THAT ALL FIXED.
I WOULD BE REMISS IF I DIDN'T
MENTION SEQUEL.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD THAT BROUGHT
UP WHAT'S TODAY I'M SHOCKED --
BUT A GOOD EXAMPLE FOR SEQUEL
COULD BE SO ACTUALLY IT'S FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS ARE IN A VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION --
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
SEEK BAR ON A PROJECT BY PROJECT
BASIS FOR FEW REDUCTION PROJECTS.
AND WE SHOULD COME UP WITH
STANDARDS THROUGH THE REGISTER
PROFESSIONAL FORESTERS BORE
FORESTRY OTHER PROPERTY AGENCIES
SO THAT WE CAN CARVE OUT OF
SEQUENCE ACTION FOR THEM TO GET
IN THERE DO THESE. TWO REDUCTION
PROJECTS THAT.
VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT AND
I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO GET
SEWER -- IN
THE DOWNTOWN BUSINESS JUST
BECAUSE WHY IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR PARADISE --
SO NO DATA.
CENTER NIELSEN SOONER INNOCENTLY
GALLAGHER IS WORKING HARD ON
THAT AS WELL WITH THAT JENNIFER
INTO WHICH WOULD MAKE ALL OF YOU
THAT CAME UP IN VISIT PARADISE
TWO NIGHTS GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR A REALLY GREAT FOR FREE
HEARING YOU. FOR YOUR INSIGHT.
WE NOW LIKE TO TURN THE FLOOR
OVER TO CHIEF MICHAEL OFTEN IS
WITH THE CONCERN THIS AT
COMMUNITY SERVICES DISTRICT.
BUT THEN THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
CHIEF IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE FOR YOUR TIME THE FLOOR IS
YOURS YOU HAVE FIVE MINUTES WILL
GIVE YOU ONE MINUTE PROMPT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH --
THERE IS A MEASURE THAT MICHAEL
GLADDEN THE FIRE CHIEF WE
CONSUME ISN'T IN ELK GROVE --
SPECIFICALLY SITTING BEFORE YOU
TODAY AS A LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY --
BOTH CENTER STERN AND DAN S.
OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE
WITH YOU ON THESE IMPORTANT
MATTERS THAT THAT AFFECT OUR
GREAT STATE --
THAT -- AS
IS AS WE MOVE IN THERE'S BEEN
MANY GREAT THINGS PROPER FOR YOU
TODAY FROM TEACH WHICH WIND
SPEAKING THIS MORNING OF THE THE
BUILDING CODES IN THE BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT EXIST.
CURRENTLY IN CALIFORNIA EVEN
THROUGH THE CURRENT CODE CYCLE
CONTINUING TO BUILD UPON THAT IN
IMPROVE UPON THAT.
AND I'M GONNA SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
OF THE CAMPFIRE HERE IN JUST A
MOMENT BRING SOME OF THESE
THINGS --
TOGETHER --
DIRECTOR GIL DUE TO YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE WHOLE COMMUNITY AND
UPPER IN THE NEED TO BRING
EVERYBODY TOGETHER BECAUSE
REALLY THE END OF THE DAY WE'RE
ALL HERE FOR THE SAME REASON A
VERY HIGH LEVEL MAYBE SIXTY
THOUSAND FOOT LEVEL IS.
RISK MANAGEMENT HAZARD
MANAGEMENT THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE AT THE
END OF THE DAY IT DOESN'T MATTER
IF YOU'RE UTILITY PROVIDER AN
INSURANCE COMPANY.
LEGISLATURE'S LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT OR JUST MEMBERS
LIVING IN A COMMUNITY THAT WE
WANT TO TRY TO MITIGATE IN
CONTROL MANY OF THESE PIECES --
THAT -- IS --
WAS BORN RETIRED FARMER SHEL --
DARGAN MENTIONED IT'S REALLY
TRYING TO TAKE IT DOWN A USE OF
THAT TECHNOLOGY THAT NOT ONLY BE
ABLE TO FOCUS IN A LASER IN ON
SPECIFIC PARCELS.
BUT BE ABLE TO TAKE THAT
INFORMATION PUT IT IT KIND OF
VISIT THERE BUT IT'S NOT QUITE
THERE YET IN YOUR PART OF SOME
OF THE INITIATIVES PART OF THIS
BE NOT A ONE LAST YEAR BRINGING
TECHNOLOGY TO THE FOREFRONT.
AND THAT'S A GREAT STEP MOVING
FORWARD IN GETTING SOME OF THOSE
PIECES -- IN
TERMS OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PEACE AND TYING IT IN TO DO THE
CAMPFIRE THAT --
I HAVE --
TWO TALES OF MY EXPERIENCE WITH
FIRST I I RESPOND AS PART OF THE
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL IT'S A
MANAGEMENT TEAM TO STAFF THE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER FOR
THE TOWN OF PARADISE. FOR A
PERIOD OF A WEEK RIGHT BEFORE
THANKSGIVING --
AND AS A AS A LINE FIREFIGHTER
WRITTEN COMING UP TO THE RANKS
AND RESPONDING IN APPLYING THESE
EMERGENCIES IT'S AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT ROLE WHEN YOU WALK
INTO ANY --
SEE THAT STAFFED SOLELY BY TOWN
OF PARADISE EMPLOYEES THAT FIFTY
ONE OUT OF SIXTY NINE TOLL
EMPLOYEES LOST THEIR HOMES SO
TALK OF AN IDEA WAS TO IN TERMS
OF POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT IN
DEVELOPING SOME OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WAS INSTRUMENTAL.
OBVIOUSLY EMOTIONAL AND
OBVIOUSLY SIGNIFICANT AND REALLY
JUST CAN'T BE UNDERSTATED TO
TALK ABOUT TRULY HOW RESILIENT
OF A COMMUNITY THEY ARE THAT
THEY WERE STILL STAFFING THE EOC
EVEN IN THE WAKE OF EVERYTHING
THEY HAD --
SOME OF THE OBSERVATIONS THEIR
RECORD IMMEDIATELY AFTER YOU
KNOW THE FIRE THAT REALLY IT BY
THIS POINT THE EMERGENCY ITSELF
IN THE TOWN HAD --
ED MITIGATED WE ARE MOVING TO
CODES AT THE TOP OF TOWN THERE'S
A NEW DEVELOPMENT OF DUPLEXES
THAT WERE BUILT WITH THE MODERN
CODE MODERN STANDARDS --
AS IS BEEN MENTIONED IN THE
FIRST TEN HOURS OF THE FIRE
FIGHT NOBODY WAS FIGHTING FIRE
IT WAS ABOUT RESCUE WILL THIS
DUPLEXES COMMITTEE OF DUPLEXES
THAT DAY I THINK TEN OR FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT BUILDINGS ONE BUILDING.
BURNED DOWN THE REST WITH STOOD
WITH NO FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES.
THE COACH WORK BUT NEVER COMES
BACK TO THE ENFORCEMENT THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AS FAR MARSHALL
ARGAN POINTED OUT --
THAN PUTTING SOME OF THOSE
THINGS IN PLACE AND THEN THE
STUFF BECAUSE YOU REALLY SCRATCH
YOUR HEAD AS YOU GO INTO THE
MIDDLE OF A PARKING LOT.
IS A VEHICLE THERE'S NO
VEGETATION NEARBY IT'S NOT NEAR
ANY STRUCTURES IT'S ALL BY
ITSELF.
IT IS COMPLETELY GUTTED AND
BURNED TO THE GROUND WELL IF A
METAL FLAKE MENTAL VEHICLE ON
THE OUTSIDE ISN'T FIRE RESISTANT
REAR WHERE WE FINDING OURSELVES
RIGHT IS JUST ONE OF THOSE
IRONIES THAT.
MAKES YOU REALLY PONDER AS
YOU'RE MOVING THROUGH THAT --
IN AS WE TALK ABOUT THE SPOTTING
AND BURNING FROM WITHIN AS IS
BEEN INDICATED --
MADE.
PRELIMINARILY THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
ARE CON FOR FORCED A LOSE ABOUT
30% OF THEIR NEEDLES ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS AS PART OF A NORMAL
CYCLE WELL THIS FIRE WAS LEAD
WAS SIXTY MILE AN HOUR WINDS
THAT TOOK THAT NEEDLE CAST IN
BASICALLY CREATED A FINE DID
FEEL BAD THROUGHOUT.
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY AS WE'RE
MOVING TO THE COMMUNITY THEY
WERE GREEN WASTE CAN SITTING AT
THE CURB.
FULL OF PINE NEEDLES MANY MANY
MANY PEOPLE IN THAT COMMUNITY
WERE DOING THEIR DUE DILIGENCE
TO PROTECT THEIR COMMUNITY TO
KEEP THEIR COMMUNITY FIRE SAFE.
BUT NATURE TOOK OVER GETTING
THINGS TOGETHER --
THE NEXT PIECE IS A I ALSO SAYS
A CALIFORNIA DIRECTOR ON THE
WIRE FOR WHAT WESTERN FIRE
CHIES --
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
FIRE CHIEFS IN AWHILE AND FOLLOW
VIOLIN FIRE POLICY COMMITTEE.
BRINGING TOGETHER SOME
INITIATIVES TO REALLY REFLECT
THE WESTERN STATES WALL ANY
DRIVE EDUCATION ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD CAN BURN.
NON BURN JUST LIKE IT DOES IN
THE WESTERN STATES AND SO WE'VE
TAKEN UPON OURSELVES AS THE
BOARD WE DID A SUMMIT.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN REALLY BROKE.
OUR PROBLEM DOWN INTO TRYING TO
DEVELOP INITIATIVES INTO PRE
EVENT AS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
IDENTIFYING THE PROPERTIES ARE
RISK ITS MASTER PLANNING A
GENERAL PLANNING.
OF COMMUNITIES AND REALLY
FOCUSING ON THAT THAT
PREPARATION PIECES MAKING SURE
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION SYSTEMS
ARE IN PLACE IS MAKING SURE.
YOU KNOW FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND
COMMUNITIES ARE WHERE IT'S
MAKING SURE THAT DESK I WEIGH IN
NINETY NINE CAN HANDLE THE THE
THE TRAFFIC OF WE HAVE TO
EVACUATE THE TOWN OF PARADISE.
IS C. EVENT ITSELF IN THE
ABILITY TO MOBILIZE WHICH WE DO
A VERY GOOD JOB OF CALIFORNIA IS
ABLE TO MOVE MORE RESOURCES IN A
SHORTER.
TIME THAN ANY PLACE ELSE IN THE
WORLD BUT THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM
FOR IMPROVEMENT.
THEN THE POST EVENT PIECE WHICH
IS REALLY INTERESTING FACTOR
TALKING ABOUT THE TOWN OF
PARADISE IS THAT.
IT'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO PLAN
AHEAD IF WE HAVE AN EVENT LET'S
NOT DO WHAT WE DID BEFORE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THE OUTCOME BUT
LEARN FROM.
THOSE EXPERIENCES TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD WHICH IS HOW TO CREATION
TO THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND
FIREFIGHTERS WEEK IN ORDER ARMS
ARE SMART PHONES.
THE LITTLE THING YOU CARE IN
YOUR POCKET AS MORE COMPUTING
POWER THAN WHAT WE PUT MEN ON
THE MOON WITH.
AND YET THEY'RE STILL TECHNOLOGY
THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
AVAILABLE TO US THAT WE'RE STILL
TROUBLING TO TRY TO GET THERE --
AND THEN THE LAST IS PARTNERING
WITH THE INSURANCE INDUSTRY
THEIR LOSSES ARE LOST AS A
COMMUNITY LOS WERE REALLY ALL IN
THE SAME FIGHT TOGETHER IN PART
OF THIS CAMPFIRE TO WERE WE DID.
BROUGHT IN MEMBERS FROM THE
NATIONAL INSURANCE INDUSTRY THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS OTHER CO DEVELOP DEVELOPMENT
ENTITIES TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
LOOK AT AND TAKE WHAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT AND REALLY GIVE
THEM.
A STRAIGHT FOR CLEAN EXAMPLE OF
SOME OF THE OF THE REASONS OF OF
THE NOT ONLY WHAT WE NEED TO DO
BUT REALLY BREAKING IT DOWN TO
DO -- THE
BEING ABLE TO I GUESS TRULY
DEMONSTRATED WHAT WE EXPERIENCE
OUT HERE IS NOT --
A MARSH FIRE SOME PLACE IN THE
IN THE SOUTEAST SO WITH THAT --
AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND I'LL BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS HE'S
NICE JOB THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE HERE TODAY YOU
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE GONNA OPEN UP
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN
JUST A BIT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR.
WE ARE APPRECIATIVE THAT WE HAVE --
PRESENT BAILEY HERE TODAY HE'S
PRESIDENT METRO FIRE HERE IN THE
STATE CAPITAL.
WE'RE GRATEFUL SIR THAT YOU'RE
HERE WE WELCOME YOU YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES WILL GIVE YOU A
LINE ONE MINUTE FROM THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME'S TIE BAILEY ON MY
FIRE CAPTAIN WITH SAC METRO FIRE
DISTRICT.
I AM ALSO PRESIDENT OF
SACRAMENTO AREA FIREFIGHTERS
LOCAL FIVE TWO TWO AND I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
OUR LOCAL IN THIS AREA WE'RE
UNIQUE WERE AMALGAMATED I
REPRESENT EIGHT FIRE DEPARTMENTS
OVER TWO THOUSAND MEMBERS.
AS THE MEN AND WOMEN ARE SENT
OUT ABOUT OUT TO BATTLE WITH
WILDLAND FIRES TODAY.
THERE ARE MANY FACTORS THAT
CREATE HIGH RISK [inaudible]
CATASTROPHIC FIRES.
IN THE AFTERMATH OF EVERY MAJOR
FIRE WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AND
ATTENTION ON SMALL FIXES THAT
FOCUS ON INDIVIDUAL PROPERTY
OWNERS.
BILL MATERIALS DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
PROPER EGRESS TEMPORARY REFUGE
AND SO FORTH.
WELL THESE ARE CRITICAL AND
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATIONS.
RE RICH WE RISK OVER ENGINEERING
THINGS.
IF WE DON'T LOOK AT ALL THE
FACTORS IN RISK FACTORS.
THOSE REQS INCLUDE A NUMBER OF
RESIDENTS IN AN AREA THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
FUEL LOADS PREVIOUS FIRE HISTORY
AND WEATHER EVENTS.
THESE MORE EXPANSIVE RICK'S RISK
FACTORS CAN'T BE VIEWED AS
STRICTLY LOCAL ISSUES.
THE IMPACT OF CATASTROPHIC FIRED
TOUCHES EVERY CALIFORNIA.
THESE COST OF THESE DISASTERS
ARE LARGELY BORNE BY ALL OF US.
IN THE NEW NORMAL AS THEY SAY.
CALIFORNIA MUST DO MORE TO MAKE
SURE THE LAND USE POLICY.
TAKE THESE RISK FACTORS INTO
ACCOUNT.
IS IT IT IS.
WITHOUT SAYING THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING CLOSELY AT NEW
DEVELOPMENT IN THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE AND OTHER RISK
AREAS.
BUT WE MUST ALSO LOOK
EXTENSIVELY AT THE DEVELOPMENT
THAT HAS BEEN BUILT OVER THE
YEARS WITHOUT INTERVENTION.
WHILE THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE
FIRE IMPAIRED US PARADISE WAS
BEYOND MEASURE WE KNOW THAT THE
TOWN WAS DEVELOPED HALF A
CENTURY AGO WITH.
PERSPECTIVES THAT ARE MUCH
DIFFERENT TODAY.
AS WE ASK THE QUESTION.
SHOULD WE BUILD IT BACK.
WE HAVE TO LOOK BEYOND LOCAL
ZONING AND CONSIDER THE BIG
PICTURE.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT FUEL LOADING
LOCATION ROADS IN AND OUT.
IGNITION SOURCES AND OTHER
CASUAL FACTORS.
ONLY THEN CAN WE DECIDE.
ON THESE ISSUES SUCH AS SPACING
ROSE AND STRUCTURAL COMPOSITION
AND NEW CONSTRUCTION.
OF COURSE.
NO ONE SAID PRESCRIPTIONS IS
FULL PROOF.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE SANTA ROSA
FIRE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE HAD
WIDE ROADS PLENTY V. GRESS.
ANY MANY CASON VERY MODERN
MATERIALS.
BUT NO AMOUNT OF PREPARATION OR
FIRE RESPONSE WAS GOING TO STOP
THAT FIRE SWARMING THOSE
NEIGHBORHOODS.
EVEN HERE THESE EXPERIENCE
SHOULD OFFER A ROADMAP AS WE
LOOK TO REBUILD.
AS THE STATE AS TO THE STATE'S
ROLE THE FIRST AND FOREMOST
REQUIRES A REALISTIC AND MORE
CURRENT ASSESSMENT OF THE RISK
OF THE STATE AND ALL THE
COMMUNITIES.
HAVE WE'VE HEARD CAL FIRES MAPS
ARE UNDERGOING A REVISION.
BUT EVEN WHEN THESE MAPS ARE
CURRIED CAL FIRE IS ONLY
REQUIRED TO PUBLISH THE DATA ON
VERY HIGH.
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY AREAS.
WHEN YOU OVER IDENTIFY PEOPLE
BECOME NUMB TO THE RISK?
IN OTHER AREAS.
LIKE HIGH --
MODERATE FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ADOPT THE COW
FIRE MAP.
BUT IN MANY CASES LOCALS LRA
LOCAL AREAS DO NOT COMPLY INTENT
PENALTIES ARE NOT SAID
SIGNIFICANT.
THESE LAWS NEED MORE TEETH. ONE
EXAMPLE IS SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
FROM TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHICH
REQUIRES LOCAL AGENCIES PROVIDE
LONG TERM HAZARD MITIGATION SO
PLANS BY.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AGENCIES
THAT DON'T COMPLY WITH ESPYS
THREE SEVENTY NINE MAY NOT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FEMA AID IN THE
EVENT OF A CATASTROPHIC FIRE OR
DISASTER.
WE ARE GOING TO EXPERIENCE
MASSIVE FIRES IN DISASTERS ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
BUT THE IMPACT OF CATASTROPHIC
FIRE STRETCHES WELL BEYOND ONE
SET OF BORDERS.
AND THE STATE NEEDS. TO TAKE A
BROADER VIEW AS WELL.
WE CAN'T CONTROL MOTHER NATURE
BUT WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB
DECIDING WHERE AND HOW TO PUT
PEOPLE IN THE PATH TO DISASTER.
I THINK I HAVE A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE ON THE FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA I STARTED WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WORKING ON
HAND TRUTH.
ON THE STANISLAUS NATIONAL
FOREST I ALSO WORKED. FOR CAL
FIRE FURTHER ADD THREE YEARS.
BEFORE I BECAME A FIREFIGHTER
WITH METRO FIRE [inaudible]
AND SOME OF THE FIRES THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE TODAY'S A CEDAR.
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN I WAS FIRST
IN OUR FOR RESPONDED OUT WE ARE
ONE OF THE FIRST.
STRIKE TEAMS.
ON THE WHICH FIRE.
AND I REMEMBER TELLING THE OTHER
FIREFIGHTERS AND I CAME BACK.
THAT THIS WAS A CAREER FIRE AND
I KNOW THAT SOMEONE IS SPOKE ON
THAT EARLIER.
HERE WE ARE ELEVEN YEARS LATER
[inaudible]
AND THE CLEAR FIRES ARE
HAPPENING EVERY YEAR YOU KNOW AS
THEY SAY THE HUNDRED YEAR FLOODS
EVERY RIGHT NOW IT'S EVERY FIVE
YEARS OR LESS.
AND THE FIRES THAT WERE HAVING
TODAY.
NEED TO HAVE A HOLISTIC APPROACH
UTILIZING ALL THE INFORMATION
THAT WE'RE WE'VE AYE FOR TODAY'S
BEEN GREAT.
BUT IT'S NOT ONE OF THOSE THAT'S
GONNA MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
IT'S REALLY LOOKING AT THE
EDUCATION PORTION THE TECHNOLOGY
BOOTS ON THE GROUND MEETING WITH
COMMUNITIES.
AND LASTLY THE ENFORCEMENT PIECE
OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
RESIDENTS ARE TAKEN CARE THEIR
OWN PARCELS.
AND I THINK WE CAN GET IT DONE
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE REPRESENTING
THAT FIREFIGHTERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND AND SACRAMENTO
AREA.
THANK YOU THIS PRESENT WE'RE
GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND PLEASE PASS ON
OUR THANKS. TO EVERYONE IS ACT
WHICH WAS THE WERE MUTUAL AID
FOR WEEKS AT A TIME --
YOUR CLEANS FROM THE FIRE THEN
OBVIOUSLY UP IN.
A PARADISE AS WELL SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR.
WITH THAT WOULD OPEN UP TO
COMMITTEE ON FIRST GO TO THE
CHAIR IF YOU AS WELL MISTER
CHAIR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I GUESS TWO QUICK QUESTIONS.
WELL FIRST OF ALL.
THANKS FOR PUTTING YOURSELVES ON
THE LINE STRETCH YOUR ENTIRE
CAREER.
WHEN ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
WORK EITHER IT MUNICIPAL
GOVERNMENT DO OR?
NO IN THESE IN THESE FIRE CREWS
THE TRAUMA PART OF IT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE FOCUS THIS
HEARING BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE GOT OUR I OWN TO BECAUSE
CAREER FIRES.
HAVE CAREER.
IMPACTS TO WIN PEOPLE'S WELL
BEING AND IT'S AN ONGOING
CONCERN FOR US --
YOU MENTIONED.
THE MAYOR LAUDER NOTES FORMER
MAYOR LOUDER WE'LL CALL YOU
MAYOR MISTER MAYOR YOU CAN KEEP
THE TITLE I I ALWAYS I THINK
YOU'VE EARNED IT FROM WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN THROUGH --
YOU MENTIONED YOU CHECKED IN
WITH THE CITY ABOUT YOUR
REBUILDING PLANTS WAS THIS WAS
OUR INNER ORDINANCE ADOPTING
JUST CURIOUS ABOUT THE SWORD
IMPLEMENTATION YOU'D MENTIONED
SORT OF YOUR AND THEN THE NEW
GUIDELINES.
WHEN -- WHEN
THE CHIEF FOR A RICH ONE WAS
TALKING AND ANY?
IT IT SOUNDED TO ME LIKE.
IT WAS OPTIONAL. TO YOU HAVE TO
REBUILD UNDER THAT WE WE
STANDARDS --
I QUICKLY TEXTED MIGHT TOWN
MANAGER I SAID BERMAN I'M FIVE
MY IMPRESSION IS THAT IT'S
REQUIRED --
SO -- AT
LEAST IN THE TOWN OF PARADISE I
CAN SAY THAT IT IS IT IS
REQUIRED THAT YOU HAVE TO
REBUILD UNDER THE WILLIE
STANDARDS UNDER THE WE SET AN
MISTER SNOWING SAME SAME THING
THERE IS THOUGH A MOVE AFOOT.
IN SOME OTHER JURISDICTIONS TO
USE OF PREVIOUS BUILDING CODE IN
THAT CONVERSATION CAN BE
HAPPENING SO UNLESS SOMETHING
EXTRAORDINARY HAPPENS.
WE WOULD REBUILD TO THE NEW COAT.
UNDER EIGHT UNDER A COUNTY
ORDINANCE OR UNDERSELL
UNDERSTATES Là UNDERSTATE LAW
AND IT.
BUT WE ADOPT THE STATE LAW
LOCALLY YOU ADOPT THAT WILL BE
THE WILL BE STANDARD INTO THE
INTO YOUR STATE DOOR BUILDING
CODE.
INTO YOUR BUILDING CODE.
SO CAN YOU IS THERE A WAY TO GET
OUT OF IT I MEAN YOU'RE SAYING
THERE'S A MOVEMENT OF MINIMUM
STANDARDS UNLESS OR SOME
LEGISLATIVE RELIEF [inaudible]
UNDERSTOOD --
CAN I INTERJECT HERE PLAY A JOB
JUST RECEIVED SOMETHING THAT
YESTERDAY OR DAY BEFORE FROM
SHASTA COUNTY AND THEY HAD
ROLLED THEIR BUILDING CODES
AFTER THE CAR FIRE BACK.
TO THE NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN
STANDARDS BUT THEN ADDED IN THAT
YOU STILL NEED TO MEET WE WE AND
AND FIRE SPRINKLERS IN THE NON
COMBUSTIBLE MATERIALS.
SO I PRESUME THAT WAS TO SAVE
PEOPLE MONEY IN TERMS OF
ENERGIES ENERGY CALC BECAUSE THE
COST REBUILDING IN ALL THESE
AREAS IS IS HORRENDOUS IDEA OF
BLAKE COUNTY.
THE VALLEY FIRE FOUR YEARS AGO
EVAN ACHIEVE 20% REBUILD YET IT
LA IN AN NAM PARADISE LOST.
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND A YEAR --
PARADISE AND WE GET A LOS
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND HOMES AND AND
CONQUER OUT.
OF IT YET --
Là AB YEAH HATE TO THINK WHAT
THAT'S WHAT THAT DOES TO THE
ECONOMY THERE AND ALL THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE DISPLACED SO ANYTHING
YOU CAN DO. TO MAKE IT EASIER TO
REBUILD.
I THINK.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA SEE FROM.
THE CHAIR AND I A GOING FORWARD
I MEAN THE TESTIMONY WE RECEIVED
TODAY.
IT'S INCREDIBLY COMPELLING AND
THIS IDEA OF AT LEAST PRIMING
THE PUMP AND GETTING STARTED ON
THE INCENTIVE CITING COMING UP
WITH.
A WHOLE SUITE OF OF STATE
INCENTIVES WHERE WE'RE
INTEGRATING WITH THE LOCALS BUT
THE KIND OF YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S IN THE TAX CODE OR WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH SOME EXISTING
PROGRAMS WE HAVE I MEAN THERE'S
ALREADY OF A FAIR AMOUNT OF
FUNDING APPROPRIATED --
BUT WHETHER WE NEED NEW
MECHANISMS TO ADMINISTER SOME OF
THAT IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA
BE LOOKING VERY CLOSELY AT MEAN
ANY.
YEAH ANY FEEDBACK YOU ALL MIGHT
HAVE IN THE FUTURE ON ON WHAT
THAT STRUCTURE LOOKS LIKE WE
KNOW THAT EVERY COMMUNITIES ALSO
DIFFERENT AND BUYING POWERS
DIFFERENT RIGHT AND SO EVEN IN.
YOU KNOW TAKE THE WILL THE FIRE
MALIBU SEMINAL SPRINGS WHICH IS.
LOW INCOME TRAILER PARK RIGHT
NEXT TO A MANSION RIGHT AND AND
THEY'RE NOT THAT FAR APART AND
WE KNOW THAT THOSE SITUATIONS.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT BIG
BEAUTIFUL HOME IN THE MOUNTAINS
OR YOU COULD BE LIVING YOU KNOW
ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE VERY NEARBY
AND SO.
HAD A SORT OF TAYLOR THAT AND
AND FIND THAT SWEET SPOT I THINK
WILL BE AN IMPORTANT ISSUE GOING
FORWARD THERE WERE THIRTY THREE
MOBILE HOME PARKS THE IN THE
EFFORT TO BURN DOWN IN.
OTHER LOT OF MANUFACTURED HOMES
SO THE HOUSING STOCK IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN SHOWREEL WHEN
THEY CAN COPY PARK YEAH AND IT'S
AWFUL TO WATCH THE THE ON THE
MOBILE HOME SITES ESPECIALLY THE
OLDER HOMES --
JUST HOW COMBUSTIBLE THEY ARE
AND HOW DIFFICULT THEY ARE TO
RETROFIT AND JUST HAVE
DECIMATING IT CAN BE OUT THERE I
DID WANT TO GIVE --
CHIEF PIMLOTT JUST A CHANCE. TO
TO COME BACK TO US I KNOW YOU
HAD A FEW OUTSTANDING ISSUES BUT
I THEY WANT TO COME BACK.
TO THAT YOU DIDN'T GET TO IN
YOUR EARLIER REMARKS AS BROWN'S
JUST EMPHASIZING A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT --
I HEARD TODAY THAT I THINK ARE
GOING TO BE --
IMPORTANT ANDERSON SOME THESE
OUTSIDE THE BOX --
CONVERSATIONS THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO BE BE HAVING THAT PLAYED
OUT IN THE CAMP FIRE --
BUT ALSO SOME NEW THINGS ONE IS
THIS THE CONCEPT OF THE
SHELTERING IN PLACE --
YOU KNOW THAT HAPPENED JUST
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT FIREFIGHTERS
DID AND THAT'S WHERE PEOPLE WENT.
JUST BECAUSE IN ON THE CAMPFIRE
AND THEY BE NO THEY GRAVITATED
TO A PARKING LOT IN A STRUCTURE
THAT WAS DEFENDABLE AND
FIREFIGHTERS WERE ABLE.
TO PROTECT THOSE CITIZENS THEY
WE EVACUATED.
YOU KNOW WE LEARNED A LOT FROM
THE FIRES IN VICTORIA AUSTRALIA
FROM THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS
WHERE THE HEY HAD A STAY AND
DEFEND POLICY WHERE THEY ALLOW
HOMEOWNERS ENCOURAGE THEM TO
STAY IN THEIR HOMES.
WHEN THE FIRE BLEW THROUGH AND
WHAT HAPPENED IS OVER TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE DIED?
BECAUSE WHEN THE FIRE HIT THE
COMMUNITY THEIR HOMES THEY
REALIZE THEY'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH FIRE WERE SCARED AND THEY
ALL CHOSE TO LEAVE AT A TIME
WHEN THE FIRE WAS ACTUALLY
PINGING.
THOSE PEOPLE ACTUALLY DIED OUT
ON ON ROADS AND SO WE IN THE
STATE THE FIRE SERVICE
COLLECTIVELY LOOKED AT A READY
SET GO.
A POLICY WHERE IT WAS GET PEOPLE
OUT DO ALL THE THINGS YOU TO
PREPARE AND THEN WHEN THE FIRES
THERE YOU KNOW EVACUATE EVACUATE
EARLY AND ALLOW FIREFIGHTERS IN
LAWN FORTUNE TO COME IN AND DO
THEIR THING.
I THINK WHAT WE LEARNED FROM THE
CAMP FIRE IS THAT WE STILL WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVACUATION IS
THE FIRST PRIORITY THAT WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE.
SHELTERING IN THEIR BASEMENTS
LIKE YOU WOULD FOR A TORNADO IN
THE MIDWEST BUT WE ALSO
RECOGNIZE.
MUNIZ WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
EVERYBODY OUT THROUGH
EVACUATIONS BECAUSE OF HOW
QUICKLY SO WE NEED TO BE LOOKING
AT THESE IN TERMS OF PRE
DESIGNATED.
HARD YOU KNOW HARDENED AREAS
THAT ARE STAFFED BY FIREFIGHTERS
ARE LAW ENFORCEMENT OR PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICIALS THAT CAN BE
THERE FOR THE WELL BEING OF THE
SCREEN THERE.
THEY'RE NO DIFFERENT THAN --
I EVACUATION ZONE FROM A FLOOD
HERE'S WHERE YOU GO IF YOU LIVE
IN X. PART OF TOWN AND HAVE ALL
THAT INGRAINED IN EVERYBODY'S
THOUGHT PROCESS SO THAT AT LEAST.
THEY KNOW WHERE THEY CAN GO WHEN
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THAT DECISION
THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
THINKING ABOUT AS LONG AS RICH.
AS WELL TALK ABOUT HARDENING OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ALL WITH ME THAT --
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO CONSIDER AS PART OF THIS
BROADER MITIGATION.
AND I BELIEVE IT WAS DIRECTOR
KILLER DUCHIN MAYBE LEASE ONE
OTHER THAT BROUGHT THAT UP AND
THAT'S THERE MAY BE AREAS THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THE JUST
AREN'T DEFENDABLE --
THAT WHERE WE NEED TO FACTOR
INTO OUR GENERAL PLANS ARE
MITIGATION PLANS THAT THEY'RE
NOT NECESSARILY GOING TO BE
BUILDABLE ARE THERE OPTIONS. TO
MAKE AN OPEN SPACE TO ACTUALLY
PURCHASE THAT OUT WHETHER IT'S
IMMINENT DOOM IT WHATEVER THAT
IS --
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT DOES
COME WITH A HUGE LIABILITY FOR
WHOMEVER NOW BECOMES THE OWNER
OF THAT PROPERTY WHETHER IT'S
PUBLIC OR THROUGH AN A AND H.
AWAY.
BUT THAT MAY BE ANOTHER OPTION
TO TRY TO HELP GET SOME OF THESE
AREAS THAT ARE JUST NOT.
BUILDABLE FROM A SAFETY
PERSPECTIVE --
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS I THINK
WE'VE REALLY GOT TO BE --
YOUR LOCAL LAND USE PLANNING
DECISIONS.
THIS TIES THAT IS A STATE WIDE
ISSUE AND WE WORKED REAL HARD ON
TO US SENATE BILL.
TWELVE FORTY ONE WAS SENATOR
KEOGH TO START THIS LAND USE
PLANNING DISCUSSION AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
BUT EVEN TODAY IT'S STILL JUST.
ADVICE IT'S STILL JUST THE STATE
AND LOCAL EXPERTS SITTING DOWN
WITH PLANNING OFFICIALS --
LOCAL OFFICIALS REALLY NEED TO
HAVE SOME TEETH TO BE ABLE.
TO ENFORCE IT SOME OF THOSE
GUIDELINES WHEN THEY'RE MAKING
THESE TOUGH DECISIONS IN FORCE A
PROCESS THAT ALLOWS.
FOR DOING SOME MITIGATION
CRITERIA --
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE SOME
AREAS WHERE I THINK WE IN THE
ENFORCEMENT SIDE.
SO FOR OUR FIRE FIGHTING
PERSONNEL THAN HERE.
I MEAN HAVE YOU HAD EXPERIENCES
DEALING WITH THAT LOCAL LAND USE
PLANNING PROCESS WHERE YOU SEEN
[inaudible]
THEM LISTEN.
A DIFFERENTLY WHEN YOU'RE THE IS
PERSON IN UNIFORM THERE AND SORT
OF I'M JUST CURIOUS ABOUT YOUR
YOUR EXPERIENCE GOING THROUGH.
I THEIR PARTICIPATION IN GENERAL
PLANNING PROCESS I I DON'T KNOW
HOW MUCH INTERFACES THAT YOU GOT
IT'S GOT A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
TO BE DOING TO BUT IS THAT A
COMPLETE THAT A VIABLE PATH TO
SORT OF JUST GETTING MORE
INVOLVED IN THAT GOVERNANCE
PROCESS.
IN NO WE WE ARE CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN IN THAT A OUR AGENTS
YOU KNOW FIRE AGENCIES LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE ALWAYS INVOLVED
IN THE GENERAL PLAN IS PART OF
THE SAFETY ELEMENT IN LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW THOSE RISKS EXIST IN
THE COMMUNITY WERE INVOLVED IN
HELPING DEVELOP THE HAZARD
MITIGATION.
PLANS IN PULLING THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER AND COMMENTING ON THEM
YOU KNOW WERE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES.
YOU CAN LIE IT'S YOU KNOW
POLITICAL SUBDIVISIONS IN IN
DIFFERENT AREAS YEAH I WAS GONNA
SAY I'M SORRY TO INTERRUPT BUT
THE CITY.
SAFETY SIDE ONE THING YOU GET
DOWN TO THE SPECIFIC IF FORTY
SOME OF IT COMES BACK TO
RELATIONSHIPS IF YOU KNOW
RELATIONSHIPS ARE IMPORTANT
CRITICAL PIECE.
BUT THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY
SOMETHING THAT SOLVE THE LOCKS
US TOGETHER RADIO WOULD THEN IN
IN MY PARTICULAR CASE I'M A
SPECIAL DISTRICT OVERLAYS TO
CITIES WE HAVE GREAT WORKING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH BOTH OF THE
CITIES IN OR JURISDICTION.
WERE INTIMATELY INVOLVED IN MANY
OF THE DECISIONS BEING MADE FOR
NEW CONSTRUCTION OR PLANNED
DEVELOPMENT --
MASTER PLANNING STRATEGIC
PLANNING --
YOU KNOW WHERE OTHERS YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S DEPENDED UPON
RELATIONSHIPS YOU KNOW THAT WHEN
YOU'RE A A CITY FIRE DEPARTMENT
OR A DEPENDENT.
COUNTY YOU KNOW FIRE DISTRICT
YOU KNOW SOME OF THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS CAN BE --
BUT LITTLE MORE COHESIVE BECAUSE
YOU'RE BOTH REPORTING TO THE
SAME BOSS AT THE END OF THE DAY
BUT IT'S ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS
ABOUT INVOLVEMENT IN WERE YOU
KNOW WE ARE ABSOLUTELY --
INVOLVED IN IN BRINGING THAT
PIECE FORD M. IF IF YOU MAY I
TOUCH ON THE THE THE CODE PIECE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
MINUTE AGO.
THAT -- BIT.
RIGHT NOW THE CITY CALIFORNIA IS
IN THE PROCESS OF ADOPTING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIRE CODES TO
THE INTERNATIONAL CODE COUNCIL --
EVERY THREE YEARS THROUGH THE
CONSENSUS BUILDING PROCESS
BUILDS THE MODEL CODE AND IN THE
CALIFORNIA TAKES THAT MODEL CODE
IN ROLES IN.
CALIFORNIA AMENDMENTS AND THEY
HAVE A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS OF
BASICALLY BY JUNE THIRTIETH THEY
NEED TO ROLL OUT THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CODE IN WHICH LOCAL
AGENCIES THEN HAVE A HUNDRED
EIGHTY DAYS IN A QUESTION THE
CODE IS THAT THE LOCAL AGENCY
CANNOT ADOPT A CODE THAT IS LESS
LENIENT.
THAN WHAT THE STATE ADOPTS WE
CAN BE MORE STRINGENT BUT WE CAN
ONLY BE MORE STRINGENT IF
THERE'S TOPOGRAPHIC.
GEOLOGIC.
CLIMACTIC IN THERE'S ONE MORE
APOLOGIZE HAVE DINNER THERE'S
FOUR THERE'S FOUR FACTORS TO
GIVE US THE ABILITY AND HAD THE
IN ORDER FOR US TO MAKE.
A PROVISION IN OUR CODE MORE
STRANGE IT HAS TO BE DEPENDENT
ON A SPECIAL RISK OR UNIQUE RISK
EXISTS IN OUR COMMUNITY MEAN
TOWN OF PARADISE AND ISSUES AS
AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE AT SOME POINT
OF OUR CONVERSATION.
IT'S SURROUNDED BY A DEEP CAP
YOU KNOW --
CANYONS THAT ARE OPEN LAND BLM
LAND THAT POSES A HAZARD IT'S
UNIQUE COMPARED TO THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO OR THE CITY OF ELK
GROVE -- BUT
BUT WE CAN'T ADOPT A CODE IT'S
LESS LENIENT TO THE WHAT THE
STATE IS ADOPTED.
NAY UNIQUENESS REQUIREMENT IS
THAT A STATE LAW IS THAT IS THAT
IN STATE LAUNCH THAT YEAH IT'S
DEFINITELY BUT IT I KNOW IT IS
IT IS PART OF THE STATE YEAH
IT'S IT'S PART OF THE FIRE CODE
IS BUILDING AND WHAT YOU CAN.
BUILD AND SO THE STATE ADOPTED
IN THE BEFORE IT ALTERNATELY
COMES DOWN --
TO THE LOCAL LIKE I CAN SAY TO
YOU SPECIFICALLY WHERE THAT IS
BUT I CAN CERTAINLY GET YOU THAT
INFORMATION SO TO MISTER TOWNS
ARE YOU GUYS LOOKING AT THAT'S
COMING DOWN THE PIKE IT SOUNDS
LIKE SO HOW HOW HOW DOES BUTTE
PLANNED.
BUT WE HAVE A CONVERSATION AHEAD
OF US ACTUALLY WORK WE WILL BE
ADOPTING THE NEW COSTA QUESTION
IS I THINK FOR US IS ARE WE
GONNA BE MORE STRINGENT ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL NOT.
THERE I DON'T KNOW A PATH AS IN
THE FOR PARAMETERS --
TO BE MORE LENIENT AND I THINK
THAT THAT'S A HARD.
YOU KNOW POINT TO MAKE I THINK
THE WORK WE'RE GONNA HAVE THE
DISK NEW.
MANUFACTURED HOMES THE IN THE
PAST THE COULD BE.
AS OLD AS NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AND BE INSTALLED IN THE COUNTY
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE NOT.
VERY SAFE IN MY OPINION A UNITS
TO BE INSTALLING SO WE ADOPTED A
CO THAT LIMITS THE AGE TO TEN
YEARS OR NEWER.
SO THAT'S THE ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE'VE DONE.
IN THE COMING THAT'S ALLOWED
THROUGH STATE LAW.
IN.
DO YOU OF WOOD YOU'LL FIND THE
FOR THE FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
FOLKS HERE THE THE KIND OF
TRAINING THAT.
OUR FORMER AS FAR STATE FIRE
MARSHAL MENTION FOR HELPING CITY
PLANNERS AND LOCAL SORT OF TRAIN
THEMSELVES IN SOME OF THESE BEST
PRACTICES DO YOU MEAN.
DO I MEAN YOU YOU YOU ALL ARE IN
FIRE COUNTRYSIDE IMAGINE THERE'S
SORT OF A NATURAL INTEREST TO GO
DO THAT BUT YOU DO GET HAVE YOU
SEEN THAT SORT OF WITHIN THE
RANKS THE JUST LACK OF TRAINING
FAMILIAR.
I HAVE TWO FIREMAN IN MY OFFICE
SO THERE'S VERY CLOSE
COORDINATION WITH YELL FIRE.
YOU CAN FIRE SO --
I THINK THROUGH THE CONFERENCE'S
ASSOCIATIONS BUT THERE'S ALWAYS
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT.
I THINK THE I THINK THE FIRE
CHIEFS IN THE FIRE MARSHALL'S IN
OUR COMMUNITY WOULD APPRECIATE
HAVING THE PLANNERS HAVE A
GREATER UNDERSTANDING.
OF THAT THAT MAKES IT A LITTLE
BIT EASIER TO EXPLAIN AND GET
THINGS ACROSS BOB AND ONE TWELVE
FORTY ONE PASSED THE FOR THE
FUNDING IN FULL STAFF SUPPORT TO
HAVE THAT MORE DIRECT CONTACT
THE LOCAL LEVEL YOU'RE NEVER
FULLY MATERIALIZE FROM FROM A
BUDGET PERSPECTIVES I THINK FROM.
THE STATE'S PERSPECTIVE.
OBVIOUSLY I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THEM HAVE MORE RESOURCES TO
ENGAGE WITH THE COUNTY AND LOCAL
PARTNERS ON THAT.
VERY HELPFUL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE TERMS
OF ASHER.
RESEARCHER --
MAYBE I SHOULD DIRECT THIS --
TO MERE LAUDER --
ANYONE COULD GET ANSWERED
BECAUSE YOU'RE GONNA TO REBUILD
HOMES AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
COMPONENTS TO BUILDING HOMES
THAT WERE DISCOURAGING THE USE
OF GAS FOR COOKING.
SO YOU'RE ALL EXTRICITY.
AND YOU'VE GOT ALL KINDS OF FUN
DEVICES THAT --
YOU NEED TO HAVE POWER.
FOR AND SO THE CULPRIT IT SEEMS
TO ME WAS HIGH.
SUPER WHIMS AND POOR.
UTILITY POLES OF MINES AND
CONNECTORS [inaudible]
SO.
THE OFTEN ROOMS P. JEANNIE AND
THEIR CHAPTER ELEVEN BANKRUPTCY
SO -- WHAT
RECOMMENDATIONS DO YOU HAVE WE
HAVE COMMUNITIES IN MY DISTRICT
THAT YOU DON'T SEE POWER POLES
THERE EVERYTHING'S UNDERGROUND
IT IT'S ALL?
YOU DON'T SEE A A WIRE ANYWHERE
IN THE SKY SO I'M JUST WONDERING
IS AT I I THINK IN THE END
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
THAT IN IN PARADISE.
I DON'T KNOW HOW PRACTICAL IT IS
IN AND THAT WITH THE TERRAIN
THAT WE HAVE WITH LAVA
CAPTIVATED THE GEOGRAPHY IT'S A
TREMENDOUSLY EXPENSIVE WHO'S
GOING TO PAY FOR IT --
WELL WE'RE GOING TO PAY FOR IT
AND MAKES THE REBUILDING PROCESS --
MORE DIFFICULT I THINK OF THE S. --
NO POWER LINES --
BUT I THINK WE HAVE --
TO ACCEPTED THERE'S GONNA BE
SOME THAT --
IF WE GET THESE TREE HARDEN ONES
IN AND THEY DO A BETTER JOB OF
IT -- THAT
WOULD CERTAINLY BE AN
IMPROVEMENT BUT THE REALITY IS
THIS FIRE WAS FROM THOSE HIGH KV
A LINES THAT YOU SEE.
A L. ACROSS THE COUNTRY THE
RANCH I'M LIVING ON IN MY
TRAILER NOW --
TO BE GRANTED A FRIEND OF MINE
OWNS HAS FOUR OF THOSE MAJOR
TRANSMISSION LINES RUNNING
THROUGH THE PROPERTIES --
BUT WILL FAMILIAR AND BUT THAT'S
WHERE THE POWER THAT'S WHERE THE
THE FAILURE WAS --
IN THE P. JEANNIE SYSTEM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I'M GONNA DO SOME RAPID FIRING
AND ASK IF OUR PANELISTS WOULD
MIND RESPONDING QUICKLY.
FIRST OF ALL --
SO BUILDING OFFICIALS HAVE
DISCRETION TO BETTER --
I APPROVE REBUILDS --
BASED OFF THE STANDARD WHEN THAT
HOME WAS BUILT.
AND THERE'S BEEN NO [inaudible]
NO.
BASED ON THE STANDARD OF THE
CODE IN AFFECTED THE TIME THANK
YOU EACH PERMIT TO BE
INTERMEDIATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
CLARIFICATION SO --
SHOULD THERE BE FLEXIBILITY LIKE
THAT -- WITH
IN -- THE
WILL WE WELL THAT'S THE DEBATE
THAT'S AHEAD OF US I AM NO NO I
KNOW PERSONALLY I DON'T THINK SO
I THINK WE OUGHT TO BE GOING
WITH THAT THE TOUGHER STANDARD.
IN MAKING OUR HARDENING THE
STRUCTURES IN THE FIRE ZONE SOME
CELLS ARE THAT'S WHERE THE
BATTLE IS IS I BELIEVE ONE OF
THE BATTLES IS AT ON THE
BUILDING BY BUILDING.
PARTIAL BY PARTIAL LEVEL.
AND SO THOSE ARE THE STANDARDS I
THINK THAT SHOULD BE.
TIGHTENED THANK YOU REST OF THE
PANEL.
IT A DATE EVERY PROVISIONED.
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY FOR THE FIRE
CONSIDER MOST FAMILIAR WITH MY
WORLD.
EVERY PROVISION WITHIN A FIRE
CODE IS SOMETHING THAT WAS
GENERATED BECAUSE SOMETHING BAD
HAPPENED TO SOMEBODY YOU KNOW
FROM ADAM HAVING STRICT
REGULATIONS FOR ASSEMBLY
OCCUPANCIES. TO RESIDENTIAL
SPRINKLER SYSTEM RESIDENT NO
INDIVIDUAL IS DIED IN A
SPRINKLER RESIDENTIAL OCCUPANCY
I MEAN THAT'S NOT SOMETHING HAS
BEEN A TOPIC OF CONVERSATION.
AS WE BRING THE RESIDENTIAL
SPRINKLER SYSTEMS TO THE
FOREFRONT YOU KNOW HIGH PILED
STORAGE IN WAREHOUSES IS WE ARE
NOT ALLOWED BECAUSE OF THE THE
DENSITY OF MATERIALS INCLUDED
INTO IT SO THAT A SPRINKLER
EITHER COULDN'T CONTROL IT.
OR IF THERE WAS NO SPRINKLER
BECAUSE IT WAS DEVELOPED IT WAS
EXISTING --
NONCONFORMING TYPE OF A
STRUCTURE AN INABILITY TO GET
THE STREAMS TO THE BACK BUT
EVERYTHING WITHIN THE CODES HAS
BEEN DEVELOPED. TO ADDRESS
SOMETHING THAT WASN'T DONE
PROPERLY FROM SEISMIC STANDARDS
IN NEED TO EXIST AS WE LEARN
MORE WE BRING THOSE UP TO BE TO
BE NO SO THE STRUCTURES CAN BE.
MORE HARD AND DID REALLY TO KEEP
OUR PEOPLE SAFE TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE TO KEEP OUR
BUSINESS IS SAFE.
AND SO TO GO BACK AND LOOK AT A
PREVIOUS CODE IT'S TAKING.
KNOWLEDGE THAT WE'VE GAINED
SINCE ACT CODE WAS ADOPTED IN
JUST REGARDING THAT ADVANCE OF
KNOWLEDGE AND I THINK YOU KNOW
IF YOU'RE.
THE POINT TODAY I THINK IT IT'S
YOU KNOW WE WE NEED TO ADVOCATE.
FOR YOU KNOW THE MODERN
STANDARDS WERE THERE YOU KNOW
WHERE THERE COULD BE FLEXIBILITY
I THINK WAS MENTIONED IS YOU
KNOW MAYBE SOME OF THE THE
ENERGY YOU KNOW COMPONENTS OF
YOU KNOW OF THE ASPECT OF THE
CODE WITH YOU KNOW WITH REGARD --
TO WE KNOW THINGS WOULD MAKE
THAT HOME MORE EFFICIENT I MEAN
IF WE WERE LOOKING TO MAY TRY TO
MAKE SOME CONSTRUCTION
POTENTIALLY.
LESS EXPENSIVE BUT I DON'T KNOW
IF THAT'S THE DIRECTION THEN THE
THEN THE LIFE SAFETY STANDARDS
YEAH AND THAT'S THAT'S FOR I
KNOW.
OUR COMMITTEES BEEN FOCUSING ON
A ARE THOSE LIKE SAFETY
STANDARDS AND THERE'S SOME REAL
CONCERN.
PARTICULARLY WHAT WE KNOW NOW --
IN WHAT WE SEEN ON THE GROUND
WHY WE WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
DISCRETION.
IF WE KNOW THE CITY CENTERS ARE
TRUE THE GOING TO SAVE LIVES
THIS PRESIDENT THANK YOU WANT TO
BE A SAYS.
YES I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT AB.
ALL THE STANDARDS THEY WERE
LOOKING AT TODAY [inaudible]
THERE.
NOT ONLY ARE YOU LOOKING AT HOW
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR SAFE
COMMUNITIES SAFER IN YOUR
RESIDENTS SAFER BUT THE
FIREFIGHTERS AND THE POLICE NEED
TO BUILD YOUR JOB.
AND BY HAVING THESE PLANS
IMPLEMENTED AND ENFORCED IT
GIVES US THE OPPORTUNITY TO GO
AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE NOW WHEN-THE WINDS BLOWING SEVENTY EIGHTY
MILES AN HOUR IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT.
BUT WHAT'S MORE DIFFICULT FOR US
IS WHEN WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE ACCESS AND
EGRESS POINTS ON A ROAD.
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH FUEL.
AROUND A HOUSE THAT'S BEEN
ELIMINATED SO THAT WE CAN GO IN
AND DO OUR JOB.
AND SO WHAT I ASK IS THAT
WHATEVER WE DO GOING FORWARD.
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY IN THE RESIDENCE IT'S
ABOUT ALLOWING THIS THE
FIREFIGHTERS IN OUR STATE POLICE
OFFICERS ENTER STATE DO OUR JOB
IN DOOM SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY.
THANK YOU IS PRESENT.
WHEN I GO TO KEEP IN MIND --
YOU'VE SEEN IN YOUR CAREER --
THE SEVERITY OF FIRE CHANGE
SIGNIFICANTLY.
ARE GOING FROM BAD TO WORSE.
SO WHAT CONCERNS HAVE YOU DO YOU
HAVE FROM WHERE YOU SEEN THE WAY
THESE FIRES TO BURN.
IN THE WAY COMMITTEES HAVE BEEN
DEALT.
ARE THAT WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THESE COMMUNITIES IF NOT MORE
ALL OVER THE STATE THAT ARE JUST
WAITING TO BURN AND THE FACT
THAT EVERY YEAR IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS IT CONTINUES TO GET WORSE
JUST AS I THINK TIED OTHERS SAID
HEY WE THOUGHT WE HAD A CAREER.
FIRE WHEN WE WERE AT THE CEDAR
FIRE IN TWO THOUSAND THREE EVERY
YEAR SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
WE WERE SEEING CAREER FIRES AND
THAT THAT'S WHAT CONCERNS ME THE
MOST.
WE HAVE ALL OF THIS AGAIN WE
TALK ABOUT LEGACY.
EVEN IF YOU FORGOT ABOUT THE NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS WE HAVE A
LIABILITY SITTING OUT THERE IN
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND STRUCTURES HAVE IT'LL
STRUCTURES.
IN THE STATE RESPONSIBILITY --
ALONE THAT IS EVEN CONSIDER
THESE OTHER AREAS WITHIN THE LRA.
ALL OF THEM ARE VULNERABLE AND
AS TIES WERE TO CONTINUE TO
EXPOSE FIREFIGHTERS IN THE
PUBLIC. TO THESE KIND OF
CONDITIONS AND WE HAVE TO FIND A
WAY TO TURN THE CORNER.
I'M LOOKING BACK AND TAKING CARE
OF WHAT WE'VE GOT NOW IN OWNING
UP TO THE CHALLENGE.
WHATEVER THAT MIGHT BE I'M ALL
ABOUT INCENTIVES IN RE DIRECTING.
HAZARD MITIGATION MONEY FROM
FEMA RE DIRECTING AND I KNOW
THAT FORTY FIVE DAY PLAN TALKS
ABOUT LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN
INVEST.
IN SOME OF THESE RETROFITS WE
HAVE TO FIND A PLAN --
AND IT THERE MAY HAVE TO BE SOME
TO THE FIREMAN'S. TO GET SOME OF
THIS MONEY TO ENSURE THAT IT
HAPPENS BUT WE'VE GOT TO FIND
SOME WAYS. TO HELP HOMEOWNERS
MAKE THESE CHANGES --
SO THAT WE CAN START YOU KNOW
IMPROVING BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
BIRD THIS YEAR LAST YEAR TO FOR
QUESTIONS ON THAT SO --
WERE SEEN HOW FAR THOSE
IMMERSIVE IMPLYING AND THAT'S
WHAT'S BEEN CATCHING WE SAW THAT --
IN PARADISE WE SAW THAT IN SANTA
ROSA -- SO
THE BEST WAY TO BE ABLE TO
MITIGATE THAT HAS A WHAT THE
MAYOR SAID IS THE SAME THING
THAT WE SAW SANTA ROSA ONCE THAT
THING GOT GOING.
THERE'S NO STOPPING IT WITH THE
EMBER CAST IS WHAT'S REALLY
DRIVING THE OF THE INTERIOR
BURNING OF THE COFFEE PARK.
ALL OF YOU KNOW PARADISE REALLY
BERNAMA'S FROM THE INSIDE OUT IF
YOU WILL BECAUSE THAT WITHIN AN
HOUR THE ONLY WERE EMBERS
LANDING INSIDE.
THE COMMUNITY AND SO I I THINK
FOR OF THE GERMAN FROM VENTURA
COUNTY EARLIER TALKED ABOUT IT
WE SORT OF HAD THIS WE'VE
HISTORICALLY HAD THIS PERIMETER.
OF DEFENSE DISCUSSION AND
THOUGHT PROCESS IF WE KEEP THE
FIRE OUT OF THE EDGE OF TOWN
WE'RE GOOD WELL IT'S THAT'S
REALLY NOT THE CASE ANYMORE AND
SO WE REALLY NEED TO BE.
THINKING AND GOING INTERIOR
SUBDIVISIONS AND COMMUNITIES
THAT WE THINK.
ARE NOT IN A WILDLAND FIRE
ENVIRONMENT ARE BURNING BECAUSE
OF ORNAMENTAL VEGETATION TO
BRING BECAUSE OF BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION --
THERE WE JUST NEED TO LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN PROTECT INSIDE COFFEE
PARK IS A PERFECT EXAMPLE WE
SHOULD NEVER NONE OF US EVER
THOUGHT.
THAT WOULD BURN ON THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THE FREEWAY IN IN A
DEVELOPED SUBDIVISION BUT WHEN
WE STEP BACK AND LOOK.
YOU KNOW IN THE EARLY NINETEEN
SIXTIES THE HAMLEY FIRE ACTUALLY
DID BURN THERE IT JUST LOOKED A
LITTLE DIFFERENTLY AT THE TIME
SO.
THERE ARE SOME TOPOGRAPHICAL
FEATURES AND OTHER THING
INFLUENCED FIRE BEHAVIOR THERE
AND SO WE NEED TO GO DEEPER.
INTO WHAT WE WOULD NORMALLY
CONSIDER TO BE URBAN AREAS AND
AND DO SOME MORE ANALYSIS TO
ENSURE BURKE CATCHING ALL OF
THESE THESE FIRE PRONE AREAS.
WE WE PUT A LOT OF WAY ON HAZARD
MITIGATION DOLLARS.
BUT THOSE ARE THE EASIEST TO BE
TO DEAL WITH --
THE AND IT HAPPENS AFTER
INCIDENT ANY COULD HAPPEN --
WERE STILL SEEN DOLLARS THEY
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED FROM TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN IN THE VALLEY
FIRE.
SO.
IS THAT REALLY A RELATED TO
CHIEF DO YOU THINK THAT'S A
REALISTIC APPROACH.
WELL I THINK IF WE DON'T
CONTINUES PURSUE THAT YOU KNOW
WILL BE REMISS BUT NO IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE THE ONLY SINGLE
ANSWER WE CAN BE TO LOOK AT
OTHER YOU KNOW FUNDING SOURCES.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'S JUST A
GOVERNMENT PROBLEM EITHER I
THINK WE NEED TO BE THINKING AND
OTHER ENTREPRENEURIAL WAYS TO
GET SOME OF THIS WORK.
DONE AND I FOR THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY TALKED ABOUT TODAY AND
OTHERS THIS IS IT ITIS GOING TO
TAKE ALL.
EFFORTS --
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE SECTOR
FUNDING SOURCES AND INCENTIVES
AND SOME REQUIREMENTS BECAUSE I
WOULD OWN THESE HOMES HAVE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY TOO BUT YOU JUST
CAN'T EXPECT A HOMEOWNER TO COME
IN AND WANT TO MAKE A TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR INVESTMENT
IN THEIR HOME TODAY --
TO MAKE IT FIRE SAFE I MEANS
WE'VE GOT TO FIND WAYS TO
INCENTIVIZE THAT AND IT'S GOING
TO TAKE.
ME A MULTIPLE SOURCES OF FUNDING
VARIOUS LEVELS.
THE AND COME BACK TO WHERE IS
SINCE THIS IN THE PLANNING
COMMUNITY WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
WITH FIRE MARSHALS AS WELL --
ON NOT ALLOWING FOR LOCAL
DISCRETION WITHIN THE WILL HE
IT'S A CLUSTER.
WELL.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN THE LAND
USE PROCESS LIKE WHEN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE LOCAL HAS MAGIC
MITIGATION PLAN.
AND GETTING INTO THE GENERAL
PLAN THAT'S WERE WE THEN ENGAGE
WITH THE PUBLIC IN THE PUBLIC
POLLS IN LAW ENFORCEMENT FIRE AS
WELL AS THE COMMUNITY.
AND THAT'S WE HAVEREALLY HARD
FOUGHT COMMUNITY MEETINGS AND WE
IDENTIFY PRIORITIES AND GROWTH
AREAS ALL THOSE.
NO NO TRAIN WRECK BUT THEN IT
BUILDING OFFICIALS DON'T WANT TO
STAY DAY TO TAKE THAT DISCUSSION
AWAY.
AND IN SO FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS AND BILLS THAT
HAVE MOVED IN THE PAST. TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS --
WE CAN'T --
IN AGAIN NOT AT ALL FROM DOESN'T
OFFICIALS ANY THE BUS BECAUSE
THEY'RE FANTASTIC.
AND I JUST LIKE THE LEGISLATURE --
A LOT OF OPINIONS I IN ANY TIME.
THERE SIGNIFICAN CERTAIN SO --
HOW DO WE DRIVE THAT?
AND AND I APPRECIATE AND
POIGNANT SPONSOR AND THANK YOU
I'M NOT A BUILDING OFFICIAL SO
IT'S OKAY NO I AM.
BUT BUT IT'S TRUE LIKE WITHIN
WITHIN YOUR SHOP THOUGH YEAH
RIGHT.
YOUR FOLKS ARE SAYING THAT THERE
ARE SOME THAT WILL SAY WELL IT
SHOULD BE UP TO LOCALS.
I IN SOME THAT SAY AS YOU JUST
SAID IS WE NEED TO BE TAKEN
THOSE NEW STANDARDS WHAT WE JUST
HEARD FROM THE CHIEF AND FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
SO HOW DO WE DRIVE CONSENSUS WE
KNOW THAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
WELL TOUGH QUESTION I THINK THAT
THE THE GENERALLY SPEAKING YOUR
BUILDING OFFICIALS ARE GOING TO
BE HARD.
ADVOCATES FOR A TOUGH BUILDING
CODE AND I THINK IT'S ONLY AS
THE THE PRESSURE COMES ON THEM
INDIVIDUALLY LIKE CASE BY CASE
WERE YOU SEE THEN THOSE.
TOUGH DISCUSSIONS HAPPEN ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL OF ALLOWANCES AND
THINGS LIKE THAT SO I THINK THAT
GENERALLY SPEAKING THERE THEY'RE
NOT THE PROBLEM THEY'RE NOT IN
THE WAY OF IN FORCING A TOUGH
BUILDING CODE.
WE HAD SOME CHALLENGES BUT OKAY
BUT I'M GONNA SAY THAT AND I
KNOW THAT ISN'T THAT WERE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT THIS
YEAR BECAUSE I LOOK.
IF WE TAKE A LOOK AT THE LOW
HANGING FRUIT THE NO BRAINER
THERE'S NO WAY IN HELL THAT WE
SHOULD BE ALLOWING
RECONSTRUCTION AT A LESSER
STANDARD ESPECIALLY WHEN IT
COMES A WHOLE HOME HARDENING.
I AGREE TO CHIEF THERE MAY BE
SOME THE FLEXIBLE ON BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO MAKING YOUR HOME MORE
RESILIENT ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
IN THE WILL HE WHY ARE WE EVEN
HAVING THIS DEBATE.
CHIEF IT JUST JUST TO CLARIFY
THAT.
THE STATE ADOPTED CODE LOCALS
CAN ONLY BE MORE STRINGENT WE
CAN'T BE LESS STRINGENT SO WE
CAN'T BE MORE LENIENT WE CAN
DISREGARD.
WHAT THE STATE CODE SAYS WE NEED
TO DO WITH THE PROVISION THERE
IS A PROVISION IN THE CODE TO
GIVES US A LITTLE BIT DISCRETION
IS CALLED ALTERNATIVE MEANS AND
METHODS?
BUT THAT NEEDS TO BE
DEMONSTRATED THAT WHAT YOU'RE
GOING TO DO MAYBE TWO LAYERS OF
SHEET ROCK ON A WALL TO INCREASE
THE FIRE RATING IN A PARTICULAR
ROOM WELL THAT'S FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION FOR FOR
RECONSTRUCTION YOU CAN GO BACK
THOUGH IT WHAT RICANS WILL THE
DISCOUNT WE HAVE.
IS EXISTING NON CONFORMING I WE
HAVE A LOT OF THAT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES MEANING.
IT WAS A COMPLIANT WITH IT WELL
WE WOULD HOPE LET'S LET'S GO
WITH THE ASSUMPTION THAT THE THE
HOME WAS BUILT OVER THE
DOCUMENTS HE WAS BUILT. TO THE
CODE THAT EXISTED THE TIME THE
PERMIT WAS PULLED AND SO IF THAT
BUILDING HAS NOT GONE THROUGH A
TENANT IMPROVEMENT OR REMODEL A
NEW PERMIT PULLED SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IT
COMPLIES WITH WHATEVER NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO CODE THAT EXISTED
THERE NOT SPRING CLEARED DO YOU
KNOW AND A LOT OF THE THE OTHER
PIECES THAT'S THE CHALLENGEBUT
YEAH HOW DO YOU GO BACK IN AND
TALK ABOUT SOME A MAYBE.
MAYBE SOME OF THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS AND SOME OF THE
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT ESPECIALLY FOR THAT
STUFF IN THE IN THE WE WE AND AS
FAR MOTION ORGAN POINT OUT THE
V. ESTIMATED TO DO GRANT PRO SO
THAT TO CREATE. TO GET THOSE
THEIR VOCAL BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO GO BACK IN
AND FORCE A CO DIRECTOR OF
RETROACTIVE ENFORCEMENT.
OF OF OF A MORE MODERN CODE --
ALTHOUGH IT WOULD BE A COULD
CERTAINLY BE HELPFUL IN SUMMER
GARDEN IN THAT'S BEEN SOME OF
THE DEBATE THAT WE'VE HAD IT
WITHIN OUR COMMITTEE CAN SOME
SAY -- THAT.
LOCALS DO BUT I I HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE NEEDS THE
MONEY PUT ON THE TABLE I A FOR
SERIOUS ABOUT MAKING A
COMMITTEES MORE SO I THINK WORK
TO KIDA NIBBLING AT IS THAT YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE CAN WE IF
SOMEONE'S REMODELING.
A KITCHEN CAN WE REQUIRE THEM TO
PUT ON BETTER COVERS OR EVEN
COVERS AND RIGHT NOW NO IS THE
ANSWER UNLESS THERE WAS
LEGISLATION.
THAT REQUIRED THAT OR OR USE
THAT AS ONE IS ONE OF THE
STRATEGIES ONE OF THE TOOLS AND
TOOL BELT TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
MORE SAFE FROM FIRE SAY
PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU.
CHIEF DID YOU WANNA CHALLENGES
HE WAS JUST IT'S ALMOST THREE
QUESTION BACK BUT IT'S THE
CONCERNED IT'S IT'S IT MAKES NO
IT IT'S A NO BRAINER TO ME TO DO
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING WHY
SHOULD WE GO BACKWARDS IN AND AS
SHE WOULD OFTEN TALKED ABOUT WE
WANT THERE. TO REASON THE CODES
ARE UPDATED BECAUSE WE LEARNED
WHAT ISN'T WORKING WILL LEARN
FROM THESE FIRES AFTER THE
DAMAGE IS NOT WHAT WE NEED TO DO
IN THE FUTURE TO MAKE CHANGES.
YOU KNOW THAT PART I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANY ARGUMENT.
GO BACK OUT TO THESE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THESE KINDS OF LAWS AND
ORDINANCES CAN BE VERY MUCH
ARTICULATED AS SLOW GROWTH --
LOW GROWTH THEIR GROWTH
INHIBITORS HOW TO GO BACK TO
COMMUNITIES AND SAY IT'S GOING
TO COME I'VE OWNED THIS PROPERTY
FOR FORTY YEARS NOW YOU'RE
TELLING ME.
IT'S GOING TO COST TWICE AS MUCH
MONEY TO REBUILD.
MY HOUSE UNDER THESE NEW
STANDARDS SO THE PRESSURE.
IS ALWAYS ON EVERYONE TO TRY TO
REDUCE THAT TO BRING THE ECONOMY
BACK IN SO HOW DO WE BALANCE
THAT.
THAT CONVERSATION.
I THINK YOU HAVE TO THE RIGHT
NORMAL THE WAY WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO THAT REDWOOD VALLEY FOR
EXAMPLE SUBURBAN VALLEY IN THE
MINUTES YOU KNOW --
THE REDWOOD AB COMPLEX FIRES
BURNED DOWN A THIRD OF THE WATER
SYSTEM DISINTEGRATED --
WE HAVE TO BE TO RE BUILD TO
STANDARD PIPES AREN'T BIG ENOUGH
I'D BE ABLE TO COMPLY WITH NEW
BUILDING CODE FOR FIRE
SPRINKLERS.
STATE REASONS AND HAZARD
MITIGATION DOLLARS AT FEMA IS
ADVANCING --
IN A QUICKER FASHION.
IN THE STATE HAD TO PUT
ADDITIONAL TWO MILLION IN.
THE PROJECT BUT AGAIN TO BE ABLE
TO GET THEM THERE WE HAD TO BE
ABLE TO GET THEM MAJORITY THE
MONEY.
ON THE TABLE I THINK THAT'S
WHERE AND PLEASE CORRECT ME IF
I'M WRONG THIS FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND CHIEF --
THE PLANNER HERE IS ALL ST IT'S
AN BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO BE TO
PUT SOME INCENTIVES ON THE TABLE
TO BE TO MAKE IT WORK CORRECT.
MISTER PRESIDENT I KNOW HE DID
YOU HAVE ONE OTHER ITEM THE ONES
I OKAY [inaudible] FIVE BEFORE
WE WRAP IT UP WITH A BETTER TURN
OVER DISINGENUOUS AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANY URGENCY [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY ON BEHALF OF
CENTER CERTAIN ENTIRE OF BOTH
COMMITTEES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY REALLY REALLY GREAT
FOR THE ALL OF YOUR HERE.
NICE JOB THE WORKING THE PHONE
UP WITH EACH WEEK THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO BE OPEN IT UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I WANT TO SAY
THANKS TO ALL OF YOU FOR HANGING
WITH US.
TODAY -- IN
WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO INVITE YOU
TO BE ABLE TO COME FORWARD IF
YOU DON'T MIND JUST GIVE US YOUR
FIRST.
NAME IN YOUR ORGANIZATION WE
WELCOME YOU HAVE YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND I'LL GIVE YOU ONE
MINUTE PROMPT.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
IS THIS MICROPHONE ON IT IS ARE
GOOD TO GO THANK YOU CHAIR IN
MEMBER -- MY
NAME IS KELLY COVERAGE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND WANTED THANK YOU.
JERRY MCGUIRE AND ALSO CHAIR
STERN FOR ASSEMBLING --
THIS PANEL OF EXPERTS FOR THIS
VERY IMPORTANT AND TIMELY
DISCUSSION.
OTHER REALTORS LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS THE HARDENING AND
PROTECTION OF EXISTING HOMES.
IN THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
AS WELL AS THOSE HOMES LOCATED
DEEP IN THE HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES.
I WOULD LIKE TO ECHO POINT MADE
BY CHIEF RICH WINE EARLIER TODAY
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMMUNITY WIDE HARDENING EFFORTS.
HARDENING PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS ON
TRIGGERING EVENTS FOR INDIVIDUAL
HOMES WILL NOT INSURE THE SAFETY
OF THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING ON
SOLUTIONS THAT SAFETY AND
RESILIENCE THROUGH GREATER
COOPERATION AND INCENTIVES THANK
YOU.
I THINK YOU SO MUCH AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR HANGING WITH US
TODAY AS WELL.
GOOD LUCK WITH THE LAST CALL FOR
FOLKS WHO LIKE TO BECOME A AND
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT IF YOU
COULD PLEASE COME FOR THE
MICROPHONE.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE --
AND AS YOU CAN TELL WE'VE HAD A
LONG HEARING --
DO WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO EACH
AND EVERY ONE OF OUR PANELISTS
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR
STERN IN THE ENTIRE NATURAL
RESOURCES WATER COMMITTEE --
FOR WORKING IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
US SCRIVENS ALWAYS GOOD TO SEIZE
HER IN GREAT JOB WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE GENTLEMAN TO MY
LEFT HIS NAME IS ANTON HE'S DONE
A FABULOUS JOB ON THE ORGANIZING
GETAN FOLKS HERE --
ANTON AS USUAL NICE WORK IN
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
YOUR EFFORTS I WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH AT THE CHAIR CHAIR STERN --
ON POTENTIAL RECOMMENDATIONS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD HERE IN THE
COUNTY YEAR AND AGAIN THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED